WILL COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE.
EXTRAORDINARY BUT NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FAR MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY ARE SENATOR STERN. AND WE
ASK IF YOU HAVE A STAFF PERSON
WITH YOU SENATOR TO PLEASE
IDENTIFY THAT STAFF FOR NOW
GOOD MORNING SENATOR STERN.
MORNING YEAH I'M HERE AND I
HAVE- JEREMY WILL CURE MY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RIGHT. SENATORS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE FOR OUR MUTUAL
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. ARE IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. AND
ONCE RECOGNIZE. PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN THEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL USE A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESSCODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND.
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR I'LL REPEAT
THAT NUMBER THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SIX ONE ONE ONE. ONE SEVEN NINE
AGAIN. THE ACCESS CODE IS. SIX
ONE ONE ONE ONE SEVEN NINE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE. AND THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESSURES ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE AND MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
HOWEVER INSIST THAT WE MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING OUR HEARINGS AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICES OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT OKAY ARE THE MICROPHONE
MUTE AND UNMUTE MYSELF WHAT. TO
TALK. THAT'S TRUE BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T THEY ALL RIGHT. HERE ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT WELL. THAT WAS
INTERESTING OKAY THIS IS
PROBABLY NOT GONNA BE DAHLE.
AND THEY'LL PROBABLY BE SOME
GLITCHES BUT- AGAIN I ASK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR OF
RESPECTFUL UNDERSTANDING-
BECAUSE THIS IS NEW TO MOST
PEOPLE AND- CERTAINLY NEW TO ME.
ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE BEGIN I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME SENATOR
MELENDEZ WHO IS SITTING TO MY
LEFT BUT THAT'S PROBABLY THE
ONLY TIME. SHALL EVER BE
DESCRIBED AS BEING TO MY LEFT.
BUT WE ARE HAPPY THANK YOU AND
WELCOME TO OUR COMMITTEE
SENATOR MELINDA'S. WE HAVE
NINETEEN BILLS ON OUR AGENDA
pCONSENT AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHORS AND
COMMITTEE- AND STAFF- TO PUT
THOSE ITEMS IN THE FORM WHERE
THEY CAN BE CONSENT ITEMS TODAY.
BUT BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION
ON THOSE BILLS SO I WOULD LIKE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHEN. I MEAN FACT SEND HERE
JACKSON HERE FOR JESS. AND IT
MAY I ADMIRE ASKED THAT WE MAKE
SURE BECAUSE THIS HAS TO BE
CLEAR TO EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM
AND WATCHING. FOR YOU SPEAK
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
SO THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY YOU
SPECIFICALLY PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU CENTER BORCHERS LARGEST
PRESENT DO WRESTLED HERE. WITH
US SO HERE. GONZALEZ MICRON
HERE ONE SALAS HERE MELENDEZ
HERE MELENDEZ HERE MORNING HERE
MONEY HERE STERN. PRESIDENT
HASN'T REMOTELY I'M BURKE. WHY
CAL SKINNER WAY CASKEY HERE-
MADAM CHAIR YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU MADAM CONSULTANT.
MADAM CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR VERY
GOOD- WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE US THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE ON THE
CALENDAR. FOR CONSENT. FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
NOT A NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE. FILE
ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAANSHAN. FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL. FILE NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG FILE ITEM
TEN. AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIND TRYING.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE WITH
AMENDMENTS. AND FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU WITH
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THAT CALENDAR MADE BY SENATOR
MELENDEZ. MADAM CONSULTANT TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATORS
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. JACKSON HI
JACKSON BY FOR JESS BY FORGES I
DID AWESOME. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ I
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE STERN.
NINE STERN I BURKE HI I'M BURKE
I WHY CAL SKENEIDAE Y. HOUSE
SKI I TO OUR SIX YOU HAVE EIGHT
VOTES AND LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
INDEED WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPENED FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE VOTE IS EIGHT TWO ZERO AT
THIS POINT IN TIME AND NOW WE
WILL START WITH OUR FIRST
AUTHOR. IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA WITH US TODAY. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE ON HIS BEHALF OUR
MEMBER THE SENATOR CAN SOLVE
THIS GONZALEZ WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR HIM GOOD MORNING
SENATOR GONZALEZ THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE A. B. EXCUSE ME FILE
ITEM TO A. B. NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN YOU ARE PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
AND TO FEEL FREE TO PROCEED
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN EXTENDS THE FILING
DEADLINE FOR RETALIATION CLAIMS
FOR THE DIVISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT DLS SEE
FROM SIX MONTHS TO ONE YEAR NOW
OUT FROM LAST YEAR'S AB FOUR OH
THREE FROM TWO YEARS TO ADDRESS
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
ALLOWS RECOVERY OF ATTORNEYS
FEES TO PREVAILING EMPLOYEES
AND ONLY APPLIES FOR WHISTLE
BLOWER RETALIATION CLAIMS
RETALIATION IS NOT ONLY
PERVASIVE BUT ALSO A GROWING
PROBLEM. DUE TO THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE SURROUNDING
IMMIGRATION AND THE LAST FOUR
YEARS OF AVAILABLE DATA FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IMMIGRATION RELATED
RETALIATION CLAIMS FILED WITH
THE T. L. S. E. INCREASED BY
NEARLY 2000% AMID THE PANDEMIC
ADVOCATES REPORT AN INCREASE IN
CALLS REGARDING HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES AND WE JUST UP
AND MISS CLASSIFICATION. IT IS
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER THAT WE
INSURE ALL LEGAL AND- AVENUES
ARE AVAILABLE FOR WORKERS WHO
COME FORWARD. THE TWO MAIN
BARRIERS WORKERS SPACE TO
FILING A CLAIM ARE DRESSED IN
THIS BILL. FIRST WORKERS WHO
HAVE FACED RETALIATION
ESPECIALLY IN EXTREME FORMS OF
TERMINATION OR VIOLENCE NEED
MORE TIME TO GATHER THE
RESOURCES AND SEEK ASSISTANCE.
A SIMPLE SIX MONTH EXTENSION
FOR FILING A WORKER RETALIATION
CLAIM WILL GIVE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER THEIR
LIVELIHOOD AND THEN. THEIR NEXT
STEPS FOR RECOURSE. AB NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN ALSO BUILD UPON
EXISTING ABILITIES FOR COURTS
TO WORK REASONABLE ATTORNEY'S
FEES TO ATTORNEYS WHO TAKE
THESE CASES ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS. THIS IS NOT A BILL
INTENDED TO INCREASE LITIGATION
AS THE OPPOSITION ARGUES RATHER
IT IS. IT PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL SENSIBLE AND
REASONABLE WAY FOR LOW WAGE
WORKERS TO PURSUE RECOURSE WHEN
IT UNFAIRLY TALLY IT AGAINST
FOR INVOKING THE RIGHTS UNDER
STATE LAW. WITH TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IS
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ FROM CHIRLA
AND MEDICAL SO HE HADA WITH.
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FERNANDO.
THANK YOU ARE. SENATOR WE HAVE.
I BELIEVE TWO WITNESSES- AND
ARE THEY BOTH INTENDED TO BE ON
THE LINE TALKING REMOTELY YES
AND ARE THEY AVAILABLE. AFTER
YES HELLO AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS MERRY
GO YOSHI HARDEN THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
I'M ARE LAWYERS LIKE MANY OF
YOU I'M SURE- ARE HEARING FROM
SO MANY WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE WHO FEEL UNSAFE AT WORK
BECAUSE THEIR EMPLOYERS NOT
TAKING PROPER PRECAUTIONS TO
PROTECT THEM FROM BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN. AND THE LEGISLATURE
IS WORKING ON ANY OF THE BILL
TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION THAT
HELPS STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS
FOR OUR ITS CENTRAL WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE RIGHT ACTION
THAT WE PUT IN PLACE FOR
WORKERS REALLY MEAN NOTHING IF
THEY CAN BE FIRED RETALIATED
AGAINST FOR TRYING TO A THIRD
THOSE RIGHT OR ASK FOR THOSE
PROTECTION. THE REALITY OF MANY
WORKERS. SPEAK OUT BECAUSE WE
SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE
THEIR JOB ESPECIALLY IN THIS
ECONOMY. I REMEMBER THOSE
WORKERS WHO DO SPEAK OUT AND DO
FACE RETALIATION SIX MONTHS
DOES NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR THEM
FILE CLAIMS LABOR. THAT. WILL
HELP INSURE THAT THESE WERE
DON'T LOSE THEIR- BY GIVING
THEM AND SIX. OF THEIR CAR. ON
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN WILL. HELP
WORKER THE TICKET. LOW WAY.
IMMIGRANT WORK TO GET
ASSISTANCE. FOR WHAT THE LOWER
RETALIATION CLAIM BECAUSE IT
WILL ALLOW THOSE RECOVERS
WORKERS TO RECOVER THEIR
ATTORNEY. THE NEXT. RIGHT NOW
I'M LIKE MOST THE END FEDERAL
WHISTLEBLOWER STATUTE THERE IS
NO ATTORNEY P. PROVISION WHICH
MEANS THE WORKER HALF THE PAY
THEIR LEGAL FEES THROUGH A
PORTION OF THEIR RECOVERY. OR
ELSE FIND AN ATTORNEY TO TAKE
THE CASE FOR FREE. I'M AT THE
RECENT NEW YORK TIMES EDITORIAL
POINTED OUT ALLOWING WORKERS TO
RECOVER THEIR ATTORNEY FEES IF
THEY PREVAILED DOES NOT
INCENTIVIZE FRIVOLOUS
LITIGATION BECAUSE OF COURSE
THE LAWYER GET NOTHING I'M NOT
THEY WENT. MICHAEL WILL LOSE
ALL THE THEY PUT INTO A INTO
WORKING ON A CASE IF THE CLAIM
HAS NO MERIT IN REALITY
ALLOWING THE RECOVERY OF
ATTORNEY FEES REALLY PROVIDES
MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE BECAUSE LOWER WAGE
WORKERS CAN PAY THEIR LEGAL
FEES REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEY
END UP RECOVERY. AND THEIR
AWARD WHICH IS OFTEN TIED TO
THE WAGES. THIS BILL. WILL HELP
INSURE MORE WORKERS ABLE TO
ENFORCE THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE
LABOR CODE WHICH WE KNOW IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO MANY
WORKERS ARE RISKING THEIR LIVES
DURING AND THAT MAKE. THE FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE IS. THE SECOND
WITNESS AVAILABLE AND I AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT RE OF. THE
RULES WE ARE GIVING THREE
MINUTES TO EACH SIDE THAT WAS
TWO MINUTES SO IF WE HAVE A
WITH US THE- OTHER WITNESS
MISTER SANCHEZ. ON THE LINE
WE'LL GIVE YOU A MINUTE TO-
PRESENT YOUR REMARKS ARE YOU
WITH US MISTER SANCHEZ. MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU MY APOLOGIES
BUT I WANT TO BE CONSISTENT SO
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND ASK
YOU IF YOU COULD PRESENT IN A
MINUTE. MEANING NOW BUT I FOR
ONE MINUTE. CHRIS RESPONSIBLE
CHIRLA THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET DEMERITS ORGANIZATION
DIRECTORY PREVENTING IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES DURING SOME WORKERS I
WILL TRY TO BE A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND- I'VE ALREADY
STATED WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL
MORE IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PANDEMIC.
BOB IS A RECEIVED REPORTS OF
WORKERS WHOSE WRITING DID
COMPROMISED AND PLAYERS A MENU
BUT THEY WORKING ON IT
CONDITION THE STORES ARE NO
DIFFERENT THAN THE ONES WE WERE
PART OF THE PANDEMIC THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE ABOUT THE WORK FORCE
OF THE CREATES A REPORTS
RETALIATION AND OTHER EMPLOYER
BECAUSE I MEAN CREWS. ARE FOR
TO THE WORKING WITH WHO ARE
WORKERS- NOTE WE KNOW THAT OUR
SIX MONTH IS NOT ENOUGH AND A
YEAR WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE A LOT
MORE BENEFICIAL TO IMMIGRANT
WORKERS ESPECIALLY TO COME
FORWARD ARMS TO TRUSTED
SOURCES. IF ARE- IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT SOME
CASES FROM DOCTOR ARE WORKERS
THAT WILL BE FILED WITH THE
LABOR AND ALLOW BURDEN DOCUMENT
WORKERS INSURANCE ARE
JUSTIFIABLY BE SAID ON THE
DETAILS WERE CASE. BOTTOM RIGHT
I'M AND WHICH WAS SO THE
PROTECTION SUCH AS SUPPORT OF
THIS TOP SPONSOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EXACTLY MINUTE WELL
TO. ARE NOW WE ARE GOING TO ON
TO ANYONE. WHO WISHES TO. OUR
AND WE ASK THE AT THE IN TIME
FOR THEIR- NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WITHOUT FURTHER
EXPOSITION ON THAT POSITION
WE'VE HEARD TWO WITNESSES WILL
HAVE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND AN EQUALLY TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ABLE TO PRESENTED
WITH FOR A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES. SO WHAT WE WILL DO
NOW. IS WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
OF ALL THOSE WHO ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY ARE IN THE QUEUE
WISHING TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
AGAIN LIMITING THEIR NAME THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE MEASURE EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OR WE
HAVE AN OCCASIONAL WITNESS WHO
COMES IN ITS STRONG NEUTRALITY
SO AGAIN WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO
GIVE US THAT INFORMATION AND-
LET'S GO TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROME FORTY TWO
OR THREE WHO WISH TO STAND UP
AT THE MICROPHONE. IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES OR AFFILIATION- AND
THEIR POSITION BY CHOOSING NONE
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. APPEARING TO BE NONE-
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY BE THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS- MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB IN NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE'LL WAIT
ONE MINUTE TO SEE WHO LINES UP
AND THEN I WILL ASK YOU MATTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD. IN
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS OR SO GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THIRTY SECONDS IS A
LONG TIME IS SENATE ALL RIGHT
DO YOU HAVE ANY INDICATION NOW
MADAME MODERATOR OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE THERE ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE HAVE FIVE IN Q. VERY GOOD IF
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU LINE ONE ZERO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU RIDE A ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
NOT ACOSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
COURT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU BYE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU ITEM ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JACKIE TURN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER TRADE THE CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I ONE ZERO
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHLEEN
BACK IT TOOK TO BUY IN MY
PERSONAL CAPACITY ALTHOUGH I AM
ON THE ADVISORY BOARD FOR CLEAN
CAR WASH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT MADAME MODERATOR. I
HAVE NO FOR THEIR LINES IN Q.
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD. SO ARE.
WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
TO OUR OR CHOOSE ME ONE WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION PREPARED TO SPEAK
BàN THE BANK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IS ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION IS
THAT CORRECT MYSTERY BACK. YES
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU IDENTITY
COME OUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. I WILL
NOT BELABOR THE POINT WE'VE HAD
THAT OPPOSED TO PREVIOUS
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL IN RECENT
YEARS AND TO BE BRIEF WE HAVE
NO OBJECTION TO INCREASE IN THE
STATURE LIMITATIONS FOR SUCH
CLAIMS. BUT WE CONTINUE TO BE
TO BE OPPOSED TO THE PROVISION
OF THE BILL THAT CREATES A ONE
SIDED ATTORNEY FEE PROVISION OF
THESE CLAIMS ARE FILED IN
COURT- UNLIKE THE NEW YORK
TIMES EDITORIAL WE DO THINK
THIS INCENTIVE WILL DRIVE MORE
CLAIMS TO BE FILED IN COURT
WHICH IS MORE COSTLY AN
ADVERSARIAL. IN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER PROCESS AND RAISES
THE COSTS FOR ALL SIDES FOR
THESE REASONS RECOUP WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THIS PROPOSAL AND
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY OR WHO ARE ONLINE TO
TEST FIVE WITH ABOUT A- MINUTE.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY OF TIME A
COUPLE OR ANY OTHER WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. HI TING NONE WILL
NOW OPEN THE- NINE TO AT ANY
OTHER WAY. WHO WERE TO GIVE
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. MADAME MODERATOR
COULD YOU. PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE AND- ASK FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO. SIGN ON AND TO
BE HEARD. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OUT OF
AB ONE NINE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AND EXCUSE ME MY MISTAKE I
NEED TO ASK IF THERE ANY
WITNESSES ACTUALLY PRESENT IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION ANYWAY WITNESSES
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. RIGHT SEEING NON
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE. OF MADAME MODERATOR TO
LET'S GO TO YOU AND SEE IF
THERE ANY PEOPLE ON THE LINE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AND IF SO COULD YOU
TELL US HOW MANY THERE ARE. YOU
ARE FOR IN Q. VERY GOOD LET'S
PROCEED. THANK YOU OVER TO LINE
ONE LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
CALL RIGHT CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND REACH YOUR
RESPECTFULLY ACCOUNT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES ON THE LINE
MATTER MODERATOR WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. NINE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHECKS
IS NOT FROM THE FACT THAT
INSURANCE WITH ALREADY OPPOSED
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM A
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. I HAVE A BROTHER
LIVES IN Q. AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT SO- NOW WE WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO DISCUSSION OF
WITHIN THE DYE IS HERE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
LET'S GO AHEAD AND- I BELIEVE A
SENATOR BORCHERS SHE WANTED TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I'D LIKE TO ALSO- EXPRESS A
HEARTY- CONGRATULATIONS TO OUR
NEWEST MEMBER- SENT FORMER
ASSEMBLY WOMAN MELINDA'S NOW
SENATOR MELINDA'S TO OUR FIND
COMMITTEE. I HAVE A QUESTION
AND I'M NOT CERTAIN TO WHOM I
SUPPOSE IT IS. IT'S. IF A PARTY
INITIATES SUIT OR A GRIEVANCE
ON TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
CAN AT THAT- GRIEVANCE BE
WITHDRAWN IF THE PARTIES
SETTLED THE MATTER OUTSIDE OF
THE COMMISSION SETTING. TWO WE
ED IT MADAM PRESENTER FOOD LIKE
TO SPEAK OR WE DO HAVE TO I
BELIEVE THE TO- WITNESSES
EXPERTS ON THE LINE WHO MAY BE
ABLE TO ASSIST IN ANSWERING
THAT QUESTION THE STANDARD ARE
YOU STILL ON THE LINE. SORRY.
TO HAVE MR OFF. YES MERRY GO
MERRY WHICH USED MY UNDER IS
YEAH AND IF THE IF THE MATTER
IS SETTLED THAT BIN AND THEN IT
WILL BE WITHDRAWN FROM THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S PROCESS TO
A FINANCIAL SETTLEMENT BETWEEN
THE PARTIES THAT'S REACHED-
COULD CRITICIZE TO ASIAN WHERE
THE GRIEVANCES WITHDRAWN FROM
THE LABOR COMMISSION. THAT'S
CORRECT. MY UNDERSTANDING THE
REASON THE REASON WHY I ASK
AUTO BUT IT. I'M SORRY GO AHEAD.
I KNOW GO AHEAD. THE REASON WHY
I ASK IS IN THE COURSE OF
BUSINESS I THINK WHAT IS LIKELY
TO HAPPEN. AND I WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT THE FOLKS THAT DON'T
THINK THAT PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS
FOR CONSUMER ATTORNEYS WHO
WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY. IS THAT IF IT'S
THE CASE THE ATTORNEYS FEES
COULD BE COLLECTED AND IT IS A
ONE SIDED- AS OPPOSED TO WHAT
WE LEARNED IN LAW SCHOOL THE
BRITISH RULE AND- BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND. THE BRITISH RULE IS
THAT THE PREVAILING PARTY IS
ABLE TO COLLECT NOT JUST. ON
ONE SIDE A SITUATION LIKE THIS
SO I THINK IN TERMS OF EQUITY I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WILL
LIKELY BE AN IMBALANCE OF
RESOURCES BETWEEN A LOW WAGE
EMPLOYEE VERSES EIGHT
CORPORATION I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT FOR PURPOSES OF EQUITY. IF
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE FOR
ATTORNEYS FEES- ON THE TABLE I
THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM FOLKS IN
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT ON
THEY DON'T HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE EXTENSION OF THE- STATURE
THE LIMITATIONS THEY HAVE ISSUE
WITH THE ATTORNEYS FEES AS TO
WHY SO I THINK. IF EQUITY IS
GUIDING THIS THEN I THINK IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO I'LL-
BOTH PARTIES THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT BUT HERE'S REALLY WHERE
IT'S GONNA GO I SUSPECT. IS
THAT. ONE DO WE HAVE A DEFINITE
DO WE HAVE A DEFINITION OF THE
PREVAILING PARTY IN A CIVIL
ACTION. I'M NOT CERTAIN ABOUT
LABOR CIRCUMSTANCE BUT A CIVIL
ACTION. IT COULD BE A PARTIAL
VICTORY. LAW WOULD ALLOW AN
INDIVIDUAL TO DECLARE
THEMSELVES A PREVAILING PARTY
IT COULD BE 51% OF THE ACTIONS
OR DETERMINATIONS IN ONES
FAVOR- WHATEVER THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLE IS SO I DON'T KNOW
HOW IT PERTAINS IN A LABOR-
CONTEXT OF RETALIATION WHETHER
TO ONE DETERMINED OF. JUDGMENT
ON THE ISSUE OR THURSDAY
ASSEMBLY OF DIFFERENT ISSUES SO
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT HOW YOU
WOULD COME ABOUT WITH A
PREVAILING DETERMINATION THE
PREVAILING PARTY BUT MORE
REALISTICALLY. IF WE CAN IF WE
CAN APPRECIATE THAT THESE
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE SETTLED
BY VIRTUE OF THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR- FOR THE FOR THE
ELIGIBILITY OF ATTORNEYS FEES.
I CAN EASILY SEE. ATTORNEYS
RACKING UP RETALIATION
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST AN EMPLOYER.
EMPLOYER CALCULATING THE COST
OF GOING TO TRIAL OR GOING TO A
REGULATORY BODY IN DEFENDING
ITSELF IN SIMPLY SAYING I WILL
OFFER YOU THIS TO WITHDRAW YOUR
COMPLAINT. AND THAT I THINK IS
A TERRIBLE DISINCENTIVE IN THE
WORK FORCE BECAUSE THE
CORPORATION OR THE BUSINESS
WILL SIPLYLOOK AT THE
OVERHEAD OF WHAT IT TAKES TO GO
THROUGH A REGULATORY REVIEW
WORD MINISTRY TO REVIEW. AND
JUST PAY IT OUT SO BY VOLUME
YOU COULD BE LOOKING AT
ATTORNEYS. ASSEMBLING A NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS AND HAVE THIS
BEING A CASH COW SO- I THINK I
WOULD CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
FIRST PART OF IT. I WOULD ASK
THE AUTHOR OR THE PERSON
REPRESENTING THE AUTHOR. CAN'T
WE JUST LEAVE THE FIRST PART
THERE FOR THE EXTENSION. AND
WITHDRAW THE ATTORNEY'S FEES
PORTION THAT I THINK WOULD MAKE
THIS. A BI PARTISAN IN
CERTAINLY AN ACCEPTABLE BILL IN
MY OPINION THANK YOU CENTER
PORCHES BEFORE I GO TO SENATOR
MORNING LET ME OBSERVE WE DON'T
USE THE BRITISH SYSTEM- AND
THERE'S A GOOD REASON WE DON'T
WE HAVE VERY DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
OF JUSTICE. AND IN TERMS OF THE
BALANCE OF POWER. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT CORPORATIONS.
HAVE MUCH GREATER RESOURCES AND
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO HAVE AN
ATTORNEY'S FEES PRISON
PREVENTION. MANY PARTICULAR OF
OUR LOW WAGE WORKERS HAVE NO
RESOURCES I DON'T KNOW TOO MANY
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE WILLING TO
WORK FOR FREE THESE DAYS. AND
WE CERTAINLY PULL THE PLUG ON A
LOT OF OUR LEGAL AID PROGRAMS
THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD DO THAT
SO- I THINK THAT TO. YOU'D LIKE
TO BRING A BILL PERHAPS PICTURE
THAT PUSHED MOVES US INTO THE
BRITISH SYSTEM I'M SURE THAT
THAT WOULD TO. BE SOMETHING
THAT- YOU COULD TO- I THINK THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE HERE WORKS WELL
AND THESE DIRE PREDICTIONS JUST
DON'T EVER SEEM TO HAPPEN- SO.
THE WORST CASE SCENARIO IS MORE
FICTIONAL THAN FACT AND- I
THINK WE- WE REALLY NEED TO.
RECOGNIZE THAT. LAWSUIT AND-
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EQUALIZE THE
PLAYING FIELD JUST SIMPLY DON'T
HAPPEN IF. PLAINTIFFS WHO ARE
MOST OF THEM. WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES ARE FIGHTING THE
GOLIATH OF CORPORATE AMERICA
WE'RE MANY OF THEM HAVE
STABLES. ALL FOR A- UP ON ON
SITE COUNCIL. THE RARE IN TO GO
AND VERY HAPPY TO. AND THESE
CLAIMS AND OF COURSE IF IT'S A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT AGAINST
THROWN OUT AND THERE ARE
ATTORNEYS FEES PROVISIONS LET'S
NOT FORGET. THAT THERE IS AN
INHERENT BALANCE THAT IS
CREATED WHEN YOU HAVE A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT. LAWYERS
GENERALLY WON'T TAKE A CASE
UNLESS THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS MERIT TO IT BECAUSE THEY
WON'T GET PAID. AND AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS PRACTICED LAW- YOU
DON'T. WANT TO TAKE THOSE CASES
BECAUSE THERE'S USUALLY NOT
ONLY YOUR TIME THAT IS NOT
COMPENSATED BUT OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES AS WELL. AND OF COURSE
IF A SETTLEMENT IS REACHED- THE
CASE IS RESOLVED AND- THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE
HAPPEN AND FRANKLY SOME OF US
ARE HOPING THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO EVEN. UP THE SHOULD BE. COMP
WILL COMPLY. AND THAT'S THE
ULTIMATE GOAL IN IF YOU HAVE A
HEAVY CAMERA THAT'S THE
INCENTIVE. OFFER COMPLIANCE AND
CHANGED THE WORKING WELL SO
WITH THAT SENATOR MONNING. I
JUST WANTED ALSO MY WELCOMING.
MELINDA'S TO THE COMMITTEE
WELCOME- THIS IS WHERE WE GET
TO HAMMER OUT ALL KINDS OF
EXCITING LEGAL ISSUES IF YOU
WANT A LAWYER COMING IN YOU'LL
BE A- LAWYER LEAVING- FOR
BETTER OR WORSE IN A- COUPLE OF
COMMENTS THE CHAIR ADDRESS SOME
OF THIS. IT'S MY EXPERIENCE
THAT IF THERE'S AN OUT OF COURT
SETTLEMENT BETWEEN AN EMPLOYEE
AND EMPLOYER. PART OF THAT
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IS THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE CHARGE FROM
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER IT'S
NEGOTIATED IT'S PART OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS THAT PREVENTS.
THAT BEING A COMPONENT OF A
SETTLED CASE. ON THE ATTORNEY'S
FEES ISSUE WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD
LEGISLATION PROPOSED. TO
REQUIRE- LOSING. PLAINTIFF WHO
ALLEGES RETALIATION HAVE TO
SHOULDER ATTORNEYS FEES AND
THAT'S NEVER MADE IT THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE AND IN TWO.
WELL YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
BALANCE OF POWER IN THE
LEGISLATURE OR YOU CAN LOOK AT
THE EQUITY QUESTION OF WHAT ARE
WE TO PUTS THE PUBLIC POLICY.
OF ANALYZING AN EMPLOYER WHO
RETALIATES ILLEGALLY AGAINST AN
EMPLOYEE. WHO COMPLAINS THAT
SAY ABOUT AN UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITION. BUT SAY WORKING
CONDITION THAT COULD COULD
SERIOUSLY INJURE OR KILL OTHER
WORKERS. A WORKER BRINGS THAT
TO THE ATTENTION OF
AUTHORITIES. AND IS TERMINATED
FOR THAT. IF THERE'S THE THREAT
OF HAVING TO SHOULDER.
EXTRAORDINARY ATTORNEY'S FEES
IF YOU DON'T PREVAIL. IN THAT
CASE. EIGHT THE PUBLIC POLICY
IMPACT IS A CHILLING IMPACT ON
BRINGING TO THE. FOR REPORTS
EXERCISING EXISTING ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS WHETHER THAT'S TO
CAL OSHA OR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ON WAGE CLAIMS
THAT CENTURY SO THE PUBLIC
POLICY DIVIDE IN IN WHAT MAY
LOOK LIKE AN IMBALANCE OF WHO'S
ELIGIBLE FOR ATTORNEYS FEES IT
THAT THAT IMBALANCE IN
APPEARANCE IS BALANCED TERMS OF
THE PUBLIC POLICY ENCOURAGED
YOU DON'T WANNA CHILL AFFECT ON
SOME MISSING. SOME THAT BUT IF
CLEAN IN PURSUE A CASE AND
DON'T PREVAIL MY FAMILY I'M
WORKING FOR MINIMUM WAGE I
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY THE
ATTORNEY'S FEES. OF A
CORPORATION- SO THAT'S WHY I
THINK THERE'S- UNNECESSARY
DISTINCTION BETWEEN WHO'S
ELIGIBLE ON AND IS THIS BILL
BOTH EXTENDS A STATUE
LIMITATIONS AND REAFFIRMS THAT
PRINCIPLE I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY IN MADAME SHARED
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. VERY GOOD-
CENTER I CAL SKI. AND HIGH I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER HAND UP
SENATOR STERN CHOICE IN WHAT
YOU'RE GOOD BUT WILL END WITH
THE OBSERVATION BY CENTER Y.
CASKEY I'M ON PAGE SIX OF THE
STAFF AND ALL SUS UNDER PRE
EXISTING CLAIMS THE AUTHOR
AGREES WITH THE- THE FLAPS. ARE
CLAIMS THAT THERE'S NO REVIVAL
SINCE THE BILL SIMON ON IT
JUST. DOUBLE CHECKING. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME CENTER
MELENDEZ TO THE COMMITTEE ALSO.
HE SAID I SING THAT THAT'S- THE
ANALYSIS THEY HAVE IN YEARS.
I'M SURE WOULD YOU REPEAT THAT
GET THE HIT THEY TALK ABOUT PRE
SIXTEEN CLAIMS THAT THERE'S THE
BILL SILENT ON ARE REVIVING ANY
LAPSE CLAIMS THAT THERE IT'S
ONLY GOING FORWARD A
PROSPECTIVE CLAIMS THE DO A
NICE ANALYSIS OF THE SUPREME
COURT DECISION ON THIS SO I
ASSUME THAT THAT'S- THE AUTHOR
AGREES. THERE'S NO TRICKS HERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT IS THE CASE
BUT ALL DEFERRED OF MARIE GO AS
WELL AS SHE HAS ADDITIONAL OR
CHRISTOPHER FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THAT I BELIEVE
THAT'S CORRECT BUT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND GET CONFIRMATION- ARE
ONE OF THE TWO OF YOU MISS-
MISTER LET'S SEE I HAVE
CHRISTOPHER AMERICAL I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T LAST NAMES
ARE. NOT AS QUICK TO OF TO MY
MIND BUT IF EITHER OF YOU- HAS
A COMMENT TO CONFIRM OR REJECT
THAT I'D APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPRESSING THAT TO US. YES FEET
THE INTENDED NOT TO REVISE
BLOCKED CLAIMS THAT IT'S FOR-
EXISTING CLAIM TO EXPAND. THAT
THE TIME PERIOD. FOR THOSE
EXISTING CLAIM NOT TO REVISE
ONES THAT HAVE ALREADY LOCKED.
THANK YOU SO EXTINGUISH CLAIMS-
REMAIN EXTINGUISHED. VERY GOOD.
WHERE WOULD I BE ABLE TO
COMMENT VERY BRIEFLY WHO WHO IS
THIS IF YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF
PLEASE. DYNAMIC ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. IT BRIEFLY PLEASE
THANK YOU. I AGREE WITH THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES I DID WANT
TO POINT OUT ASSEMBLY BILL LINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACE LAST
YEAR WHICH EXTENDED THE
STRUCTURE LIMITATIONS FOR
CLAIMS EXPLICITLY PROVIDEDTHAT
IT DID NOT REVIVED LAPSED
CLAIMS SO WE THINK IT WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH THAT STATUTE
AND MORE CLEAR IF THAT'S THE
INTENT TO EXPLICITLY PROVIDE SO
IN THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THAT WE
DON'T HAVE OUR- CONSULTANT WITH
US IN THE ROOM TO RAISE THAT
ISSUE BUT CERTAINLY WE WILL.
HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ALONG
THAT LINE WITHOUT ANY PROMISES
JUST CAN'T DO. OUR THE TO HAVE
THAT ONE ON ONE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT WAS THE INTENT AND-
IF THE AUTHOR IS WILLING TO
TAKE FURTHER CLARIFICATION THAT
CERTAINLY- WOULD MAKE SENSE-
BUT WE ARE NOW THIS BILL IS
BEEN MOVED AGAIN THE MOTION. IS
TO PASS. A TO APPROPRIATIONS
BEFORE THAT DID YOU WISH TO SAY
SOMETHING I DID- MANAGER I
APOLOGIZE BUT- CHRISTOPHER AND
MARIE CAL IS IT. COULD YOU
REPEAT FOR ME- WHO THEY
REPRESENT I DIDN'T CATCH IT AT
THE BEGINNING I'M JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHO IS PROVIDING
ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS ON THIS
BILL WE HAVE. WITH US- FASTER
FOR SANCHEZ POLICY ADVOCATE
WITH CHIRLA AND THEN MERRY GO
YOSHIHARA. LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION OKAY SO THEY- THEY
DON'T REPRESENT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT OUR SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
AND DO THEY. ARE THEY JUST HERE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ARE THEY SPONSORS I
BELIEVE THEY'RE ALSO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL. AND YOU WILL YOU
WILL FIND IT BOTH OF THEM.
WHITE REGULARLY THE EMPLOYMENT
LAW LAW. OF FOLKS AS WELL AS A
CHIRLA- ARE VERY ACTIVE
PARTICIPATE BUT THEY CERTAINLY
SOUND LIKE- AND THEIR WELL
VERSED ON THE SUBJECT I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
THE AUTHOR IS IN HERE I'M NOT
SURE WHY THE ARTERIES IN HERE
AND SO. IT SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE
OUTSIDE FOLKS ANSWERING
QUESTIONS ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOM KALRA IS BILL. WELL IT'S
NOT JUST THAT UNCOMMON TO HAVE
EXPERTS WHO ARE ABLE TO GIVE US
FURTHER ASSISTANCE- SO. I THINK
THAT WE WILL HAVE FURTHER
TESTIMONY I KNOW THAT THE- RICO
HAD A DOES A NUMBER. OF
ANALYSES AND EFFORTS ON BEHALF
OF. THE EMPLOYMENT LAW SECTION
OF THE BAR AND THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT ACTUALLY WERE IN THE
TRENCHES THERE CONTROL IS ALSO
VERY ACTIVELY INVOLVED. AND I
WILL INDICATE TO THAT ONE OF
THE COURTESIES THAT HAS BEEN
EXTENDED AND I THINK HAVE BEEN
EXTENDED TO BOTH HOUSES. IS IN
ORDER TO KEEP AS FEW PEOPLE IN
A CONFINED SPACE AS POSSIBLE
THAT WE ARE OFFERING AND THE
ASSEMBLY IS ALSO REST
RECIPROCATING AND OFFERING
THERE. ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
PRESENT BILLS ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHORS. UNUSUAL COUNTING BUT
THAT'S ONE OF THINGS WE'RE
DOING SO WITH THAT THERE IS A
MOTION TO PASS TO ASSEMBLY TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS ON THIS
MEASURE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AND I'M CHAIR JUST WOULD LIKE
TO SAY- I THINK ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA I THINK
THE WITNESSES AND I ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ABOUT. THANK YOU WITH THAT-
MATTER IN CONSULTANT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IF THE
SENATORS COULD PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO A. B. NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN KALRA. THE MOTION IS D.
PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. COMMITTEE
JACKSON. HI JACKSON I BOARD YES
NO. BORDERS NO DID ASAL.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI MELENDEZ
NOW MELENDEZ NARROW MINING HI
MY NAME AYE STERN. STERN I AM
BURKE HI AMBERG I WAKE HOUSE
KEY HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I. SIX
BUT SIXTY TWO WITH A MEMBER
MISSING CORRECT SO THE VOTE
COUNT AS SIX TO TWO WILL PLACE
THAT MATTER ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF THE CENTER GONZALEZ AND
NOW WE WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO EIGHT BY.
SENATOR PER WHEN EXCUSE ME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. THIS IS
A CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
PLATFORMS AND PLATFORM
CHARITIES ARE WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN THE FLOOR SHORES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR AND
SENATORS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO OO EIGHT
A BILL THAT WILL UPDATE OUR
STATE LAWS ON CHARITABLE GIVING
TO ACCOUNT FOR OUR NEW ONLINE
METHODS OF DONATING. WHILE
PROVIDING CONSUMER PROTECTION
SUPPOSED DONORS AND CHARITIES.
THIS BILL IS THE ONGOING WORK
PRODUCT OF LITERALLY YEARS OF
EFFORT BY MY OFFICE TO UPDATE
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THE NEW
REALITY OF ONLINE CHARITABLE
SOLICITATION. AND STAKEHOLDER
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN LED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT BEGAN
LAST FALL. OUR STATE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE TURNED TO
INTERNET TO THE INTERNET TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO LOCAL
CHARITIES. THERE ARE VARIOUS
WAYS TO GIVE ONLINE INCLUDING
DIRECTLY TO A CHARITY AND
INDIRECTLY TO VARIOUS CHARITIES
THROUGH ONLINE PLATFORMS THAT
LIST ALL CHARITIES REGISTERED
WITH THE IRS. THE BENEFITS AND
EFFICIENCIES OF TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGY ALLOWING
CALIFORNIANS TO DONATE TO
VIRTUALLY ANY CHARITY DO NOT
FIT EASILY WITHIN THE CURRENT
LETTER OF THE LAW. AT WHICH
NEVER CONTEMPLATED A PERSON OR
COMPANY WOULD HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO SOLICIT FOR MORE THAN A
HANDFUL OF PARTNER CHARITIES.
AB TWENTY TWO AWAY WILL ALLOW
FOR CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
PLATFORMS TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVERY CHARITY.
TO REACH FAR BEYOND THEIR
TRADITIONAL DONOR BASEBALL
PROVIDING KEY OVERSIGHT
CAPABILITIES. TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ENSURE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. WHAT
CONVERSATIONS ARE STILL ONGOING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON ELEMENTS
OF THIS BILL. I COMMIT TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON ANY FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT COME FROM THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. TODAY I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ANTHONY LOU AND BRIAN ARMSTRONG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
ARE CLEANING PROTOCOLS.
COMMITTEES ARE INSTITUTING A
TIME LIMIT. SO WE ARE SADLY-
LIMITING A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES PER SIDE AND ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY. HAVE TO
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES AND WITH THAT- WE HAVE
VISIT THE- ADOBE ATTORNEY.
ANTHONY LOU AND- DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BRIAN
ARMSTRONG ON THE PHONE- WHICH
ONE OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO START
AND WE'LL GIVE YOU. EACH A
MINUTE AND A HALF OF FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS. GOOD MORNING HI
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ANTHONY
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE- I'M GONNA MAKE MOST OF
THE COMMENTS AND THEN BRIAN
WILL INTRODUCE THEMSELVES- AT
THE END. EIJI BUT SERRA IS
PLEASE THE SPOTS EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWO ZERO EIGHT THE BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
OVERSIGHT OF CHARITABLE FUND
RATE. INTERNET PLATFORMS. WHAT
ALSO ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND
PROTECT CALIFORNIA DONORS AND
DECEPTIVE AND MISLEADING
CHARITABLE SOLICITATIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
HIGHLIGHTED THERE ARE MANY NEW
WAYS THROUGH WHICH INDIVIDUALS
CAN DONATE TO USING WEB OUTLOOK
PUNISHED PHONE. AND EVEN OF
DON'T THEIR EVENT CHARITABLE
FUNDRAISING CLASS. THE CURRENT
SOLICITATION WHICH WERE ADOPTED
BEFORE THE INTERNET AGE IT'S
NOT SPECIFICALLY REACH SHOULD
BE ABLE PLATFORM. TO ENSURE
THAT. CHARITABLE THE
PROVISIONAL IS OUT DAY. IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE AGING
CONTINUED ABILITY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC OUR OFFICE NEEDS TO
BE IN A POSITION TO OVERSEE
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
PRACTICES. THAT OCCUR INTERNET
PLATFORMS AND FIND NIMBLY TO
NEW CONCERNS WHATEVER THEY
ARRIVE. AS POINTED OUT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS IN TIME
OF NATURAL DISASTER WE SEE AN
INCREASE ONLINE SHOWING
RAISING. THE COVE IN NINETEEN
CRISIS IS NO DIFFERENT. BUT FOR
THAT REASON WE AGREE OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT NOW WITH THE
RIGHT TIME TO UPDATE THE LONG.
ESTABLISH A BASIC FRAMEWORK TO
ENABLE THE AG'S OFFICE THE
EXERCISE PROPER SUPERVISION
OVER THAT FAST GROWING STATE.
BUT STILL RESULT ROBOTS COURT
PROCESS TO FILL IT BY AG AND
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN. STARTED
OVER EIGHT MONTHS AGO AND
CONTINUE TO BE FOR. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE FEEDBACK WITH EVEN
THIS PROCESS AS YOU KNOW THE
BOW PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AND WE ARE STILL COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSING WHAT THEY
QUOTED GOING FORWARD SHOULD THE
BILL PASSED TODAY. WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA DONOR AND
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION. AGING
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
AND REAFFIRM HIS COMMITMENT TO
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY GUARD THE
PUBLIC FROM FRAUD OR
MISREPRESENTATION. AND ENSURE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE I
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER LOU-
MISTER ARMSTRONG IF YOU'D LIKE
TO GIVE IT A OF THIRTY SECONDS.
SURE THIS IS RIAN ARMSTRONG
I'M A DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL-
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL THE FERRIS
CHARITABLE TRUST SECTION I WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT A COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO AWAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT- YOU
WILL STAY ON THE LINE IN CASE
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS HERE
THIS IS SO. OBVIOUSLY SORT OF A
IN THE WEEDS KIND OF ISSUE BUT
AN IMPORTANT ONE SO WILL
ANTICIPATE THERE MIGHT BE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU. AND WITH
THAT- LET'S GO AHEAD AND- SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN ROME FORTY TWO OH THREE. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO- GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY HOW ARE THERE. ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE SO LET'S
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. AND
MATTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE AB TWENTY TWO
OO EIGHT. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO OH
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT UP
MATTER MODERATOR OF ARE THERE
ANY PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE AND IF
SO COULD YOU TELL US HOW MANY.
THANK YOU I HAVE ONE IN Q. VERY
GOOD IF YOU WOULD GO AHEAD AND
PROMPT THEM TO SPEAK. PINE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO THIS IS LUCY SELL
FETAL CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES ON THE LINE MATTER
MODERATOR WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. I HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. AT THIS TIME. VERY
GOOD WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO- WILL BE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. YES NOT INSURANCE IS
CAMPER DEMENTIA MAP OF TECH
THAT- BUT I'D BE ABLE TO SPEAK
OUT YES PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR NUMBER SEVEN
A MAJOR ATTACK NOT WE SHOULD
AUTHORS GOLD TRANSPARENCY AS IT
RELATES TO GENERAL FUND RAISING
AND DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND OUR STAFF
HAS DONE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE BUT UNFORTUNATELY AFTER
NINE MONTHS OF CONVERSATIONS
AND STAKEHOLDER MEETING. TECH
THAT REMAINS OPPOSING LAST
MINUTE ON AB TWENTY TWO OH
EIGHT. I MEMBER COMPANIES WORK
WITH THEIR CUSTOMERS AND
PARTNERS TO RAISING PROCESS
BILLION DOLLARS IN DONATIONS
FOR NONPROFIT. NOW MORE THAN
EVER THIS IS GOING EXPECT
HIGHLIGHTED DURING THE COKE
WITH NINETEEN CRISIS. AND THE
REASON CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
WHEN NONPROFIT TO RAISE MONEY
TO SUPPORT THOSE AND FROM MIND
AND LOCAL COMMUNITY. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROVISIONS OF
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN NOT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
SUCCESSFUL FUNDRAISING EFFORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN REALIZED TO OUR
PLATFORMS. IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WE HAVE
PROPOSES HERE'S AMENDMENTS TO
THE AUTHOR THAT WOULD. HELP
REMEDY THE TENANTS OF THOSE
LEGISLATION WITH THE REALITIES
OF OUR CURRENT CHARITABLE
PRACTICES. FIRST IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT OUR MEMBERS ARE
PROVIDED TIME TO ADAPT TO NEW
STATUTORY AND STILL UNKNOWN
REGULATORY SCHEMES CONTEMPLATED
IT AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT. FOR
THIS REASON WE THINK A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR BUSINESSES
TO MODIFY. THEIR CURRENT
PROSTHESES. IN ORDER TO BE.
WITH THE COMPREHENSIVE OVERHAUL
AND CHAIRED GIVING PROCESS.
SECOND WE REQUEST A LITTLE.
RECIPIENTS AND STAND AT THE IN
THIS. SHOULD BE MORE. OF NON.
CHARITY INCLUDING THOSE OUT OF
THE UNIED STATES THEY MAY NOT
BE. BY THE ARE OR AT THESE WERE.
THIRD TECH THAT REMAINS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BROAD
STATUTE STATUTORY AT THE
DEFERRED AN AGING OFFICE FOR.
RULEMAKING THE BILL AS MANY
PRESCRIPTIVE COMPONENTS CLEARLY
OUTLINED IN THE LANGUAGE THE
BILL ALSO MAKES SPECIFIC
ALLOWANCE THE AG TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCE. THE
STATUTORY PARAMETERS OF THIS
BILL ONE EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE
OPEN IN THE NATURE OF WHAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE REQUIRED
AND ALL TOWARDS THE AG'S
OFFICE. WHICH WOULD BE RESOLVED
IN STATUTE BUT WHICH COULD BE
RESULT AND CATCH YOU ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF THIS PRODUCT
óRDENES FOUND IN SECTION SHARE
THE BILL. WITH AG IS GIVEN
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH RULES
AND REGULATIONS WHICH SHALL
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO.
THE ADDITIONAL. ACTION
SOLICITATION THAT MEET. HAVE A
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING CLASS
FORMER PLATFORMS. TO JESSE
CHANGES IN TECH. IN CLASS
FUNDRAISING CLOUT FOR. WE
BELIEVE FEATURES AND ARE BETTER
OFF. AND WILL DO. BY ABILITY
OUT THAN WHAT THE DOJ. THE
REQUIREMENTS SET FORTH IN THE
BILL CAN OF AND GIVING OPEN
OVER PLATFORM AND FORCED A TO
RE EVALUATE THE VIABILITY FOR
SIX. CHARITABLE STRAW. FOR
THESE REASONS AND OUTLINE INNER
CITY IN AND TECHNO REMAINS IN
BECAUSE I'M NOT AMENITIES LOOKS
TO THE- PREDICTED CONVERSATION
WITH YA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES I
BELIEVE I HAVE HER MISTER
DILLON HOFFMAN WITH THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION WILL GIVE
YOU ANOTHER FORTY SECONDS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK. ARE YOU
WITH US FOR OFTEN. I AM THANK
YOU MADAM AND CENTER ON THE
OCCUPANTS REALLY GREAT MY
NAME'S ON HOW I'M TRYING. OF
TALK GOVERNOR AFFAIRS THE
INTERNET POSTED. I JUST WANT ON
MY CAR WITH MIKE. FROM FROM I A
AND ARE. SURE SAME CONCERNS
PARTICULARLY THAT THE BILL
WOULD GRANT PRETTY PROUD
REGULATORY AUTHORITY THAT WE
BELIEVE CAN BE ADDRESSED- IN
STATURE- JUST HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OTHER ISSUES- THAT OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS FLAGS- RELATED
TO THE- BILL'S COULD STAND
REQUIREMENTS. WE BELIEVE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS- ALONE
FOR A LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS IN
GOOD STANDING THREE MACHINE
READABLE WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS-
AND MAKE IT EASIER TO IMPLEMENT
THE BILL- IN- THE BILL'S
REQUIRE. PLACE BURDENS ON.
HUNDRED AND PLATFORMS COULD
HAVE THE UNINTENDED. OF A
REDUCE INSURABLE GIVEN SO
HELPING READERS SOME OF THOSE
BURDENS- AND ALLOW FOR
AUTOMATION WOULD BE IMMENSELY
BENEFICIAL- I. SIR OVER AND MY
APOLOGIES FOR WE ARE TO KEEP
THIS TO THE MINUTES I'M SURE
THERE BE SOME QUESTIONS WHICH
WILL ALLOW YOU TO- FURTHER
COMMENT BUT AT THIS POINT- WE
ARE TRYING TO STICK TO THE
THREE MINUTE GOLAN WE WENT A
LITTLE BIT OVER. AND MY
APOLOGIES FOR THAT- ALL RIGHT
WHAT. WE NEED TO DO NOW IS TO
ASK IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WITH THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. SEEING NONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE. TO
HAVE PEOPLE ON THE LINE COMETA
MODERATOR- IF YOU WOULD Q. THEM
UP AT THIS POINT IN TIME- TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE DO
SO NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OUT OF
AB TWENTY TWO OO EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HE SAID. THAT YEAH. ALL%
NO MATTER MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES ON THE LINE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE ONE ON THE
LINE. IF YOU WOULD TO ENCOURAGE
THEM PROMPT THEM TO SPEAK
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I
WON SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS JUDY BEAT ALL
WITH THE K. PROGRESSIVE SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION BASED IN
LITTLE TOKYO IN LOS ANGELES AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS WILL
HAPPEN IT HAPPENS EVERY TIME
PEOPLE WHO WEREN'T ON THE LINE
IS THERE ANYONE IF YOU WOULD
CHECK ONE MORE TIME AT A
MODERATOR FOR ANY OPPOSITION-
THIS MEASURE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PROMPT THEM
TO SPEAK. SHE THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY TWO OO EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE
LINE MATTER MODERATOR. I DO
HAVE ONE THERE WITH AN OPERATOR
RIGHT NOW IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT CERTAINLY. WE GOT A LINE
ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS IS MARGARET GLAD SHE
NUMBER HELP FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE
APOLOGIZE FOR- ARE LATE LETTER
INTO THIS WE HAVE A CALL OF
SUBMITTED. WE WOULD LIKE THAT
ARE ONLINE PORTALS TO BE
TREATED THE SAME AS OUR BRICK
AND MORTAR AND- WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE LANGUAGE OF
CREDIT. THANK YOU MUCH. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MADAM MODERATOR. I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THE WE WILL THEN
BRING THIS BACK TO DISCUSSION-
ALONG THE MEMBERS AND I BELIEVE
CENTER BORCHERS FALL BY CENTER
Y. CASKEY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO THINK A
ASSEMBLY WOMAN OR ONE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I THINK
THERE ARE SOME REALLY.
IMPORTANT TOOLS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED. ON I THINK WE HAVE
SEEN THAT. WHEN PEOPLE ARE
DRAWN EITHER THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA OR ODD THROUGH OTHER TECH
MEANS- TO SUPPORT A CAUSE- IN
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DONATE
DOLLARS TO THIS BECAUSE USING A
PLATFORM. IT'S A SITUATION
WHERE THINGS CAN GO AWRY
MEANING THAT THE PLATFORM OR
THE FOLKS THAT ARE OPERATING AT
A OR SUBMITTING THE MESSAGE TO
THE VIEWER CAN MISLEAD THE
VIEWER- IN ALL USING EXAMPLE-
THERE WAS A- THERE WAS A
FOREIGN ENTITY- ASKING FOR
DONATIONS TO SUPPORT TO SUPPORT
THAT REFUGEES. AND IT WAS LATER
REVEALED THAT IT WAS TO A
TOTALLY UNRELATED- ENTITY THAT
USE THAT PLATFORM TO BY PASS
AND GIVE THE DOLLARS ON TO
ANOTHER PURPOSE THAT SOME WITH
THE THAT SCHIST FRAUD BUT I
THINK T'S RIPE THAT STUFF LIKE
THIS DOES HAPPEN- I THINK WE'VE
HEARD THAT. EVEN WITH THIS GOOD
IDEA THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT. STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE RECOMMENDING THE THIS. MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOME AMENDMENTS
AND MORE DISCUSSION AND I KINDA
GETS TO MY LAST POINT IS- I
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORTER VERSION
OF THIS BILL AT SOME POINT IN
TIME I THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT.
FULLY DEVELOPED IN A WAY THAT I
THINK IT COULD BE. AND I'M KIND
OF CONCERNED THAT. HOW THIS
FITS IN WITH OUR OVERALL-
APPRECIATION OF BILLS THAT
SHOULD BE HEARD IN OUR
TRUNCATED- TIMELINE IT'S NOT
COLLUDED RELATED. IT'S NOT TIME
SENSITIVE IT'S NOT COMPLETELY
VETTED SO I DON'T KNOW WHY.
THIS WAS ELIGIBLE AND SHOULDN'T
BE BROUGHT BACK IN JANUARY.
MAYBE ALL THE FOR MY QUESTION
TO CHAIR WOMAN TO EXPLAIN HOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE COVERT
SESSION IS AN IMPERFECT SCIENCE.
THAT THAT'S MY RESPONSE SENATOR
WHY CAL SKI. WELL I'M GLAD I'M
GLAD THAT THAT'S NO CLEAR THE
AIR. THAT IT'S NOT BASED ON THE
LETTER IN THE MAIL THAT WAS PER.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION HERE WE'RE HERE
WITH THE HEARING WE'VE GOT A
BILL BEFORE US- AND- SENATOR
WHERE CASKEY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROCEED PLEASE FEEL FREE. FROM
THE OPPOSITE IN ABOUT NO
GUIDANCE IN CERTAIN- AREAS
ABOUT THE H. E. L. AT ISSUE IN
THESE REGULATIONS TAKEN FROM ON
THAT THEY WANT TO HAVE MORE
GUIDANCE ON PAGE TEN OF OUR
ANALYSIS TO TALK ABOUT DO
REGISTRATION FOR COMMERCIAL
CHARITIES. I WANT TO KNOW IF-
IS THE SUGGESTION THAT MAYBE.
THE EIGHT ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
MAYBE DEPUTY LIEU ONCE ANSWER
THIS FOR THE AUTHORS AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DOES HAVE THE-
OPTION TO EXEMPT PEOPLE THAT
ARE ALREADY. REPORTING
REGISTERED AND LIKE WHAT IS HE
AUTHORS THOUGHTS ON THAT. I'D I
WOULD I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO SAY
IS YOU KNOW THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR. THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
THIS BILL AND IT IS VERY
RELEVANT TO COUPLE THAT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS COMING
INTO THE ONLINE PLATFORMS IS.
ABSOLUTELY EXPLODING AND IN
SOME WAYS ONLINE GIVING IS THE
WILD WEST SO I WOULD LIKE TO
THE- THAT. THEN SENATOR
JACKSON'S ABOUT OF AND REALLY
GETTING DOWN INTO THE WEEDS ON
THIS BILL AND IT HAS BEEN A
VERY A HARD BALANCING ACT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP OUR
SPONSOR- WHO IS REALLY LEADING
THE DISCUSSIONS IN SUPPORT TO
KEEP CAL NON PROFITS IN SUPPORT
AND REALLY TRYING TO ADDRESS
ALSO THE ISSUES OF TECH THAT
THAT WILL CONTINUE OVER THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS BUT WE ARE NOT
IN ANY WAY GOING TO REDUCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION WHICH IS
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT SO. ON YOUR SPECIFIC.
QUESTION I THINK IT'S MUCH
BETTER THAT THE SPOT OF ANSWER
THE SO I EITHER MISTER LOW OR
MISTER ARMSTRONG I'M SURE CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT TO REGISTRY
LET'S GO AHEAD. MISSION WHEN I
IS THE PERSON YOU'RE TO GET.
BOB TO YOU DO THAT MR HOFFMAN
FISH ON THE CALL FOR YOUR
YOU'LL SIGN THIS IS HAPPENING I
THINK YOU ARE. AND I THINK
BRIAN WILL TRY ABOUT COULD
SORRY MIGHT BE FACIAL. ALL
RIGHT SO WE DO HAVE ON THE CALL.
TRYING TO FLEE THROUGH ALL OF
THE NOTES IS THAT RIGHT
CHALLENGE WE DO HAVE LET ME IT
THIS WAY WE HAVE AG ON THE CALL
WHOEVER WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER
THIS QUESTION FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. SURE YOUR HONOR THIS IS
THIS IS BRIAN ARMSTRONG. LET ME
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
THE CONCEPT OF A TOOL
REGISTRATION AND HOW IT'S
REALLY NOT A PROBLEM-
ESSENTIALLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL NEEDS TO KNOW WHO'S
DOING WHAT FOR INSTANCE TWO
BUTTONS AT THE WALL. THAT THE
FIRM IS PLAYING WHEN THEY'RE
SOLICITING DONATIONS POLLUTION
HALF THE GAS. AND FIGURE THAT
OUT- AND THERE ARE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF REGISTRATION CATEGORY
IF THERE'S ONE CALLED THE TREE
HE IS A CENTURY ASKS ARE. OLD
CHARITABLE ASSET. THERE'S A
WEDGE AND WHAT WILL FOR THAT
THAT FOCUSED ON FOR INSTANCE
CHAIRED CORPORATE GOVERNANCE
AND THE PROVIDING INFORMATION
ALONG THE LINES OF FLAKE OUT OF
FINANCIAL STATEMENT THAT YOU'LL
SEE FROM AN AUDITOR IT REALLY
INVOLVES FUNDAMENTAL ASPECTS OF
BEING A CHARITY- MEANWHILE WHAT
WE HAVE HERE IS- BUT THE BILL-
ENVISIONED AS A CHARITABLE
FUNDRAISING PLATFORM. IS VERY
WELL MAY NOT BE AN ACTUAL
CHARITY AT ALL ALTHOUGH IN SOME
CASES THE COULD BE. AND THIS IS
AN AND IN THE OPTIONAL ROLE
THAT IF IT IS A CHARITY BUT IT
MAY TAKE ON AND IT'S KIND OF
LIKE THEY'RE THEY'RE TAKING ON
THE ROLE OF FUND RAISING FOR
OTHER CHARITY. SO WE NEED TO
KNOW FOR INSTANCE WHO IS
SERVING IN THAT ROLE OUR
CAPACITY OF A CHARITABLE
FUNDRAISING TOP FORM. SO WE CAN
SUPERVISE FACILITATION FOR
POSSIBLE WRONGDOING. IN THIS
BAG FOR AN ADDITIONAL
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS SO WE
CAN LEARN THAT FOR AN
ADEQUATELY PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SPECIFIC TO THE ONLINE.
SOLICITATION WHAT PORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT GO WITH
REGISTRATION WOULD BE SPECIFIC
ALSO TO THE ONLINE FLIRTATIONS
SO THERE WOULDN'T BE
DUPLICATION AND REPORTING AND
NOT CARD. I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT TODAY THAT THERE IS A DUAL
REGISTRATION AS A RELATES TO
THESE TYPES OF TRUSTEES TODAY.
OR NOT IT'S WHEN THEY PERFORM
RAFFLES WHICH IS THE TYPE OF
THE LEGAL FORM OF GAMBLING AND
WHEN A CHARITY PERFORMS ARRIVAL
THEY NEED TO REGISTER IN
ADVANCE BEFORE PERFORMING THE
RAFFLES AND PROVIDE- SEPARATE
REPORTING ON THAT AS WELL- YOU
KNOW THAT. THIS IS WORKED OUT
FINE AND THE CAPACITY OF
RAFFLES LIKE THAT. I'M. AND WE
WE'RE NOT SEEING THE CONCERN
THAT. IT MAY HAVE. THE DOOR
REGISTRATION. THE THAT'S IT
YOUR HONOR. THANK YOU DESERVE
TO YEAH I THINK SO I EIGHTH.
WE'RE WE'RE SAYING THAT THE
POLL ON THE- THAT MAY PRESENT
AS A CHARITABLE PLATFORM BUT
BUT IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
ACTUAL- TRUST IN THE CHURCH
ORGANIZATION AND IF THERE'S
DIFFERENCES THERE THEN WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO SKIP THOSE PEOPLE
IN AND THE BILL. OKAY SO THE
GET AN AGING THIS COULD I COME
JUST MAKE ONE THE VERY BRIEFLY
SIR. SURE THAT OF WE ARE.
REVIEWING AMEND UNDERLYING THAT
WE'RE MADE. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
MONDAY AFTERNOON. AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO. DISCUSSING AND-
WORK THROUGH THE THINGS OF THE
NEXT DAYS I THINK AS A GENERAL
MATTER. YOU HOW ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY REGISTERED
UNDER THIS LAW AS DIFFERENT
ENTITIES THAT THE COMMERCIAL
COVENTRY AS A- COMMERCIAL
FRIENDLY MADE. AND CONDUCT THAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS OF
COURSE THE INTERNET FUND
RAISING ON THE PLATFORM SO IF
YOU'RE AN EXISTING ORGANIZATION
ALREADY REGISTERED AT THE END
AND YOU ELECT TO. THE KIND. OF
CONDUCT FALLS UNDER THE BUILD
BUT NAKHTMIN ISSUE VYING.
SHOULD THERE BE SEPARATE
REGISTRATION. AND IN ORDER TO.
FACILITATE OVERSIGHT OVER
PLATFORM TYPE OF CONDUCT OR
SHOULD USE SIMPLY BE ALLOWED TO
ENGAGE IN THAT KIND OF CONDUCT.
AND MAINTAIN YOUR PREVIOUS
REGISTRATION OF A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT ENTITY. WHICH WAS
REQUIRED OF YOU IN THE FIRST
PLACE FOR DIFFERENT SET OF
CONDUCT. SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE
THANK VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SENATOR MONNING. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR ADDRESS THIS BUT I WOULD
JUST AMPLIFY THE NEXUS WITH
COVERT NINETEEN TO ME IS
CRYSTAL CLEAR. THIS WEEK
TOMORROW THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR PEOPLE
WHO'VE LOST THEIR JOBS THROUGH
NO CHOICE OF THEIR OWN EXPIRES
NO BACK UP COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE GONNA
PEOPLE FACING. FICTION THE
INABILITY TO PAY RENT AND
ABILITY TO PAY THEIR- FEED
THEIR FAMILIES TO PUT GAS IN
THEIR CARS. WERE GOING FROM
CRISIS TO SUPER CRISIS AND- IN
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN DISPLACED
ARE GONNA BE MORE DEPENDENT ON
CHARITABLE GIVING THERE'S GOING
TO BE AN INCREASE IN CHARITABLE
APPEALS. MANNING HOPEFULLY MOST
WILL BE LEGITIMATE SOME WILL BE
CON ARTISTS WHO ARE GONNA PLAY
UP ON PEOPLE'S SYMPATHY AND
CONCERN FOR OTHER DISPLACED IN
WITH. SUPPORT IN THIS TIME OF
CRISIS SO. I DON'T THINK IT'S A
STRETCH TO SEE THIS BILL IS
VERY CONSISTENT WITH OUR
PRIORITIZATION OF COVERT
NINETEEN AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY TO MY
RESPONSE THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
A LITTLE CLIP THIS IS VERY
DEFINITELY COVERED RELATED
DIRECTLY WERE A COUPLE BILLS.
THAT WE CONSIDERED TO HEAR
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE OF
CHARITABLE GIVING AND THE
MINUTE. SADLY THAT WE'RE SEEING
WITH THE AUNT OF WELL MEANING
IN INTEREST WHO WOULD TO HELP
THOSE. NEED THIS BILL ACT. UP
AS FAR THAT. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE TWO AMENDMENTS
SHOULD'VE TO. WITH ATTORNEY
OFFICE IS SORT OF THE OF IT
FIND WE HAVE AN ONLINE. EMPIRE
OF THE- IS THAT. THEY'RE VERY
PLATFORM OUT THERE THAT ARE-
WITHOUT THE PERMISSION OR
APPROVAL OF THE ACTUAL CHARITY
THAT IS BEING REPRESENTED
CLAIMING THAT THEY ARE IN FACT
RAISING MONEY FOR THEIR CHARITY
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE THEN
THEY SHOULD FALL WITH THE PER
OF THE- GENERAL WHO. CONTROL
CHAIRED GIVING SO WITH THE-
INTRODUCTION AND IN FACT MEANT
OF INTERNET TRANSACTIONS IN
THIS WAY THERE IS REALLY BEEN
INADEQUATE PROTECTIONS. FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO GIVE ONLINE
FOR THOSE CHARITIES AND THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS BILL. IS
AND A DESIGNS TO REGULATE SO.
AGAIN THE CURRENT PROVISIONS
ARE REGULATE MORE CHARTER A
MORE TRADITIONAL SOLICITATIONS
AND IT HASN'T BEEN MODERNIZED-
PARTICULARLY AT THIS POINT TIME.
WHERE WE'RE SEEING- THE
GENEROSITY OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE PEOPLE'S
COUNTRY COMING FORWARD WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR GIFTS
TO THOSE IN NEED GOAL TO THOSE
PEOPLE IN NEED AND-
UNFORTUNATELY. WE HAVE WITH
THIS CRISIS AS WE SEE WITH
EVERY CRISIS THERE ARE THOSE
OUT THERE WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE CROP FOR THE
PHONE. UP OFTEN. THREE SHELF
AND GREED DROVE DOES AND THIS
IS A MEASURE THAT TRIES TO PUT
A CHECK ON THAT AND FRANKLY
THAT'S THE REASON THAT I WAS-
WANTING AN ANXIOUS TO HEAR THIS
BILL BECAUSE I DO THINK IT WILL
MOVE US FORWARD I IN THAT
PROTECT. THE ARE ON GOAL.
DISCUSSIONS I KNOW THAT MANY
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN AND
I THINK ARE THERE ARE STILL.
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON. BUT AT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME IN ALL
CANDOR WE ARE SEEING. A LOT OF
MONEY MOVING ON THE INTERNET
FOR CHARITABLE GIVING AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE IT GOES WHERE
IT'S SUPPOSED TO SO. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THE AND-
ALSO TO ASK YOU TO REITERATE
FOR US ON THE RECORD HERE THAT
ARE. IN EWING GROCERY SHOULD TO
TRY TO ADDRESS- SOME OF CONCERT
THAT. HAVE BEEN ARE TO. UP TO
HAVE ADDRESSED MANY OF THEIR-
STILL OPEN OR WORK TO DO. AS
TO. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. BUT A
MEMBER CHARTER ENSURE THE DE
ARE OF HOW SHARON WILL
FUNDRAISING PLATFORMS AND
PLATFORM CHARITIES OPERATE.
INCLUDING ROBUST DISCLOSURE
ABOUT FEES AND POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND THAT THE REASON
DE THAT APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
WE NEED TO GIVE THE AG IN ORDER
TO SAVE OUR DONORS AND THOSE
DONATIONS ARE TEN TO GO TO
CHURCH SO WHICH SHARE WITH US
ARE WHAT SOME OF THESE
POTENTIAL MEMBERS ARE THAT
YOU'RE PLANNING ON TAKING. AND
WHICH ISSUES THESE INTENDED TO
ADDRESS OF THAT BUT I WON'T PUT
ANY ANY AMENDMENTS WE TAKE WILL
BE PART OF THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WILL MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SPONSOR THE DOJ. CAL PROF OR
COMFORT WITH IT AND WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT ANY AND THEN
SATURDAY IN ARE RUN BY THIS
COMMITTEE ALSO VERY GOOD STORE.
AGAIN WE ARE IN TRUNCATED
COALBED. DRIVEN SEARCH IT IS
NOT I DO BY ANY STRETCH. THE
FRANKLY. PORT OF HIS PEOPLE FOR
REACH OUT TO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THAT THERE IN TEN
ARE MET AND THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
THAT ASSISTANCE RECEIVE IT SO-
WITH THAT- WE DO HAVE A MOTION
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. FAMILY
MEMBER OR WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
THE VERY GOOD- MADAM CONSULTANT
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-
SENATORS PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON AT ITS- FILE
ITEM SEVEN. AB TWO TWO OH EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. JACKSON HI JACKSON
BY BARGES. FOR JUST NOT VOTING
DATA SO I RUSSELL I GONZALEZ I
FROM THE LIST HI MELENDEZ NO
MELENDEZ NO MONNING AYE MONNING
I. STERN A- STERN I AM BURKE.
WIECKOWSKI HI MY CAL SKI I. TWO
FOUR FIVE. SIX TWO ONE IN THE
MEMBERS APPETITE OF THE VOTE
COUNT IS CURRENTLY SIX TO ONE
WE HAVE A MISSING MEMBERS SO
WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER. ROOM.
MAY MAY I ASK IF YOU ALSO
CLEANED OFF THE MICROPHONE CAP
I DIDN'T SEE THAT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE HERE. THE OUR NEXT UP
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO THIS
BILL BUT I SEE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA HERE- ARE YOU PRESENTING
FOR HER OR YOU'RE PRESENTING ON
YOUR OWN BILL FIVE WE GENERALLY
GO IN FILE ORDER BUT SINCE YOU
ARE PRESENT WE WILL GO AHEAD.
WITH THAT ITEM UNLESS THERE'S
ANY OBJECTIONHAS ANYBODY
CALLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER COULD
YOU. AB FORTY FOUR OUT OF ORDER
THAT THAT'S A GOOD POINT SO
LET'S SEE IF A. OH OKAY I DID
NOT RECOGNIZE YOU IN THAT MASK.
I'M SO STORAGE AREN'T. WE IN
TWO R THREE DAYS AS AN ADULT
CONSENT OF MOST OF THE- WHAT.
AT NOW RECENTLY AFTER CALL.
RIGHT OKAY ARE A NUMBER MY
APOLOGIES ARE WE HAVE TO GO IN
FILE ORDER BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
ON THE PHONES- CUED UP TO SPEAK
AND I THINK WE ARE JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO- BEAR WITH THE
CURRENT SYSTEM AS- STRUCTURED
INCIDENTS SO- WE WILL PROCEED I
WILL INDICATE TO YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO THAT APPARENTLY
THERE IS NO OBJECTION TO THIS
MEASURE SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
BRIEF WOULD CERTAINLY BE THE-
OF YOU. THE SOUTH. HAVE THE
TWENTY ENTER BUT I WILL I HAVE
EVERY CONFIDENCE YOU CAN REDUCE
IT DOWN TO OF A MINUTE. ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE. WHICH ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO SUSPEND THEIR
CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS WHILE
INCARCERATED OR INVOLUNTARILY
HELD FOR AN INSTITUTION MORE
THAN NINETY DAYS. BEFORE
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA PROVIDED AN
AUTOMATIC PROCESSES FOR THE
TEMPORARY SUSPENSION OF CHILD
SUPPORT ORDERS FOR INCARCERATED
PARENTS- UNFORTUNATELY THE
STATE LAW EXPIRED AND ARE
HOPING TO BRING IT BACK AND TO
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF. FOR
PARENTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN CLEARLY WHILE
YOU'RE INCARCERATED YOU DO NOT
HAVE A JOB. AND SO. GIVEN THE
CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES WE HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO. SLAUGHTER SPEC
REQUEST I VOTE AND BEFORE WE
PROCEED I WANT TO CONFIRM THAT
YOU ARE ACCEPTING IT SAW.
THIRTY ON PAGE TWO. A PAYCHECK
COMMENT FOR THE IN OUR THAT IS
YES VERY GOOD FOR GOOD ALL
RIGHT SO. WE HAVE I BELIEVE
WITNESSES WITNESSES HERE AGAIN
I WILL REITERATE BECAUSE MY
SCRIPTURES I NEED TO THE DUE TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND ARE CLEAN
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL INCH
TIME LIMITS ON TO. OF THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHER WISHING TO
TESTIFY TO LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS. TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE SO WITH THAT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A TWO WITNESSES- ALICIA
LEWIS OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT. AS WELL AS
VICTORY BREA ON THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
ON THE LINE IS THAT CORRECT THE
MADAM MARK MODERATOR. COULD I
GET AN AFFIRMATIVE ON THAT YES
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD SO LET'S
BEGIN- WITH ALICIA LEWIS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS BAND- I ASSUME
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SHARING YOUR
THREE MINUTES WITH MISTER RAY.
YES NOT GONNA BE BRIEFED CHAIR.
WE FEEL IF POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES CUT CO SPONSORED
THE MEASURE. WE ARE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT PROVIDING IMMEDIATE
COMPREHENSIVE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
RETURNING HOME TO
INCARCERATION. AND A PART OF
OUR SUPPORTED SERVICES ARE
STAFF HELPED PRODUCE.
PARTICIPANT BUDGET THERE NEARLY
FORTY INCOME. AND HOW TO WORK
TOWARD MEETING THEIR
OBLIGATIONS. EVERYDAY WORDS
BEING THE DAMAGE THAT RENTAL
INSURMOUNTABLE DEBT IS CAUSING
ON THE ABILITY OF OUR PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS THEY GET ON TRACK.
BUILDERS WHY REINSTATING
AUTOMATIC MODESTY THE SMALLER
MINUTES STAFF WORKING AT HAVING
A IMPACT ON THE LINE THE AND
MOTHERS WE WERE WITH THE REACH
HELP AND SHE WE HOPE TO SEE
BRIDGE AND BACK WITH BOTH THEIR
FAMILY COMMUNITY WE APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VICTOR RAY
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WHEN NON CUSTODIAL
CARS WAITING AND THEY LOSE
THEIR ABILITY LARGER THERE'S
BALANCES ARE INEVITABLY GOING
TO ACCUMULATE. ON BETTER
ACTUALLY. A CHILD BEFORE WE SEE
THAT LOW INCOME AND P. CAN
BECOME OVER. WHEN THEY HAVE
CHILD SUPPORT. OR MANY TIMES
DAILY THE BAD TO SAY TO PUT PAY
THEIR CHILD'S BECAUSE THEY FEEL
THEY CAN CATCH UP T. PAY OFF
INTO. AND TYPICAL THEY OFTEN
WILL WITHDRAW FROM HI IT'S
KELLY TIME THERE CHILL.
DAMAGING THE A MOTIONAL. AT THE
TRIAL NEEDS WITH THEIR PARENTS
AS WELL AS THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT WHICH THEY'RE LOSING.
WHEN THE ORDERS PENSION PROP
WITH THE PLACE. THE UNIFORMED
APPROACH AROUND STATE THE AREA.
HOWEVER NOW THAT THE LAW SINCE
IT COUNTY YOU TAKE DIFFERENT.
TO MANAGING AND- CARS. ISSUE
THE END RESULT BEING THAT THE
WAY CASES HAVE A DEPEND ON
WHICH COUNTIES AND IS IN THE
CASE. AB TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE
THE BOYS ARE THE POSTING
RATIONS AREA WE SEE COMMITTEE
TIME CALIFORNIA. HEALTH
INSURANCE PETER REASONABLE
APPROPRIATE QUARTERS. AND ARE
BETTER ABLE TO. HELP THE POOR
CLEARLY FROM INCARCERATION IT
DID NOT GIVE A FREE PASS
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE.
ABILITY TO PAY WATER
INCARCERATED. AND I. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR RARE ARM OF THE
BILL THE MOTION BY SENATOR
MORNING LET'S BEGIN THOUGH DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL
IN SUPPORT OF IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM FORTY. SEEING NONE
MATAMATA DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESS
WAY TO TAKE VIA THE TELL. ORVIS
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I DO HAVE FOR IN THE QUEUE VERY
GOOD THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD GO
AHEAD AND CALL INVITE THEM TO
SPEAK. AGAIN NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE. THANK YOU BYE AND ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS A REBEKAH
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU I TO ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARES ON
BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING
READ MY NAME IS MARA WILSON AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS.
MEASURE NOTION BILL THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
I HAVE TO AUSTIN Q. OVER THE
LINE OF ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AS PAUL
EUROPE WE HAVE TO THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
RIDE ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JUST WANTED BET ON THE
LESSONS ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES- IN
THE QUEUE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE MADAME
MODERATOR. I HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. VERY GOOD THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY LISTED- WE GET
CONFIRMATION THAT THERE ARE NO.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WISHING
TO SPEAK. ALL RIGHT SEEN THAT A
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES ARE MATTER
MODERATOR IF SO WOULD YOU
PLEASE Q. THEM UP. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE MODERATOR TO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES CUED UP
IN OPPOSITION. THERE ARE NO
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT. OF DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HI I
DID I ASK SYSTEM FORTY TWO A
THREE YEAR TWENTY FORTY ALL
RIGHT WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
THROUGH THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
THEN TO THE DíAS AND SENATOR
MELINDA'S THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- SO I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. LET'S ASSUME IT IS-
A MOTHER WHO HAS HE'S TAKING
CARE OF THE CHILDREN AND THEIR
SPOUSE OR EX SPOUSES
INCARCERATED. SO IF THE CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS STOP. THEN OUT
WHAT IS THE MOTHER TO DO TO. ME
IN A SUPPLEMENT THE INCOME THAT
SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
AS CHILD SUPPORT. THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION SENATOR- ONE
THING THAT WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
WHEN A PARENT IS INCARCERATED
IS THAT THEY MAKE ABOUT EIGHT
CENTS AN HOUR. ON TOP OF THAT
THE STATE TAKE THE MANDATORY
55% OUT OF THE EIGHT CENTS PER
HOUR. SO THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
WAY THAT A PARENT THAT IS
INCARCERATED CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE THE CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS. IN ADDITION TO THAT
THERE ARE FEES AND PENALTIES
THE ONE THAT PARENTS RELEASED
FROM PRISON. A HOT. THEY HAVE A
DEBT. THAT THEY ARE. OFTEN NOT
ABLE TO GET OUT OF I'M SORRY IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TRYING TO
EXPLAIN BUT IF YOU COULD JUST.
YOU KNOW ANSWER THIS QUESTION
WHICH IS WHAT IS THE- THOSE
MOTHER WHO'S TAKING CARE TO
CHILDREN SUPPOSED HOW WOULD HOW
DOES SHE SUPPLEMENT. THAT LIKE
HIM I UNDERSTAND THAT THE PRO.
VISIT DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME
SALARY COMING IN WELL YOU'RE
ASKING A QUESTION THAT. THE
ANSWER IS IN FRONT OF YOU
SENATOR. A MOTHER THAT DOESN'T
HAVE THE CHILD SUPPORT FROM
PARENTS THAT IF INCARCERATED IS
GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK FOR OTHER
RESOURCES. AND LUCKILY WE LIVE
IN A STATE THAT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS. AS LONG AS
WE'RE NOT CUTTING THEM. AMID
CODED AND A MAN OF VERY LITTLE.
RECESSION SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE ABLE POINT. THAT
PROGRAM PROVIDE. FOOD
HEALTHCARE. FOR INDIVIDUALS
NEED ASSISTANCE IS AVAILABLE
AND I HOPE WE CAN COUNT YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT AND I AND IF I
MAY JUST JUMP IN WE ASKED YOU
YOU AGREE TO ACCEPT. IN THE
PLACE THE. HI RUNNING. WORST TO
PEOPLE CARS RATED YOU TO HAVE
TO PAY YEARS. AND OBVIOUSLY
AGENTS AN HOUR THERE GOING TO
BE A TO. WELL WHAT ABOUT THE-
PARENT. WHO THEN AND- EVEN RISK
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO ALSO GIVE
CONSIDERATION TO THAT FACT WELL
AND THAT'S WHAT THE STUDY. WILL
LOOK AT WHAT SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE- BECAUSE THE CHILDREN
ULTIMATELY WILL SUFFER- IF
THERE IS NO SUCH. COMING IN- AT
WHAT WERE YOU FREQUENTLY FIND
COOLEY IS IT'S USUALLY
CUSTODIAL OTHER. AND ENDS UP
TAKING A SECOND JOB NO TAKING A
THIRD JOB- SO THE BURDEN DAN.
RETURNS TO THAT COULD STILL BE
A PARENT WHICH OF COURSE WHEN
PARENTS ARE NOT IN THE HOME
ABLE TO DO THE NECESSARY THE
DISCIPLINE AND OVERSIGHT OF
CHILDREN. A CREATES A REAL
PROBLEM AND THEN OF COURSE IF
THERE'S NO FOOD ON THE TABLE
SO. THIS BILL AT AT MY REQUEST
FRANKLY. OF THE AUTHOR
GRACIOUSLY AGREED TO ACCEPT.
THAT AMENDMENT SO WE CAN START
LOOKING AT THAT WE HAD ANOTHER
BILL THAT WE PUT- A DID WAS
CONSENT ITEM- BY IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL- THAT ALSO. LIMIT
ON A SUPPORT WHEN YOU HAVE A
NEW. VETERAN TO WHOSE ONLY
GETTING SSI AND OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
RESOURCES. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE CANNOT FORGET. THE
PARENT TO INTO POTENTIALLY
STUCK WITH THE BILL IF YOU
WILL- BUT CLEARLY- IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE IN PRISON I CANNOT PAY.
THEY THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AN- ARM I THINK. OUT
WITH THIS STUDY WILL BE ABLE
TO. GET A BASS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE. PROPERLY CARED
FORCE THAT THERE NEEDS ARE NOT
UNDERMINE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
PARENT TO IN MARCH. AND NOT
GETTING ANY. I THINK. ANSWERED
YES YEAH MA'AM IN A APPRECIATE
CLARIFICATION SO I AS A PANDERS
IT THEN WE BE IF THE MOTHER
DOESN'T HAVE A WAY TO STOP THE
IN. FOR SUPPORT SHE WOULD HAVE
BEEN GETTING SHE WOULD THEN
HAVE TO GO AND SOME SORT OF-
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE WHICH I
BELIEVE IS WHAT YOU WERE.
RECOMMENDING OR SUGGESTING AND
THE CHAIR SAID THAT YOU HAD
AGREED TO PUT A STUDY IN PLACE-
THOUGH THE STUDY- CERTAINLY
DOESN'T HELP THE CUSTODIAL
PARENT DURING THE TIME WHEN SHE
STILL NEEDS TO FEED HER
CHILDREN INCLUDE HER CHILDREN
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT TAKE
PLACE SO I DON'T KNOW I THINK
THIS STUDY MIGHT COME A LITTLE.
CONSOLATION TO THE ACTUAL
BECAUSE OF TO BE YOU KNOW.
SORRY FOR BEING A ABOUT THIS.
THE I JUST HAVE ONE FINAL
QUESTION- IT SAYS THIS DOES NOT
APPLY WERE THE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL HAS THE ABILITY. TO
CONTINUE MAKING CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS AND THAT- DOES THAT
MIRROR FEDERAL LAW. OKAY AND
THEN IT ALSO SAYS- IT DOES NOT
APPLY. WHERE INCARCERATION IS
THE RESULT OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AGAINST THEIR SUPPORTED PARTY
OR CHILD IS DOES THAT ALSO MERE
FEDERAL LAW OR IS THAT
SOMETHING. THAT'S JUST STATE
LAW. I'LL HAVE TO THE BY TO YOU
ON ONE I BELIEVE IN THEIR STATE
LAW BUT LET ME DOUBLE CHECK ON
A STEER YOU IN THE WRONG OKAY
AND IT'S JUST A MISTAKE
VIOLENCE SO NO WEATHER SO IN
OTHER WORDS IF THERE WERE ANY
SORT OF SEXUAL ABUSE. THAT'S
NOT FACTORED INTO THIS LIVE
USES FACTORED INTO IT. OKAY IT
IS FACTORS OR ANYTHING ELSE
FACTORED IN THAT. I DON'T HAVE
IN FRONT I DON'T I JUST HAVE A
DOMESTIC ABUSE IN FRONT OF ME
IS THERE I'M HAPPY TO GET YOUR
INFORMATION ON THE BILL. OKAY
SIR TO A CASKET FUND. CLEAR
THAT THIS DOESN'T APPLY TO
DOMESTIC PEOPLE SERVING PRISON
TIME FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ALTHOUGH SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS
FOR AUTOMATICALLY SUSPENDED
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION WOULD APPLY TO THEM
DO YOU ENVISION THE STUDY THAT
YOU AGREE TO WITH THAT GIVE US
REPORT ON THE IMPACT THAT.
ALLOWING THE DEBT BURDEN TO
CONTINUE ON THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND MONTHS SAID AND
THE NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS WHAT
THAT IMPACT MAY HAVE WANTS TO
RELEASE FOR PAYING CHILD
SUPPORT. FINDING A JOB DOING
ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS I DON'T
KNOW ITS ACT READ THE AMENDMENT
BUT IT DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY SAY
THAT IT'S ASKING FOR THOSE
IMPACTS BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT WAS. DISCUSSED WITH YOU IN
THE CHAIR WELL THEY'RE ACTUALLY
HAS ALREADY BEEN RESEARCH ON
THAT. AND THE RICHARD RESEARCH
DOES SHOW- THAT MOST OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT THAT COMES FROM
PARENTS MAKING LESS THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. AND
THAT- WHAT WE'VE DONE NOW IS
THERE ON TOP OF THE REAR RIDGE
IS A 10% INTEREST PENALTY. SO
OF THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
WHEN A PERSON COMES OUT OF
PRISON. GET BACK ON THEIR FEET
THEY ARE THEY PERCEIVE THAT
THEY ARE IN SUCH ENORMOUS DEBT.
THAT FREQUENTLY THEY WON'T THAT
DAY. DISASSOCIATE FROM ANY KIND
OF RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
CHILDREN THAT'S FINANCIALLY
BASED THE ROOM BARROW STORE
THERE ARE DATE THEY FEEL
INADEQUATE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES AND
THAT- THEY DON'T REUNITE WITH
THEIR FAMILY SO WOULD IT
APPARENTLY INCREASES
RECIDIVISM. ME TO IT'S A LOSE
LOSE SITUATION I MEAN I SEE
THAT WERE YOU KNOW WE'RE
EXCLUDING THE ROBBERS MORE
EXCLUDING THE TRUCK DRIVERS AT
TO TIME BUT WE'RE NOT EXCLUDING
THE PEOPLE OVER. SAID THERE CAN
BEEN CONVICTED OF A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND I'M JUST THINKING
THAT. DAY THE POLICY GOALS FOR
THE GOALS WE STAYED OF FREE
REUNIFICATION AND MAKING SURE
THAT ONCE THEY'RE OUT. THEIR
BEHAVIORS IMPROVE THAT THEY PAY
WHATEVER THE AMOUNT WAS JUST
WONDERFUL SHOULD BE STARTING
THAT ALSO. OKAY THEIR DATE THE
BE CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND BE IN POVERTY BE
POOR UPPER PER PERSON AND FALL
INTO ALL THE OTHER CATEGORIES
EXCEPT FOR THE CRIME THAT THEY
WERE. INCARCERATED FOR AND JUST
SEEMS. I DON'T KNOW. SEEMS LIKE
SOMETHING YOU'D LIKE TO STUDY
TO SEE. MAYBE IS THAT IS THAT
HELPFUL OR HARMFUL. MAY I
RESPOND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROCEED THE RESPONSE CERTAINLY
SO LET'S LET'S BE CLEAR ON THE
INTENT OF THE BILL THE INTENT
OF THE BILL IS TO BRING
CALIFORNIA UP TO A FEDERAL
STANDARD IT IS TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN CARS. AND
ADDITIONALLY. SUPPORT PAYMENTS
THE DAY CURRENTLY CA MEET
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN CARS AND
MAKING EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR I AM
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
ALL OF YOU ON YOUR CELL SENATOR
AND ANYONE IN THIS ROOM TO TRY
TO DO ADDITIONAL STUDIES ON HOW
TO HELP PEOPLE. GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET DECREASE RECIDIVISM
RATES. AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GO BACK TO THEIR FAMILIES. PART
OF THE CONVERSATION AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS I WANT
TO. BUY YOUR REQUEST MADAM
CHAIR KEEP THE SHORT BUT WE
COULD GET INTO IT. WHAT I HAVE
HEARD IN BOTH HOUSES FROM BOTH
PARTIES. IS AN AGREED IS
IMPLICIT BIAS. PARENTS ARE
INCARCERATED THE REALITY IS THE
MAJORITY OF PARENTS WANT TO
REUNITE WITH THEIR FAMILIES
THEY WANT TO BE A PART OF THEIR
CHILD'S LIFE. BUT THE BURDENS
THAT THEY ENCOUNTER ALONG THE
WAY ARE SO HIGH. THEY'RE COMING
OUT OF PRISON DURING PULLED IT.
NO JOBS LACK OF HOUSING AN
INCREDIBLY REDUCED
OPPORTUNITIES IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY MEMBER OF SOCIETY. WHO
HAVE CLEARLY PAID THEIR DEBT TO
SOCIETY AND WANTS TO RENO TO
REUNIFY WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND
WHAT THEIR KIDS CAN DO SO FOR
LET'S TAKE CARE OF THAT RIGHT
NOW IN ITS URGENCY. AND NEXT
YEAR I AM MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO
ANY STUDY THAT YOU WISH TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE MOVING AN
AGENDA THAT HELPS FAMILIES AT
THE END OF THE DAY MADAM CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE
WERE SAYING EXACT THAT'S TRUE
FOR EVERY THING EXCEPT FOR THE
PERSON WHO SERVING TIME FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND ABUSE AS
I UNDERSTAND THE BILL. I THINK
THE PROBLEM IS WE DON'T WANT TO
CREATE ANY POTENTIAL IN SAN.
SOMEONE COMMITTED A STICK FILA
AND GETS THE OPPORTUNITY IS A
RESULT OF THAT TO AVOID THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PAYING CHILD
SUPPORT. THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM
RIGHT RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY I'M
I'M NOT. I'M JUST RAISING THE
ISSUE BECAUSE I THINK THAT THIS
IS. THIS IS A- AND JERRY THE
LAW THAT WE TEND TO WE DON'T.
ISN'T PICKY. A SITUATION WHERE
PEOPLE ARE ABUSING THEIR LOVED
ONES AND WE THINK YOU GET
THROWN IN JAIL AND- PART OF THE
GOAL HERE IS THAT REUNIFICATION
AND BRINGING PEOPLE BACK IN.
AND I'M JUST SAYING THERE'S- I
WOULD SAY TO CARPOOL BUT THIS
IS FROM A GROUP OF PEOPLE A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN JAIL THAT ARE POOR
THAT GOT ALL THE OTHER. ALL THE
SIGNALS HERE THAT ARE
PRODIGIOUS RAISING. HIS INITIAL
MEAN I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY BUT IT'S NOT ALL THE
BOAT TO FLOAT. AT IS I IS I SEE
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE IT'S A
COMPLICATED THERE'S A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT. SCENARIOS WHERE
PEOPLE GET CONVICTED AND- THE-
WELL I'M GLAD TO RAISE THE
ISSUE MORE. I THINK A THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE I HAPPEN TO HAVE
SOME EXPERIENCE PRESS WHEN I
WAS A PRACTITIONER. AND NO ONE
EVER ASKED WHAT ABOUT THE
CUSTODIAL PARENT WHO'S LEFT
HAVING TO GET TWO AND THREE
JOBS TO MAKE ENDS MEET. I WAS
JUST EXPECTED AND MOST OF THEM
ARE WOMEN AND- YOU KNOW BEING
IN THE LOWER PAID JOB
CATEGORIES ANYWAY JUST ANOTHER
ELEMENT OF THAT SUM COMING DOWN
ON THE SCALE OF FAIRNESS AND
JUSTICE SO. HAVING THIS I THINK
IS THE FIRST TIME ACTUALLY WE
WILL OF DONE THAT STUDY FROM
THIS SIDE OF THE AVENUE AVENUE
AND I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE
THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
BEING. VERY STRONG ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY IN
PARTICULAR GENDER EQUALITY AS
WELL WILK- IF NECESSARY FOLLOW
UP AFTER THE INFORMATION IS.
RECEIVED AND- TRY TO MAKE
WHATEVER ADJUSTMENTS ARE
NECESSARY UNDER AN ABSOLUTELY
IT IS A TOTAL LOSE LOSE
SITUATION. NO MENTION THIS SHOW.
WITH THAT WE HAVE I BELIEVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR MONNING THE
MOTION IS. ADD TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT MADAM CONSULTANT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
THERE'S PLEASE TURN OUR
MICROPHONE'S ON THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE BERRYHILL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CAN
AND PERHAPS MY APOLOGIES I
SHOULD LET THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CLOSE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
WOULD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE- VAST.
JUST GOT. AND PART OF A LOT OF
WHAT I HAVE HEARD I WILL REPEAT
AGAIN IS JUST IMPLICIT BIAS
THAT THERE ARE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY THAT. ARE USING OUR
PRISON SYSTEM TO AVOID. PAYING
THEIR CHILD SUPPORT WHICH TO ME
IS LUDICROUS. YOU CAN HAVE A
SITUATION IN WHICH- PARENTS ARE
HOPING TO FEED THEIR KIDS. ARE
COMMIT A CRIME OF ROBBING FOOD
AND THEN GOES TO PRISON. YOU
CAN LOOK AT THAT AND SAY. WAS
THAT INDIVIDUAL TRYING TO HELP
THEIR CHILD WHILE THEY'RE
PAYING CHILD SUPPORT WHAT KIND
OF SYSTEM DO WE HAVE WHICH
ALLOWS AN INDIVIDUAL TO
CONTINUE TO WOULD GET PENALTIES
AND FEES WHILE MAKING EIGHT
CENTS AN HOUR. AND THEN GETS UP
ON AND THEN GET THEIR LICENSE
REVOKED BECAUSE THEY HAVE
OUTSTANDING CHILD SUPPORT DEBT.
CAN'T GET TO A JOB. DOESN'T
HAVE TRANSPORTATION. CAN BARELY
AFFORD TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
THEN THEY CONTINUE TO HOW
ISSUES WITH THEIR CHILD SUPPORT
AND THEN GO BACK INTO PRISON WE
HAVE HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
IN BOTH HOUSES- ON BREAK DOWN
THE TUITION ALLIES RATE THEM
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR THIS. IF
IDEA THAT YOU CAN PAY CHILD
SUPPORT WILL MAKING EIGHT CENTS
AN HOUR IS RIDICULOUS. AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS BUT I JUST
HOPE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY TRUE
TO OUR WORD AND IF WE ARE TO
SAY THAT WE ARE ABOUT HELPING
PEOPLE IN OURS. THAT WE BEGIN
TO LOOK AT LAWS SECOND
TENUOUSLY HARM PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND IF WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
MEN. ACTUALLY HAVE A HARM. MEN
OF COLOR MOSTLY FULL ARE LET ME
IN BLACK. IN OUR STATE. I HOPE
THAT WHILE WE DELIBERATE ON
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE THERE ARE
ACTUAL PEOPLE WHO ARE HURTING.
AND WHO NEED THIS LEGISLATURE
TO ACT AND TO ACT NOW I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ZERO.
THANK YOU MADAM CONSULTANT IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FROM THE MOTION THAT WAS MADE
BY A I BELIEVE SENATOR MONNING.
AGAIN PLEASE TURN TO MIKE FUNDS
ON THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE
CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
JACKSON BY. TEXAN NINE BARGES
FIVE. BRIDGES I DID A SO I DID
A SO HI GOOD SERVICE I. SERVICE
I MELENDEZ. MONNING THANK
MONNING I STE TURNED BUT I.
STERN I I'M BURKE HI AMBERG I
Y. CALLES KEY HI BY CASKEY I.
HE HAVE EIGHT ZERO ONE MEMBER
MISSING RIGHT WE WILL- THE BILL
COUNT AS A TWO ZERO WILL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL. FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. AND NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
NINE BY- IT'S AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RADIUS AND THIS IS ON ACTION
DEALING WITH CIVIL ACTIONS AND
WRONGFUL DEATH AND IT HAS AN
EMERGENCY PROVISIONS SO. OF
MADAM REYES THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO THEIR PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE WHICH
WILL EXTEND TO LEGAL GUARDIANS
THE RIGHT TO BRING A CLAIM ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CHILD IF THE
CHILD PASSES AWAY DUE TO THE
WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF OTHERS.
CURRENT LAW SPECIFIES THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BRING A
CAUSE OF ACTION FOR THE DEATH
OF A PERSON BECAUSE FOR THE
WRONGFUL ACT OR NEGLECT. OF
ANOTHER. THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
LIMITED TO THE DECEDENT'S
SPOUSECHILD AND IN SOME CASES
THE PARENTS. SPECIFICALLY FOR
MINOR PASSES AWAY DUE TO THE
WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF OTHERS AND
THE MINOR IS ON MARRIED AND
DOES NOT HAVE CHILDREN. THAN
THOSE WHO CAN BRING FORTH A- BY.
THE MY LEGAL GUARDIANS HAVE NOT
OFFICIALLY ADOPTED THE MINOR
THESE LEGAL GUARDIANS DO NOT
HAVE LEGAL STANDING TO BRING A
CLAIM IN THE EVENT OF A
WRONGFUL DEATH EVEN THOUGH BOTH
OF THE CHILD'S PARENTS DECEASED.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
CORRECT THIS OVERSIGHT LAW BY
ALLOWING LEGAL GUARDIANS TO
BRING FORTH A WRONGFUL DEATH
CASE BUT ONLY WHEN THE DECEASED
CHILD'S PARENTS. HAVE ALSO
PASSED AWAY. AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE ALLOWS A LEGAL
GUARDIAN TO SEEK JUSTICE FOR
CHILD WAS PASSED AWAY DUE TO
THE WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF OTHERS
WHEN THE CHILD'S PARENT CANNOT
DO SO. BECAUSE THEY ARE
DECEASED THIS BILL IS AN IS AN
URGENCY MEASURE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF DESERVING
LEGAL GUARDIANS TO PROSECUTE
WRONGFUL. ACTIONS ON BEHALF OF
THEIR MINOR CHILDREN. TIME IS
OF THE ESSENCE TO ENSURE THAT
WRITERS CLAIMS ARE NOT TURNED
AWAY DUE TO ANTIQUATED LEGAL
BARRIERS. HERE TO TESTIFY VIA
TELEPHONE TODAY I HAVE BILL.
GALLO WANTED WAS AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE LAW FIRM OF TAYLOR AND
RING. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY. THE
LET US SOME HERE FROM MR GILL
WHAT I BELIEVE HE IS ON THE
PHONE AND READY TO SPEAK IS
THAT CORRECT. A THANK YOU
MISTER GILL WHAT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT HE IS THE ONLY WITNESS AND
IF THAT'S THE CASE HE DOES HAVE
UP TO THREE MINUTES IF HE
WISHES TO TAKE IT THANK YOU.
MISTER GILL WHAT THE FLOORS YOU.
THANK YOU CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME
OKAY. YES. OKAY MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO ALL OF
YOU ABOUT THIS BILL BY WAY OF
INTRODUCTION MY NAME IS NEIL
KELLER WHY I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS FOR IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO FOUR FOUR
FIVE. BEACH WILL. I PRACTICE IN
THE AREA OF SERIOUS PERSONAL
INJURY WRONGFUL DEATH AND
SEXUAL ABUSE ABOVE ALL AB TWO
FOUR FOUR FIVE IS ABOUT
FAIRNESS THE BILL AIMS TO
CORRECT INEQUITIES IN THE LAW
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE A
MINOR DIES TO THE WRONGFUL
CONDUCT OF OTHERS UNDER SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES THE RIGHT CARE IS
IN THE WRONG ACTION. THERE WAS.
NINE CHILDREN ARE THE MINOR'S
PARENT HOWEVER IF THE MINERS
PARENTS PREDECEASED HIM OR HER
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
MINERS LEGAL GUARDIANS TO WRITE
FULLY STEP INTO THE SHOES OF
THE MINERS PARENTS CAN PURSUE
WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIMS ON HIS OR
HER BEHALF. AS WE THE LOS WE
ALREADY IN SHIP IS NOT ENOUGH
THE LAW REQUIRES THE MINERS
LEGAL GUARDIAN TO HAVE FORMALLY
ADOPTED THE MINOR IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO BRING A LAWSUIT ON
THE MINOR'S BEHALF. OWNER IT IN
CANADA. DID SHOULD ELIMINATED
AS THE LAW SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE
CHANGING NATURE OF FAMILY. THIS
BILL WOULD STILL REQUIRE THESE
LEGAL GUARDIANS TO BE FORMALLY
APPOINTED AS SUCH BY THE COURT
PRIOR TO THE MINOR STAFF. THIS
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WOULD
STILL REQUIRE A JUDICIAL
OFFICER TO EVALUATE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDERLYING THE
APPOINTMENT THANK INCLUDED THE
PARTY'S BRINGING THE
APPLICATION SHOULD IN FACT BE
OF THE MINERS LEGAL PARTY. IT
SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED THAT THIS
BILL WILL NOT EXPAND THE
UNIVERSE OF PLANETS THAT MARK
MAY PURSUE A WRONGFUL DEATH
ACTION ON BEHALF OF THE MINE.
RATHER IT NEARLY ALLOW
GUARDIANS TO STEP INTO THE
SHOES OF THE MINERS PARENTS
WHEN BOTH PARENTS HAVE PASSED
AWAY. IN SOME AB TWO FOUR FOUR
FIVE NARROWLY AND THEN TO
EXISTING LAW TO ALLOW FOR THE
FULL PROSECUTION OF WRONGFUL
DEATH ACTION. STEPPING INTO THE
SHOES OF THE PARENT IS NO EASY
TASK WHEN INDIVIDUALS TAKE ON
THIS NOBLE VENTURE THEY SHOULD
BE AFFORDED THE SAME RIGHTS
AFFORDED TO THE MINORS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES LINED UP TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THIS MEASURE. ANY
SPECIFIC MESSAGES INDIVIDUALS
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE SITE.
CHING NON DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WHO WISH TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE SITE AND- SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONES. MATTER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE-
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY FIVE. AND I WILL
GIVE YOU A FEW SECONDS AND THEN
PLEASE. INDICATE HOW MANY THERE
ARE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR
FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BETTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU INDICATE
FOR US IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES AND IF SO HOW MANY.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
IF THAT WITNESS WOULD GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED MATTER MORE
MODERATOR. THANK YOU I WON
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANY REPAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND- ONE
LAST TIME ANY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ITEM AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE SO INDICATE
NOW SO THAT THE MODERATOR CAN
PUT YOU IN THE QUEUE. TO HAVE
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES MATTER
MODERATOR. I HAVE NO FOR THE
LINES IN Q. AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. THE LET'S GO
AHEAD NOW WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
CUTE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL ANY WITNESSES WHO
HAVE BEEN SIGNED UP TO DO SO. I
DON'T BELIEVE SO I'M JUST
CHECKING TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
ONE IS PRETTY SIGNED FOR.
OPPOSITION WITNESS TESTIMONY
MADAM. MODERATOR. SIR ANYONE
LINED UP IN THAT Q. AT THIS
POINT. GUARD HEARING NONE HAVE
NOT LINE. I'M SORRY. I HAVE NO
LINE THINGS AREN'T VERY GOOD
LET'S SEE IF THEY'RE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. SEEING NONE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE LET'S GO
BACK TO MATTER MODERATOR AND IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE VIA
TELECONFERENCE- AHMED A
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AT THIS TIME.
AB TWO FOUR FOUR FIVE PLEASE-PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MATTER MODERATOR. I HAVE
NO LINES INTO YOU AT THIS TIME
RIGHT WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE DíAS I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS THIS IS REALLY COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT TOWARDS THE SAME
RIGHTS TO LEGAL REPRESENTATION
BY IN THE CONTEXT AS PARENTS
AND- JUST AS IT DOES IN OTHER
CONTEXTS SO OF THE STREET I
BELIEVE THE SAME STRICT TRICK
TOWARD PLY. TO LEGAL GUARDIAN
PARENTS YOUR CHEST ALLOWING
THEM THE IF YOU WILL STAND IN
SHOES I THINK IS THE
EXPRESSION. AND THE ONE WHO
ARE. THANK YOU FOR THE MEASURE-
OTHER ANY COMMENTS. THE BILL
THERE IS A MOTION BY. SENATOR
UMBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I THINK
RECALLING THE LEGAL GUARDIAN TO
BRING AN ACTION IN THE SAME
MANNER. AS ANY OTHER PARENT
WILL UPDATE THE WRONGFUL DEATH
STATUTE TO BETTER REFLECT THE
CURRENT REALITIES OF FAMILY
LIFE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT- MADAM CONSULTANT WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS PLEASE TURNER
MICROPHONES OFTEN THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINE IN NAY B. TWO FOUR
FOUR FIVE ASSEMBLY FOR PRESS.
AND IS DEEP OF THIS FLOOR.
JACKSON BY. JACKSON AYE BURGESS
HI. LARGEST AYE DRESSEL HI
RUSSEL I GONZALEZ HI. GONZALEZ
I MELENDEZ. MORNING HI MONNING
AYE STERN. STERN I AM BURKE I
AMBERG I Y. CASKEY HI MY CASKEY
I THAT EIGHT ZERO ONE REMEMBER
MISSING HI OF THE VOTE COUNT IS
EIGHT TWO ZERO WE HAVE ONE FOR-
NOT IN THE ROOM SO WE PUT A
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU SIMPLY
MAKE REYES. NEXT UP WE- A SAM
MEMBER. WHO I THINK IS BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY. AND HE HAS
BEFORE US FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
THIRTY TWENTY REGARDING UNFAIR
PRACTICES THE ON FOR PRACTICE
ACT. AND THE IF WE CLEANED OFF
EVERYTHING'S READY TO GO A
SICKLY MANDATORY THE FLOOR
SHOOTERS- THANK YOU MEASURE I
WILL BE BRIEF THIS BILL. IS
FAMILIAR TO ME MEASURES
COMMITTEE AS IT APPROVED YEAR
HAS AB TEAMS SEVEN HOWEVER BILL
WAS UNFORTUNATELY VETOED AB
THREE TWENTY OF REQUIRES
PENALTIES COLLECTED BY THE CITY
TO CITY ATTORNEY FROM ACTION
UNDER THE UNFAIR COMPETITION TO
BE PAID IN TO THE CITY DIEGO
MEMBERS THIS HAS NO OPPOSITION
BUT IN THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO. SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME THIS MORNING BY
PHONE I SPEAKERS HE TO MARK.
THANK YOU. CONCISELY XIN TATIAN
MUCH PREPAID OF WE HAVE A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE. IS SAN
DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MARK
ELLIOTT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING I
SAN DIEGO THREE ATTORNEY MARA
ALLIOT UNDER STATE LAW FOR THE
ATTORNEY TO SERVICE CITY OF
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND HAVE AUTHORITY TO
BRING ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
BASED ON ON OUR COMPETITION
LAWS ON BEHALF PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHEN
CHOOSING WHICH CASES TO PURSUE
I LOOKED FOR EGREGIOUS CASES.
WHERE OUR ENVIRONMENT IS BEING
HARMED CONSUMERS ARE BEING. THE
WORKERS ARE BEING SHORT CHANGED
FINANCE SCRUPULOUS EMPLOYER OR
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF OUR
PEOPLE IS JEOPARDIZED WE
TYPICALLY GIVE THE BUSINESS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLY. AND THEN
WE BRING LITIGATION WHEN OUR
EFFORTS TO EDUCATE AND GAIN
COMPLIANCE FAIL. WE'VE BROUGHT
CASES THAT ALLOWS CENSURE HARD
WORKING SAN DIEGANS ARE PAID
WHAT THEY'RE I WOULD COME TO
WORK THEY PERFORMED. RUMORS ARE
NOT CHARGED HIS. WIFE EXPLOITED
POLLUTANTS ARE REMOVED FROM OUR
WATER WAYS AND THAT'S FOR A
TICKET TO OPIOIDS CAN ACCESS
THE SERVICES THEY NEED TO
RECOVER FROM ADDICTION. BECAUSE
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE SAN DIEGO.
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO MUST SHARE THE CIVIL
PENALTIES IT RECOVERS FROM
THESE CASES WITH THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO EVEN IF THE COUNTY
DOES NOT AND THE SINGLE SECOND
ASSISTANCE WITH THE CHANGES. IT
THE CASE UNDER THIS LAW
RECOVERS PETE. A LOT OF NEW
WORK THE COW TO SHOW THE
CURRENT IT. THE DISTRIBUTION IS
NOT FAIR AND IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE RECOVERING FULL PENALTIES
FOR THE WORK WE DO IS VERY
IMPORTANT. WE REINVEST THE
PENALTIES WE WRITE WE RECOVER.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING FOR
CONSUMERS WORKERS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. IT'S UNFORTUNATE
WE MUST REJECT THE CASE BECAUSE
THE COST TO PUT YOUR PURSE
TRIMMING AND- IS OUTWEIGHED BY
THE PENALTIES WILL RECOVER.
UNDER EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO WOULD KEEP
ALL THE PENALTIES ARE COVERED
AND WHEN THE RECOVERY IT'S
USUALLY. ONLY WHEN OUR COVERAGE
IS ONLY TO OWN EFFORT. I. YOU
TO SUPPORT EIGHTY THIRTY
TWENTY. WITH ME ON THE LINE IS
THE CHIEF DEPUTIES ATTORNEY
MARK AND CORN RAN ARE
PERMISSIBLE AND FORCED UNIT AND
IT'S AVAILABLE TO HELP ME
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS WILL HAVE MISTER AND
CORN JOIN US BUT AT THIS POINT
MY UNDERSTANDING IS HE HEARS
HE'S HERE FOR TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE ON. WITH THAT- DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. IT'S
A. B. THIRTY TWENTY ITEM
FIFTEEN WHO ARE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING NONE
LET'S GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES THERE.
SEEING NONE. WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONES AND I WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE ARE TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER. IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIXTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR AGAIN IT'S ON THE
SCREEN HERE BUT I'LL REPEAT IT.
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR. THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX ONE. ONE
ONE. ONE SEVEN NINE SIX ONE ONE
ONE ONE SEVEN NINE AND LET'S
SAY A Q. THOSE FOLKS SHOP IF
THERE ARE ANY PEOPLE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TWENTY. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TWENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE GIVE US THE TOTAL OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I A LIFE INTO AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU ARE WILL GIVE ANOTHER TEN
SECONDS IN CASE ANYONE WISHES
TO. PARTICIPATE. ARE THERE ANY
SUCH WITNESSES MATTER MODERATOR.
I HAVE NO LINE THINK YOU AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE SPORT SURE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
ARE I BELIEVE WE DO NOT HAVE-
ANYTHING ONLINE DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. XING NON DO WE HAVE ANY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NON. BY IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MATTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY TWENTY
AND WILL ASK YOU TO TAKE ABOUT
TEN INSTALL ITEM UP IN INTO A
PRICE TO SEE IF IN FACT THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WHO WISH TO SPEAK
OUR ONLINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTY TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
DO WE HAVE ANY SUCH OPPOSITION
MATTER MODERATOR. I HAVE NO
LINE RINGS YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OF WE WILL
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS I WANNA THANK YOU
BYE MEMBER LAURIE FOR BREATH
THE BILL WE HEARD THAT
PREVIOUSLY WITH RESPECT TO ALL
COUNTIES THAT HAD SEVEN
HUNDRED. THOUSAND OR MORE
RESIDENTS AND I THINK BASICALLY
THOSE ARE SAN FRANCISCO. SAN
JOSE AND LOS ANGELES- AT THIS
POINT THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
AND THE BILL ONLY FOCUSES ON
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW THERE IS AN ARGUMENT
OF FAIRNESS ARGUMENT THAT IF
YOU BRING THE ACTION YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO REAP THE BENEFITS-
THERE WAS SOME DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT THAT THAT CAME. FROM SOME
OF THE OTHER JURISDICTIONS BUT
CLEARLY SAN DIEGO. RESOLVED ITS
STIFF AND- WITH THAT I
CERTAINLY THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT UP. TO THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO CONTINUE TO
MAXIMIZE THEIR EFFORTS AND
THAT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS-BILL OR THAT'S WHAT IT APPEARS
AS BILL'S GOING TO DO IN ORDER.
TO WHAT SUGGESTS CAN. IN THE
PEOPLE THE COUNTY AND I COULD
COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
AND- CERTAINLY LOOK FOR TO SPUR
IT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. WITH THE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR UMBERG
TO MOVE THE BILL WE HAVE A
COMMENT BY MISTER BORCHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. US BRAND
THE OF HONOR HEADING INTO YOUR
NAKED WOODS CHATTING WITH THE
YOUR MAYOR ON CODE RE OPENING
UP POLICIES AND JUST ACTUALLY
LOVE YOUR BACKYARD- WHEN THIS.
BILL CAME MINUTES EARLIER
VERSION I HAD EXPRESSED
CONCERNS THAT IT WOULD HIT
COUNTIES AGAIN CITIES AND VICE
VERSA AND I STILL HAVE THAT ARE
CONCERNED AS I EXPRESSED
EARLIER. AND THIS IS. FOCUS
ONLY ON SAN DIEGO WHICH I DON'T
KNOW WHY THERE CAN'T BE A
COUNTY CITY REVENUE SHARING
AGREEMENT I THINK EVERY YEAR
EVERY COUNTY AND CITY GO
THROUGH SOME SORT OF REVENUE
SHARING DISCUSSION OR EVERY
NUMBER OF YEARS- I'M SURPRISED
JUST BY VIRTUE OF LOCAL CONTROL
IF THEY CAN'T. REACH SOME SORT
OF ACCOMMODATION IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE ARE THESE PARTIES
JUST AT AN IMPASSE. WELL NOT
CITY WILL HAVE CONSENSUS
BETWEEN BUT THE CITY IN THE
COUNTY ON THIS BILL AND SUPPORT
FOR- THAT CONSIDER CROSS
AMERICAN SINCE THIS NOT EVIDENT
IN THESE OTHER. CITIES THAT THE
CHAIR REFERENCE AS A
CONSEQUENCE THE BILL HAS BEEN
NARROWED TO EXCLUDE THEM. ALL
RIGHT- I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT
IF THIS HAPPENS IN SAN DIEGO-
WE'RE GOING TO BE FINE THAT-
THE CITY OF FRESNO FOR EXAMPLE
IS GOING TO WANT TO HAVE-
SOMETHING DIFFERENT- FRESNO
COUNTY OR JUST ACROSS THE
STATE- BUT- MOST IMPORTANTLY-
HOW. AGAIN IS THIS SATISFACTORY
OF CONDITIONS OF HAVING. A BILL
HEARD THAT WAS MY LOOK MY
ULTIMATE LAST POINT HERE IT'S
NOT CODE RELATED IT'S NOT TIME
SENSITIVE- OR- WHAT WHAT IS THE
ULTIMATE BECAUSE IT THIS SOUNDS
LIKE. THIS S THE JANUARY BILL.
LET ME AS FRAZIER CONCERNED IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE RECORD
BECAUSE UP FRESNO CANNOT BRING
THESE KINDS OF ACTIONS UNDER
STATE LAW CURRENTLY IS TOO
SMALL. SO IT'S ONLY CITIES OF
SEVENTY THOUSAND OR MORE SO IF
THAT KEEP ME UP NIGHTS YOU
COULD SLEEP SOUNDLY TONIGHT
OKAY HA HA HA CONSISTING TO
COVET YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE BEING
SQUEEZED IN THIS PANDEMIC AND
THEIR REVENUES ARE PLAN. MAKING
AND HAVING TO CHOOSE VERY VOCAL.
FORTIES ABOUT WHAT TO PERSON
WHAT NOT TO PURSUE TO THE
EXTENT THAT OUR CITY ATTORNEY
HE HEARD FROM A MOMENT AGO IS
ACTIVELY HAND COLLUDED CONSUMER
PROTECTION CASES BUT HAS TO
JUDGE ON THE FACT THAT IF SHE
SPENDS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN DOING IT. SHE'LL FOR
THE REVENUE BACK SO. FOR SHADI
TESTING. THROUGH DOING I DID
DRIVE OF OPERATIONS CHARGING
CUTS NOT DOING CALL TEST. ARTS
TWENTY WANTS TO PASS THAT THE
RIGHT NOW SHE ONLY GETS HOW OF
THE- THAT COMES TO THE PROJECT.
THE COMES AFTERWARDS AND IF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO THE SAME
THING SHE GETS. NOTHING SO I
HUMBLY SUGGEST THAT THIS TIME
WITH CONSUMERS ARE BEING
SQUEEZED BY UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS.
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO HAVE OUR
PUBLIC WATCHDOGS AFTER DOING
THE WORK AND THIS WILL MAKE IT
MORE LIKELY AND BECAUSE THE
REVENUES UPON MANY ACTION MAKES
IT LESS LIKELY WITHOUT THIS
LEGISLATION. I WILL CERTAINLY
APPLAUD THAT EFFORT TO DRAW A
NEXUS OUGHT TO COVERED AS
UNIQUE AND CREATIVE AS IT WAS.
AND WHAT IF. BIGGIE GETS BACK
THE- THE OVERALL ON THE OVERALL
IMPORT OF THIS IS WHETHER IT'S
LIMITED TO COUNTIES OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR CITIES
RATHER- THE IDEA OF CREATING A
CONTEST BETWEEN MUNICIPALITIES
AND COUNTIES EVER SIZE THEY MAY
BE. HAVING SERVED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IN BOTH LEVELS THAT'S WHY
THAT'S BIGGEST SIR IS THAT WE
ARE JOB CREATING AN ATMOSPHERE
OF REVENUE CONTROL AND- BEING
VERY DOGGEDLY IN TERMS OF- WHO
HAS TURF HERE VERSUS TURF THEIR
THING. IT'S IT IS SAN DIEGO.
WOULD ARE AND VISOR LEFT
RESPECT YOUR GOOD EFFORTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR. MY TEACHING
NO OTHER OMMENTS- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR UMBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SPECS
WE ASK YOU HAVE A GOOD RIDE AND
CONSULTANT IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SEC PLEASE TURN
YOUR MICROPHONES ON. L. ITEM
FIFTEEN AB THIRTY TWENTY GLORIA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. JACKSON I AND I
PORGES. WHAT IS NOT VOTING TO
WRESTLE I. RUSSELL AYE GONZALEZ
I BEEN TELETHON A MELINDA'S NOW
MELENDEZ NELL MINING AYE AYE
MONNING AYE STERN. BUT I TURN I
AM BURKE HI NUMBER I WAKE CLYDE
WAY CASKEY I. THAT'S SEVENTY
ONE ALL MEMBERS HERE. THE
ACCOUNT IS SEVEN AT THE TWO ONE
ONE NOT VOTING THE MEASURE OF
PASSES THE BILL IS OUT EIGHTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. YEAH. IT HOPE.
THE COMPLICATED RIGHT THAT ONE
IS NOT AVAILABLE RIGHT ON
DOMESTIC WORK ON IN A MAIN
HIGHWAY THIS IS SO THAT'S JOB.
WE HAVE NECK UP OF THOSE MAY
WHERE OFF I ITEM. AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE TASK FORCE TO STUDY
AND DEVELOPE REPARATION
PROPOSALS FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN THE SENATOR BRADFORD WELCOME
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER I BELIEVE. CORRECT
AND BEFORE YOU TO BEGIN NO I
TALKED TO SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE WE WANT TO GIVE A- BIG
SHOUT OUT. TO THE ALICE'S ALL
PAGES OF IT THERE WAS A DONE BY
ALISON. MEREDITH OF IT I THINK
IT IS ONE OF THE BEST HISTORY
LESSONS THAT WE COULD ALL HAVE
IN THE PERIOD OF TWENTY FIVE
PAGES AND- I WOULD INVITE AND
ENCOURAGE OF NOT ONLY THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE IF
THEY DIDN'T WEREN'T ABLE TO
READ THROUGH. THAT I THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD READ SO I WANT
TO GIVE HER A SHOUT OUT AS WELL
AND THE HOPE THAT ONE WILL
REDUCE IT'S REALLY QUITE TO.
EXCEPTIONAL AND TERM APPRECIATE
HER HARD WORK IN THAT AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR-
BEING HERE TODAY SENATOR
BRADFORD TO PRESENT THE BILL.
Q. AND I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
ANALYSIS AND I THINK IT MAKES A
STRONG ARGUMENT FOR ANOTHER
ISSUE THE DOCTOR WHAT PERCENT
CAMPAIGN AND THAT'S UP NEXT
THIRTIES INSTEAD. SO ON THE DAY
AS NOT ONLY CALL UP THERE BUT
VICE YOUR LUNCH SO CAUCUS ON
BEHALF OF DOCTOR WHERE BRUISER
CHEER IMPRISONED AB. TWENTY
PLEASE TOP FORCED STUDY AND OF
RAPPORT. PURPLE FOR THE
DESCENDANTS OF AND PEOPLE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES THE TASK
FORCE WILL CONSIST OF EIGHT.
APPOINTED MEMBERS AND WILL
COMPILE THE HISTORICAL RECORD A
BLACK SLAVERY AND AFTERMATH IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS NATION. THE
BILL WOULD BAR TASK FORCE
DIRECT. CORPORATE WEIGHT
RESPOND TO THE HISTORY OF IN
SOME REMOTE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
STATEHOOD IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY AN
END OF SLAVERY IN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE CALIFORNIA. WAS A
FREE STATE IN NAME ONLY NOW
I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN IN NAME
ONLY THE STATE. HE'S OUT POLICE
OF. IN SLAVERY HEARING ALL FOR
EXAMPLE THIS LED TO BY ALL
SOUTHERN FLAVOR. THE WHOLE
PEOPLE IN BONDAGE AS LONG AS
HAD ENTERED THE STATE WHAT
THEY'RE IN SLAVE PROPERTY ARE
TO STATEHOOD. CALIFORNIA COURTS
EARLY BY THREE FOR THOSE WHO
DARED TO. THE BONDS OF SLAVERY
IN CALIFORNIA. IN EIGHTEEN
THIRTY TWO CALIFORNIA ADOPTED A
HARSH FUGITIVE FUGITIVE SLAVE
ACT IN PARMA STATE AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES TO
FORCE SELF **** PERSONS. BACK
INTO THE CHANGE AND ENSLAVEMENT
THEY ALSO A PASSED THE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO ALSO IN RESPONSE TO
FREEZE BLACK AMERICANS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT ORDER FUGITIVE
SLAVES. AS IS. STORE IN THIS
STORE CASE SUCH AS SAY A PARTY
LEE RETURNED TO THEIR IN
FLAVORS IN DIRECT VIOLATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
UNTIL THE END OF THE U. S.
CIVIL WAR LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. AND FOR ALL THIS ON.
ALICIA CONTRACT LAY SYSTEM.
ALLOWING ALL. HOLDERS TO
EFFECTIVELY HOLD PERSONS IN
BONDAGE FOR ANOTHER NAME. IN
OTHER WORDS CALIFORNIA STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT ACTIVELY
SUPPORTED BLOCKS SLAVERY TO SAY
NOTHING OF THE MANY RACES
POLICIES THAT CAME AFTERWARDS I
COULD SEE IF WE RE IN THIS
COUNTRY WAS BONDAGE OF ANOTHER
COMBINE RACES AN EXCLUSIONARY
LAW AND HOUSING. KING PATIENT
ENFORCEMENT I'M IN SO MANY
ASPECTS OF DAVID DAILY LIFE
MANY OF WHICH STILL EXISTS
TODAY. THE OWNER SAID AND IT'S
JUST. THIS YEAR BLACK MAKE UP A
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S. OF 40%
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION.
READY TO PUBLIC POLICY IN THE
STATE INSTITUTE BLACK MEN ARE
56% OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
BUT WE MAKE UP TWENTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE PERCENT. OF THOSE
INCARCERATED AND THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO THE LA ALL BY
NEARLY EVERY STATE MEASURE.
BLACKS K. TO TWELVE STUDENTS
HAVE A LORD'S PERFORMANCE OF
ANY RACIAL OR ETHNIC GROUP AND
THE STATE AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT COMMITTED TO
EDUCATION. EVIDENCE OF THE
LEGACY OF SLOW WHITE SUPREMACY
THAT STILL EXISTS IN THIS
COUNTRY COLBERT NINETEEN SHED
MORE LIGHT ON THESE PERSISTENT
DISPARITIES. THE BILL A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
ILLNESS AND DEATH TO THE
COLBERT NINETEEN HAS FALLEN
DRASTICALLY ON THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. AND SOME.
DISPLACEMENT CREATED A LEGACY
OF RACIAL INEQUALITY THAT
CONTINUES TO MOUNT BLACK IMPACT
BLACK PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY. THOSE WHO ARE COMES AMID
JUSTICE AT THE HANDS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REDRESS WHAT NOT GRANT. BUT
PEOPLE A LESSER STANDARD. THIS
BILL REQUIRES AN IN DEPTH
REVIEW OF THE IMPACT OF
SLAVERY. AND IN CALIFORNIA
INCREASE THE FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS THE SHAMEFUL HIS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
TODAY WE HAVE WITNESSES ANTONIO
MORE AND DOCTOR CAN JUST WATSON.
THANK YOU SENATOR. OF AGAIN I
NEED TO REITERATE THAT DUE TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEES ARE
ALL INSTITUTING TIME ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES. ALL OTHER WISH
THE PHARMACIST THEIR COMMENTS
TO THEIR NAME AFFILIATE IN M.
POSITION ON THE MEASURE AS
SHARON UNDER I WILL AGAIN
REITERATE THE PHONE NUMBER. ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR FOR.
1-111-636-4184. FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE. IS SIX ONE. ONE
ONE ONE SEVEN NINE THAT. SIX
ONE ONE ONE ONE SEVEN NINE AND
BEFORE WE PROCEED I'D LIKE TO
HAVE SOME ASSISTANCE HERE- MY
COMPUTER IS. NOT. FOCUSED ON
OUR HEARING AND I NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR- A MEMBER WHO IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IS ON
OUR SCREEN. WELL. I DON'T KNOW
WHERE WHERE THE OTHER. THANK
YOU RIGHT THE I FULLY THERE'S
SOMEONE WHO KNOWS WHAT'S GOING
ON HERE. ALRIGHT WITH THAT. WE
DO HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES AND
I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES. INTO IT
WHOEVER IS FIRST WOULD YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND PLEASE BE
BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY
REMEMBERING THAT IT HAS TO BE
SHARED SO WITH THAT WHO IS OUR
FIRST. THIS TONYA MORE THANK
YOU. ALLOW ME TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE A LOS MOVEMENT IN
AMERICAN THIS INTO SLAVERY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE ISSUE OF
RACISM IN CALIFORNIA CONNECTS
TO A LARGER. ROLE LEVEL
DISCRIMINATION FROM SLAVERY TO
BRED LINING THE RESULT IN COST.
RELATED OF MINUTES WHAT ANY
QUALITY AT EIGHT THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE WELL I JUST IN. THE
INTEREST OF THE FREE. WE MEET
THE FRAME OF THE STATE. THIS IS
THE DENIAL OF SOFT OF OTHER AND
RIGHT. SOME EVEN AT NIGHT ALL
AFTER AMERICAN CAL. CALIFORNIA
E. HAD A FEW SAVE FLAG
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS ANY PER
BROUGHT CAL PLEASE STAY OF THIS
WOULD BE CONSIDERED A SLAVE THE
ARE THE LAW EVEN THOUGH THE
CALIPHATE TUITION BANDS IN THE.
OUR OF BLACKS BROUGHT
CALIFORNIA GOLD RUSH THE RESULT
ACROSS IT CAN THAT COULD
AMERICAN WITH THIS HAVE IN THE
BENEFIT RAN WELL DO THAT
BECAUSE C<c.cyan> ACCORDING TO CAL</c>
MATTER BOARD ARTICLE IN TOLD
BLACK X. BLACK POPULAR. BY
PERCENT OF THE FORTY. IN
ADDITION A REPORT CALLED COLOR
WELL DONE BY YOU BUT LOS BY DO
IN THE PHOTO RESERVE FOR THE
REFLECT SHOWN THE WHITE FAMILY
LAFAYETTE AND WORK THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
HARD I SAID THE MIDDLE EAST
ASIA. FOR A SIXTY THOUSAND PART
IN OUR- LITTLE. FIVE THOUSAND
EVEN THE MIDDLE ACT BLACK
FAMILIES WORK A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND PART IN SIXTY
THOUSAND LOOKING THE MIDDLE
NATIVE A OS FAMILY IN THE STATE
OF LOS IS WORK A MERE TWO
HUNDRED LIKE WE- OUT. HEART THE
WAY THE MATING THAT WE WERE FOR
TO AMERICA THIS IS OF LIKE AB
THIRTY WILL TWENTY ONE AND I
WAS ASK YOU WELL I ONLY BE
THIRTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
SIR- CONNECT IS AFTER CAN JUST
WATSON OF THE RALPH J. BUNCHE I
BELIEVE IT'S PRONOUNCED CENTER
FOR AFRICAN KANNST BE SURE YOU
SEE I GOT ABOUT A MINUTE SIR.
PAUL NO THANK YOU. YOUR HONOR
THE YEAH BUT THE ON THE OF AN
THE BOARD OF THE BY THEN I'M
ACTUALLY THE RESEARCH LAB AT
HEALTH NET WE RESEARCH LAB IN
THE BY DEPARTMENT AT STATE. AND
THE CENTER AND I. TELL WHAT THE
FREE STATE IN NAME ONLY. AND
THESE. RARELY SIGHTED REALITY
THERE OR A FEW THEM STORE GOAL
AND EXPOSE WE CAN BLACK CALL
THEM CRACK. THAT IN THE ON
GOING EVERY DAY NEXT. THE ON
BLACK WELL WELL THAT ARE. THE
SO INCLUDES THE EXPAND TO DO IN.
PERSON IT. THE BLACK PEOPLE.
AND IF THEY IN ORDER THEM. WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER ALBUMS A RED
LINE. WITH THE DON'T CALLED.
AND REALLY GIVE BEFORE CALL
NIGHT. THANK YOU KIND TO ME
SPIKE ALL THE HEALTH CARE FOR
THE GENERAL. OUR LIFE THE- OF
BLACK REMAIN PEOPLE THAT DECADE
HAVE BLACK PEOPLE IN OUR MUCH
LESS PEOPLE. THREE OF HIGHER
RATE THE MARKET AND MORE THE
THERE. THREE OUT WELL AS LONG
THE ANY ABUSE BY WE AGENT. THAT
RECORD CASH HOW UNDERMINE BLACK
LIKE THANK YOU THE OUR NEXT.
FROM THE- OUT OF RIGHTLY FOR
THE LIFE ON LOOKING FOR BLACK
LAW. I THINK ASSERTION THAT THE
CONDITION THAT THEY NOT BEEN.
BY THE OF OUR OUT ARE BLATANT
YOU DOOR FOR INCREDIBLY CAR.
THE FACT ONLY. SHOWED THAT- THE
ENVOYS. FROM PLAYED THREE IF
THEY- HELD THE BLACK PEOPLE. I
HAVE ENOUGH. HERE TO ENGAGE IN
A STUDY OF HOW WE MIGHT USE THE
REDIRECT THE FAR. RIGHT DOCTOR
WHAT. BLACKROCK IS WE CALL ON
ALL OF THE FOR ITS PASSAGE THE
LEGISLATIVE. THE DE AND BREADTH
EVIDENCE THAT WILL CONSIDER
CRITICAL ISSUE IS GIVEN IT NEW
CAR AND CAUGHT THANK YOU SIR.
YOUR TEST. BARD AT THIS IN TIME
IF WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK OF IT WERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE IF YOU
WHICH GIVE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. YEAH YOU'RE ON THE
MARKET EIGHT IN FACT WERE
PROBABLY DOES CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE VOTE YES
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT WITNESS.
CHRIS LAWSON BABY IS MADE A
DEAL WITH SACRAMENTO EIGHTY WAS
CALIFORNIA ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED ME THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE HOLD ON. THANK YOU
IT'S SO NICE TO HAVE LIVE
BODIES HERE WE WELCOME YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
WILLINGNESS TO TESTIFY. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEEING NOT LET'S
GO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES WILLING AND
WANTING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SHOWING NON LET'S GO TO-
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. WE
WILL BEGIN WILL GIVE YOU A FEW
MOMENTS TO DO THAT AND THEN IF
YOU WOULD IDENTIFY HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE. IN
SUPPORT THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
META
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE GIVE
US A TOTAL OF THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVENTY FOUR IN Q.
SEVENTY FOUR. TO GET THE RIGHT.
SEVEN FOUR. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
HEAR AYE AYE SIR SAID IN HERE
THE NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR OKAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL. HERE
WE GO MADEMOISELLE MODERATOR.
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY. YEAH. NINE ONE
FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PROCEED
AGAIN FOLKS NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION YES NO ON THE
BILL- ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW WHICH
IS TAKING THOSE IN SUPPORT SO
IF YOU GO AHEAD META MODERATE.
IF YOU. THANK YOU WHAT ARE
TRYING TO FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
POSTED CURSING THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I AM TO FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM
LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU A RIDE IN A
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY THIS IS A VERY CHAU SPREAD
BECAUSE I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AFRICAN
AMERICAN CAUCUS AND AB YOU KNOW
BAKER. AND I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB THREE ONE EIGHT TWO
ONE. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE ONE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY
BROWN BELINDA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT OF
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
BENJAMIN TRANTER THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU LYING TO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND IN ADDITION ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI BOTH IN FRONT THE
PART OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M TO TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JUSTIN ROUSER ON BEHALF
OF ROOTS OF CHANGE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE TO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARIANNA ACOSTA ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IS
DONE BEFORE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WIND WIND
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO WE HEAR YOU GO HEAD OKAY
HI MY NAME IS KIM DIRE I'M WITH
A DEAL WITH LOS ANGELES AND I
SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE YEAH INDIA THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JAN LOCAL
MODEL A MEMBER OF NICKI
PROGRESSES- ORGANIZATION IN LOS
ANGELES I AM AT THE BORDER AND
EIGHTY OS AND I SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
VOTE YES ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
MAN NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
LINE ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I CAN HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY HUDSON AND I AM A PART
OF EIGHTY OR ITS ME AREA AND I
SUPPORT MAYBE THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE SO PLEASE VERY. STRONG TO
VOTE FIVE THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE ONE ON
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD OF ME.
HELLO THIS IS. TIFFANY
QUARRELSOME EIGHTY ONE
LAFAYETTE. CLEAN VOTE YEAH ON
AB ONE FOR ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NAY WITNESS. THANK YOU I AM
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELA NIRVANA
WITH A DEAL WAS SOLD CAL AND I
SUPPORT SB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I AM TO
SEVEN PLEASE OR HAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHAD BROWN WITH RADIO
AS LOS ANGELES I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY THE CHAPTER OF THE IN
THE LACI P. I SUPPORT SB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI TO THE JUST I WILL WITH ANY-
OS CAL AB- AS AREA AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE THESE ALL YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU RIDE ONE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STE HI THIS IS
COUNTY JOHN MUHAMMAD MEMBER OF
EIGHT US LOS ANGELES NEW
FRONTIER DAM CLOUT BLACK WOMEN
SAM CLUB AND THE END OF LIFE
THE P. IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
ONE TWO ONE THREE VOTE YET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
EVE BOUCHER WITH A. B. O. S.
LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT AB
ONE TWO ONE POLICE VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I ONE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A MARA
WILSON WITH EIGHTY OS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
VOTE YET. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I AM AT TO
PLEASE GO ADDED. THANK YOU HI
MY NAME IS LISA JORDAN AND I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE SENATE TO VOTE
YES ON A. B. THREE ONE TWO ONE
ON BEHALF OF A DEAL AT LOS
ANGELES THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RIDE A
ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MONIQUE QUARRELS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE VOTE YES. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I AM AT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I AM AT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WE HEAR
YOU. OKAY SORRY I AM- MINUTE
WORKING HERE THAT CONSTRUCTING
THUNDERING DOWN IT'S ABOUT JB
KEY IT YOU KNOW AT THE LOS
ANGELES. EIGHTY THREE TWO THREE
ONE TWO ONE BUT BUILT. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
RIGHT A ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS TARA PERRY
NINE A MEMBER OF A DEALER SO
CAL EIGHTY L. S. CALIFORNIA
BLACK PACKED DOT ORG I STRONGLY
URGE FOR AN IDLE ON EIGHTY
THREE ONE TWO ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN TO
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JANET TAYLOR I
AM A SUPPORTER OF AGL LAST AND
I SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE ONE TWO
ONE PLEASE VOTE YES ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU RYAN TO FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME LITTLE LOUDER WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY HI MY NAME IS
DAN WILLIAMS I'M WITH EIGHT OFF
AT ALL AT BLOCKS AND WITH IT
THE PORT OF AB THREE ONE THREE
ONE PLEASE VOTE YES ON A. B.
THREE ONE. THANK YOU WITNESS.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET'S
MOVE ON META MODERATE MY NUMBER.
THANK YOU AYE NUMBER SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
BEVERLY SOUTHERN WHEN I'M WITH
HBO AT ANGELES N. A. B. O. AT
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS IN THE
BLADE THE P. PASADENA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE AND I STRONG
URGE. ON FIND. THANK YOU RIDE
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I YES INDEED THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS ON YOUR MAC ROYAL HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT IN LOS ANGELES
AND I SUPPORT A. B. THE ONE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M TO
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL.
LINE TWO HNDRED AND THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY YOU GET
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES INDEED.
OKAY YEAH RAY FOR EVERY DAY
QUARRELED EIGHT O'CLOCK SANDERS
WITH BOMB WILL ARGUE TO VOTE
YES ON THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
MICHAEL THOMAS WITH A YOURS
CALIFORNIA AND I AM PART OF
THE- A DEALER SAN DIEGO BRANCH
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF BAY PACKS
AND YEAR AGO AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF AND DOUBLE ACP. SAN DIEGO
BRANCH- I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON A. B. THREE TWO ONE TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU LYING TO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE TWO TWO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE OF ON THE LINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS FIELD COMMENTS
AND I'M WITH EIGHT US
CALIFORNIA AND EIGHTY- SO CAL
AND I SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE AND I URGE YOU ALL
TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MONICA TOLIVER I WITH
THE AMERICAN DESCENDANTS OF
SLAVERY SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
INLAND EMPIRE HIGH GIVE IT
REGION AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
PLEASE SHOW YOUR SUPPORT BIRTH
BILL THREE ONE TWO ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU NEXT DOOR TO LINE ONE
NINETY YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS LAWRENCE ALEXANDER
I'M A MEMBER OF THE EIGHTY S.
MOVEMENT. FORMER SO THE DOCTOR
WHATEVER AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
WANT TO SUPPORT. AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS PRECEDED
DANGERFIELD ONE OF THE FOUNDING
MEMBERS OF THE AMERICAN LISTEN
CLOSELY READ THE CHAPTER AND A
MEMBER OF THE IN THE LACI P.
OAKLAND CHAPTER AND ONE OF THE
MANY DESCENDANTS OF SLAVERY IN
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE THE
SENATORS TO VOTE I ON A. B.
THREE ONE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU REID OF ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ARE YOU HATE WITH EIGHTY LEFT
LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY THREE THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE THE BILL GETS ON HEALTH.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NINE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DOCTOR DUSTIN
TAYLOR- CALL ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES CHAPTER OF EIGHTY
OS AMERICAN FLAVORING I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE AND I ASK YOU TO DO THE
SAME THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK MY NAME IS PAMELA GRAHAM
AND I AM A MEMBER OF A DEAL AS
I AM A US AND I AM ASKING THE
SENATE TO VOTE YES ON A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M MORE
THAN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT I. THIS IS LAURA WALKER IN
A VOTE YES IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ONE TWO ONE. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. STATE AND ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
YOU'RE TWENTY MCCARTY AND
GOALS- AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
A. B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE AND
I URGE YOU ALL TO LOOK AT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS RICKY BUT
WESTMORELAND I AM WITH A DEAL
AS LOS ANGELES AND- A DEAL A
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE AND DOUBLE ACP HOLLYWOOD
BRANCH AND I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE AND I A STRONG WE ASK THAT
YOU- NO YES ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I
DIDN'T SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE YOU DOING MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BRYANT I'M WITH A. B.
O. S. LOS ANGELES. SUPPORT A.
B. THREE ONE TWO ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS THE OF THE DELL AND I'M
A SUPPORTER DEBATE THE O. S.
AND I SUPPORT BILL EIGHT BE
THREE ONE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE TO FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
VALERIE WHITE FROM WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA AND I ASK THAT YOU
WOULD VOTE YES ON SENATE BILL.
AT AB THREE ONE TWO ONE AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK.
YOU I IN ONE ALL FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ELISA
DAVIS AND I SUPPORT A. B. THREE
ONE TWO ONE. PLEASE VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL. NAPA NICE VERY.
THANK YOU YOU TOO. X. WITNESS.
THANK YOU ARE LYING TO FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS WENDY DECLINE SHAPE RESIDENT
OF MONROVIA CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE TWO
ONE PLEASE VOTE YET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE LOS OPEN AND I'M
WITH THE NIKKEI FOR CAN REJECT
AND LOS ANGELES AND STRONG AB.
YOU WANT REPRESSIONS YOU. THANK
MIX WITH. THANK YOU I AM THIRTY
ONE GO OUT. HI THIS IS WHERE
SHE DOES HELP TACTIC AND I AM
WITH NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK
LOS ANGELES AS WELL AS A DEAL
LAST LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I AM TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
WE HEAR YOU HELLO WE HEAR YOU
OKAY THE TICKET ARRAIGNMENT AT
WHAT THE- THE EIGHTY- AND LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE DEAL THE A. B. THREE ONE
TWENTY LAST FROM SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I WANT FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
GLORIA WITH A DEALER FRIENDLY
AND I'D FOR COREY AB ONE CAN
MIGHT RESULT YEAH THANK THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
LINE TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KILEY
ALEXANDER FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY FOUR AND YOGA
CLASSES FOR THE MASSES I AM A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YET. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I AM TO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOHN TO CRAWSHAY OF ENGLAND
CALIFORNIA I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES ONTHE GROUND.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU
I ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE
BRAD. WHAT A RIDE OF TWO FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS THE NATION HAND FROM-
LA COUNTY DPSS THAT AND THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE PLEASE VOTE YET. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. HI THANK YOU
OVER A LINE OF TWO OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAMILLE MOORE AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I'M IN TROUBLE
SUPPORT AT A. B. THREE ONE TWO
ONE AND I URGE. JENNIFER MAY
VOTE ON THE MATTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I AM TO TWELVE PLEASE CALL
HAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DEVIN WAS
MULLIN WITH VIDEO AT AND NOT
THE POOR A. B. THREE ONE TWO
ONE THREE VOTE YES ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I'M TWO THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND I'M SURE AND
SENATORS THE CURVATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY ONE YEAH THANK YOU. THIS
Q. I WON EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH WILL
TWENTY NEXT LIKELY SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HERE IN THE TOMBS CALM WITH THE
DEAL WITH SAN DIEGO HAS
STRONGLY SUPPORT- SB TWO ONE
TWENTY ONE I'M SORRY AB TWO ONE
THREE ONE AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU OVER A WIDE
OF EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LEADER SPAN
LOOK AT OS LOS ANGELES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE AND URGENTLY CALLING
ALL MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
YES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU OVER A LINE OF TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT AT A.
B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I
WON ALL FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT WHAT OF ALL I HAVE
TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS TRACY CUT TO
KIANA AND I AM WITH MAKING
PROGRESS SAYS AND DIGITAL BOB
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID-
MEN AND- I MET AN AMERICAN
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVERY- WAS A
DEAL ESTATE AREA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
ONE TWO ONE AND- PLEASE VOTE
YES ON THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE- WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU IN SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARJORIE MELVIN AND I WOULD
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY OS INLAND
EMPIRE CHAPTER ALSO FORMER
CALIFORNIA PAROLE BOARD MEMBER.
EIGHTY THREE ONE TOOL TO ONE
AND I REQUEST THAT YOU VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN
TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BLIND MILITARISTIC WE HEAR YOU
AND YOUR MATE YEAH. HI MY NAME
IS ADRIANA HANNAH I'M UP HERE
IN NORFOLK AND I'M SUPPORTER OF
A D. O. S. AND I SUPPORT AB
THREE ONE TWO ONE PLEASE VOTE
YES ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU ARE LYING. TO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON. ALONG BEHALF OF
QUALITY KIND OF IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I AM TO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE STORE HAD.
MADAM CHAIR OF NUMBERS HANK MC
WITH SNAP MAKERS OF SNAPCHAT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU. ALRIGHT IF THE STORY
WITH A ELECT LOS ANGELES-
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE AND ASKING THAT
YOU- VOTE YES ON THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I DON'T ONE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SAMANTHA WALKER WITH A
D. O. S. LOS ANGELES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE. FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU RYAN AT ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS KISHA WAR I AM A
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY A LOT AND I
SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE ONE TWO
ONE PLEASE VOTE YES ON THE
SPELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BLIND ONE NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE TWO PHONE LINES
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
BRIANNA CROMARTIE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN DESCENDANTS OF SLAVERY
LOS ANGELES AND OUR MAIN STRONG
SUPPORT AND NINE COURAGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON A. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
WORK OUT OF BUYING TO THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS EBONY ALEXANDER I'M A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES AND AN
AMERICAN TO THINK IN A PLAY
FREE I STRONG SUPPORT AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE AND ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VOTE YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE TO THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GENEVIEVE GRAY I'M A RESIDENT
OF INGLEWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE CALL YES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I AM
THREE ARE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
USE DROWNED AT SEA FROM THE L.
S. BAY AREA. AND I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M THREE ALIVE AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I'M KEVIN FLORA NOR
KNOWN AS LEGAL TO LET ON
TWITTER A DEAL WITH. THEM IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
ROBERT- I AM THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE SIXTEEN
DROPPED IT I HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. AT THIS MOMENT ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD AND ASK
ONE MORE TIME IF THERE ARE. ANY
OTHERS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM. ON THE
LINE AT THIS MOMENT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE ONE TWO ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES MADAME MODERATOR. I
DO HAVE ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT NEW
LINES THAT. CUED UP ALL RIGHT
VERY GOOD LET'S PROCEED. WITH
ADDITIONAL THE WITNESSES AGAIN
THESE ARE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE.
MADAM A MODERATOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND OPEN THOSE LINES.
THANK YOU ITEM ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
A KILO MAC WHY I'M A MEMBER OF
ADOLF CALIFORNIAN ENOUGH LOS
ANGELES MARK PORT AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE- DUE TO ALSO BOTH
WITH THEM. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MOVE ON. TRYING TO
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. MARLIN WATSON A MEMBER
OF RADIO S. AND FOR SUPPORT OF
REPARATIONS FOR AMERICAN
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVERY WELL YES
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I AM THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
OKAY I AM- A PART OF A DEAL
LESS AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE TREES WITH A DEAL IN
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THREE ONE TWO ONE PLEASE
VOTE YET. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I'M ERICA THOMPSON
OF LOS ANGELES AND ONE OF MY
AND PLAY PATRIARCH CABLE CRAIG
WAS INTERVIEWED BY A CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN AND THE FEDERAL
FLAYED NARRATIVES. HE WOULD
ADMIT THAT ATONEMENT ILLEGAL
AND LEGAL MISTREATMENT. COULD
YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE. ONE ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
I AM TO SIX GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NINA BATTLE EIGHTY AWAY
FROM GEORGIA A STRONG SUPPORT
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
VOTE YES THANK YOU. WELCOME TO
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS AND WE THANK YOU I'M
TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE COUPLE I
HAD. HI MY NAME IS TERRY
MORRISON I'M A RESIDENT OF
INGLEWOOD- I'M A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND AN
AMERICAN DESCENDANTS OF SLAVERY
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE AND I URGE YOU
TO PLEASE VOTE YES. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
ITEM MODEL FOR PLEASE CALL US
AT. THE. NINE ONE ZERO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT. LET'S
MOVE ON. PINE THREE OH TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
WITH CHEESY HAIR AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB. THREE ONE
TWO ONE AND I STRONGLY SUGGEST
YOU DO AS WELL. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
HI MY NAME IS TAMPA NO SENSE
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT- YES VOTE ON
A. B. THREE ONE TWO ONE THANK
YOU. Q. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
I'M THREE I HAD. MY NAME IS
KRISTEN JACOBS FROM ENGLAND
HELPLINE IN AMAZON SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
VOTE YET THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M
THREE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ALEXANDER I AND NUMBER EIGHT
ON THE BAY AREA AND I STRONGLY
URGE EVERY TO VOTE YES ON A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE YOU CAN
DO IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M TO NINETY THREE WE HAD.
SECTION. AND THE- BILL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU BRIAN
THREE OR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CENTER THOMAS ON
ON THE STF NONPROFIT
CORPORATION IF I CAN A
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
A. B. THREE ONE TWO ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU I AM THREE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HI THIS IS THE
AMBER GRANT FINANCIAL ADVISER
WHICH STILL REMINDING
INCORPORATED FROM INGLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE ENCOURAGED EDITORS TO PASS
IT I AM A DESCENDANT OF. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
WILLIAM WHITE I AM A RESIDENT
AN EMPLOYEE WITH THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MY SUPPORT A. B.
THREE ONE TWO ONE. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M TO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE WHICH IS BORN ON THE
LOS ANGELES PRESIDENT AND
UNLIKELY CLICKABLE CLOSE TO
FIFTY A STRONG SUPPORT A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE ENERGY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY. I HAD. HELLO
HELLO. HELLO YES WE HEAR YOU.
THIS IS MARTY WILSON I'M WITH
A. B. O. S. SACRAMENTO. I'M
ALSO WITH CALIFORNIA BUT WE
HELP PROJECT I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
ARE TRYING TO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOR SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ONE TWO ONE ACTUALLY
SPOKE FOR IT CAPTION. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M
THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM PATRICIA HARASSMENT
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE AND I DESIRE TO HAVE
THE BILL PASSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M THREE
TABLET PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NATALIE SURE AND I
SUPPORT A. B. THREE ONE TWO ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS EMMA NORM TEN
MORE THAN OF INGLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHT B. THIRTY ONE TO ONE I
URGE TO VOTE YES. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE TO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS LOUIS A CARDIO AND
ON THAT RESIDENT OF INGLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE ONE TWO ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I AM
THREE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE ACT AND
SOME A LOS ANGELES CITY
RESIDENT AND I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL I'M SORRY A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M THREE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GLAD. HI MY NAME IS
ECONOMIST RECORDER AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE VOTE YET.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU I AM THREE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
THREE THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S GOING TO THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
THREE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME OK.
YES WHO CAN. MY NAME IS LINDA
WHY I'M OUT OF HIM IN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LYING TO
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SIOBHAN WHITE SAMSON
I'M IN MENIFEE CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO A PARTICIPANT IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I BILL YES. CHIU A.
B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU OF MINE THREE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LISA FAMILY OUT OF SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I'M A SUPPORTER OF A
DEAL AS AND I SUPPORT AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU RYAN THREE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JULIAN HELLO I'M IN AB S.
CARSON AND LOS ANGELES. POSTED
MAR SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE ONE
TWO ONE. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
TO EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRY MATTERS
OF A FOUNDING MEMBER EIGHT OF
EIGHT ALMOST FRESNO COUNTY AND
I STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH MY
EIGHT ALSO OTHERS INSISTED IN
SUPPORT OF AB B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS PAMELA DAVIS
I'M AT O. S. BAY AREA I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE
ONE TWO ONE. AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WELL I AM
THREE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS NAY REMAIN
ACT BRANCH I AM THE OWNER OF
RECORD IF IT IS NONPROFIT AND I
STAND IN AGREEMENT WITH A. B.
THREE ONE TWO ONE. YES THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT LET'S A CHECK ONE MORE
TIME IF YOU WOULD. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE TWO ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME.
AND I DO HAVE
ABOUT TEN NEW ONES IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT. OVER A
WIDER ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE ZERO FOR YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO I HAD. YES MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN BACK IT AND
I'M A SUPPORTER OF AID AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT
WHAT A LINE OF THREE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRIAN YOUNG FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I AM
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE TWO ONE.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU ITEM ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE
CALL HAD. LINE ONE FOUR TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE MOVE TO THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS EDDIE
JEANS WARNER FROM INGLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THE YEAH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I AM THREE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME THANK YOU TODAY
I'M NOT I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
THAT THREE ONE TWO ONE LEGAL
YEAH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I AM THREE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIGHER STILL
OF. IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE AND I VOTE YES. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M THREE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS THEY'LL
FRANCIS FROM EIGHTY OSS ANGELES.
NOW BUT A FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AS YOU TO YES YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WOULD PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
TERRA OUT ON A RESIDENT WALKS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B.
THREE ONE TWO ONE I HOPE THAT
YOU GUYS PLEASE VOTE YES THANK
YOU OF OUR PLASTIC CARE. THE
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I
AM THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT I AM THREE FIVE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS WILLIE
BRERA THE FRIENDS IN A KILLINGS
THE- AGAIN. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M THREE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M NOT GOING OF WATER.
AB YOUR- A LITTLE YEAH BE.
THIRTY ONE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I
THREE FOR NINE PLEASE AHEAD. HI
THIS IS FREE MATH PRESIDENT OF
IN CA. PLEASE DON'T YELL FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESS IN THE
Q. MAN MODERATE. I HAVE TWO
MORE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. I NEED TO RE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY AREA I AM NOT A
SUPPORTER OF THE A. B. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE AND I'M ALSO
PARK EIGHTY L. LAST. THANK
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE US YOUR
NAME FOR THE RECORD TEMP.
ALREADY MOVING ALONG TO THE
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I'M
THREE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THREE SIXTY SIX WITH
MARIE IN DAVIS AND I HOPE THE
TO VOTE THE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
OTHER OTHER WITNESS IN THE- I
NO FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU PART WITH
THAT OF WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO NOTICE
THAT THERE IS. ANYONE WHO IS OF
A SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ANY
OPPOSITION SO WE WILL MOVE THEN
TO. SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING NONE
ANY OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE WILL BRING
IT TO. YOU MODERATOR CHIU OF.
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY BE WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY
TWENTY ONE WE'LL GIVE IT A FEW
SECONDS. AND THEN ASK YOU TO
INDICATE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE. IS FOR PEOPLE
WISHING TO WISH TO SPEAK AND-
GO AHEAD IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE ONE
TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO OUT THIS TIME. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
QUEUE MADAME MODERATOR. I HAVE
NO LINES IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GIVE IT ONE MORE SECOND
OR TEN MORE SECONDS AND- THEN
WE WILL. BRING IT BACK TO THE
DIET SHIFT OR NO- COMMENTS.
FROM MARA THE- PHONE CALLS FROM
THE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE.
MADAME MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE
NO LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO DISCUSSION BY THE MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO START WITH THE
SENATE BOAR SENATOR. WHY CAN'T
SKI THE MORNING IN I BELIEVE
URBAN SO WHAT'S GOING AND THE
FOR SURE SENATOR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. MANY OF YOU THAT I
HAVE STRONG. IN BY IN GREEK
ARMENIAN. RELY ISSUES AND FOR A
LONG LONG TIME I HAVE ADVOCATED
FOR PREPARATION DISCUSSIONS
GIVEN THE LOSS OF PROPERTY THE
LOSS OF LIFE THE LOSS OF. OF
VALUABLE SECOND IN TERRITORY
WHEN THERE WERE THE- WHEN THERE
WAS THE FORCIBLE EXCHANGE
BETWEEN TURKEY AND GREECE IN
THE TWENTIES PRIOR TO THAT THE
PONTIC GENOCIDE GREEK GENOCIDE
IN THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. SO
THIS ISSUE PRESENTS SOME VERY
NOVEL AND- COMPONENTS. THAT IF
I AM TO BE CONSISTENT. IN THE
BELIEF THAT. HISTORY DOES NOT
HAVE A STATUE OF LIMITATIONS
WHEN IT COMES TO WRITING A
WRONG. THEN I HAVE TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOMETHING THAT
IS AS FOR DATING. AS SLAVERY
THAT IS AS PROBABLY THE MOST.
PROFOUND INSIGNIFICANT. CASTOR
FEE TO THE FALL OF PEOPLE. AS
THE INSTITUTION OF SLAVERY AS
IT SPEND CONTINENTS IT SPANNED
CIVILIZATIONS BUT IT CONTINUED
INTO MODERN PERIODS OF TIME.
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT THAN OUR
NOTIONS OF THE ANCIENT WORLD.
THE REASON WHY I'M BRINGING
THIS UP IS AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE GREEKS ARMENIANS AND OTHERS
AS THEY TRIED IS TO SEEK
REDRESS FROM THE HISTORICAL
INJUSTICES THAT BEFELL THEM.
THEN SO TOO SHOULD AFRICAN
AMERICANS BE IN A POSITION TO
SEEK REDRESS. UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE FIND OURSELVES
IN AS AMERICANS. IT'S ONLY FAIR.
HERE'S MY REQUEST TO. THE
AUTHOR PERHAPS A BIT WILL BE
THROUGH. THE CENTER BRADFORD- I
THINK IT'S ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE
FOR A BODY TO BE CONVENED TO
STUDY THIS ISSUE. I'D SURPRISE
THAT HASN'T BEEN DONE- BY OTHER
STATES MAYBE IT HAS BEEN I
DON'T I DON'T NOW. BUT HERE'S
WHAT I WOULD WANT TO SEE
DIFFERENT ABOUT THE PROPOSED
CONSTITUTION OF THIS GROUP. IS
RIGHT NOW THE APPOINTMENTS
WOULD BE FROM THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEADERS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE. WHAT I DON'T SEE I
THINK IT'S ESSENTIAL JUST AS
WE'VE- LOOK AT SOUTH AFRICA
CAMBODIA ARMENIA AND ELSEWHERE
AROUND THE WORLD WE'VE HAD
THESE CATASTROPHES IS THAT WHEN
A GROUP IS CONVENE. THESE
INDIVIDUALS BE PROPERLY
SCHOOLED AND- ARE DISCIPLINED
ON MATTERS THAT ARE RELEVANT TO
THE BODY ITSELF. SO HERE'S MY
RECOMMENDATION WOULD THE AUTHOR
CONSIDER. THAT THE EIGHT
APPOINTMENTS. BE EXPANDED I
DON'T KNOW TO WHAT AMOUNT. BUT
THAT IT INCLUDE COMPARED OF LAW
EXPERTS. INNING THE REASON I
BRING THAT UP IS BECAUSE- THE
REPORT ON THE CREATION OF THIS.
COMMISSION TALKS ABOUT. THIS
UNITED NATIONS ORGANS IN
DIFFERENT TREES AND OTHER
OBLIGATIONS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE DONE THIS.
SO COMPARED OF LAW EXPERT.
SOMEONE EXPERIENCED IN FOR
EXAMPLE AS A HOLOCAUST SCHOLAR.
OR SOUTH AFRICAN APARTHEID
SCHOLAR THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
A BACKGROUND IN DEALING WITH
REPARATIONS BUT THIS IS NOT.
JUST A- NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
APPOINTED BY THE PRO TEM THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THE GOVERNOR
AND LASTLY IT WOULD BE THAT
THERE BE A POLITICAL CROSS
SECTION REPRESENTED HERE.
BECAUSE IF IT'S JUST THOSE
THREE ENTITIES MAKING THE
APPOINTMENT. I THINK IT WOULD
BENEFIT. THE COMMISSION OR THIS
COUNCIL. THAT BODY IN BENEFIT
ALL OF US IF WE HAD SOME
REPRESENTATION THAT REPRESENTED.
THE CROSS SECTION OF OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM. I THINK DOES
A REASONABLE REQUEST I DON'T
KNOW IF I'D LIKE TO LEAVE IT
OPEN TO. BOB THE PRESENTER I
THINK THIS HAS A LOT OF MERIT.
I'M SCARED. THAT IF THE
COMPOSITION IS NOT. ALL TO
MODIFY. DATA WON'T BE IS AS IT
NEED TO BE AND I'M ALSO AFRAID
THAT WILL UNNECESSARILY IGNITE
PARTISAN PASSIONS. THAT I THINK
ARE INAPPROPRIATE. SOME SOME
MANAGER DO YOU MIND IF I
THROUGH YOU. HOSE THAT REQUEST
TO THE PRESENTER. I SIR THE
PRESENTER CAN COMMENT ON IT IN
HIS CLOTHES A BOAT YOU KNOW WE
DON'T NEGOTIATE THE TERMS OF
THE BILL IN ADVANCE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL CALL FOR EIGHT PEOPLE
ARE AND THAT THEY CANNOT ALL BE
OF THE SAME PARTY SO BAD THAT
HAS BEEN ADDRESSED BUT ALL ALL
THAT THE PRESENTER COMMENT ON
THAT. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS SO THE CENTER BOARD OF
MOVING ALONG I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE ORDER I INITIALLY PRESENTED
BUT IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME WILL
GO TO SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
IN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PRISONERS COMMENTS COMMENT ON
HIS AT HIS CLOSE I'VE ASKED HIM
TO DO THAT. A SIMPLE WHITE. THE
MAN I TO WITH THE A SHOUT OUT
FOR ALICE MERRILEES WHO WROTE
STAFF. THIS IS. MY TENTH YEAR
IN LESS. BEEN AND THE ASSEMBLY
SENATE SHOULD. COMMITTEES ALL
TIME AND WE DO EVERY DOES A
WONDERFUL JOB THIS IS. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. WAS WELL
WRITTEN BUT IT ALSO. TEES UP
THIS. TASK FORCE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE CAN GO BACK A HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE YEARS AND ASK WHY
WAS THIS NOT DONE WHEN THE
CIVIL WAR WAS OVER AND THEN
YOU'RE INTO. YOU KNOW THE. JIM
CROW LAWS IN THE N. IT IN THE
TURN OF THIS. NEARLY TWO BUT-
BUT THE STAFF REPORT.
HIGHLIGHTS HOW THE NEW TO WAS
REAL A WHITE DEAL AND AT A-
EXCLUDED TO. WORKER IN
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WHICH
SEEING IT AS I READ IT
YESTERDAY JUMPED OFF THE PAGES
WITH ME AND THEN I MOVED INTO.
THE GI WHICH EXCLUDED AND THE
RED LINE THAT WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
AND I WAS EXCLUDED THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEN YOU
GET INTO THE- CRIMINAL ORDERED
FEDERAL CRIMINALIZATION OF LAW
ON THE MASS. INCARCERATION AND
YOU'VE- IF WE DON'T TO THIS.
TASK FORCE AND SET UP TO
REPARATION WHAT DOES IT STOP
ONE TWO WHEN. ONE DISC
CALIFORNIA'S INTERAMERICAN
SOCIETY. LOOK AT THESE OR THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR- I. THE ALL AN
AS PERCENT TODAY BRING IT I'M
YOU KNOW I FILLED WITH GUILT AS
THEY SHOULD BE THEN ALL THE
BUSH BE ABOUT. THAT THE LACK OF
A TWO THAT HAD TO THIS CANCER
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR AND THAT
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED SO I
APPRECIATE THE INDULGENCE OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SIR
CENTER MORNING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I ALSO WANT TO CONVEY MY
THANKS TO THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER HER LEADERSHIP MOM
ON THIS AND SO MANY RELATED
ISSUES AND TO THE PRESENTER
SENATOR BRADFORD. I ALSO WANT
TO JUST OFFER MY THINKS- TO
ALISON MEREDITH IT'S AN AMAZING.
ANALYSIS I'VE PRINTED OUT TO
SHARE WITH FAMILY MEMBERS END
THANK YOU SECOND ALSO FORWARDED
IS AN EMAIL ATTACHMENT FROM THE
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT BUT
IT'S- IT. SO MANY WHO INCLUDING
MYSELF WERE TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ESTABLISHED.
NOT AS A SLAVE STATE AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THE FIGHTS THAT TOOK
PLACE IN MONTEREY IN WHETHER OR
NOT THE CONSTITUTION. OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
RECOGNIZE THE INSTITUTION OF
SLAVERY OR NOT AND WHILE. IT
DIDN'T FORMALLY YOU LOOK AT THE
LEGACY IN VESTIGES OF ON SO
MANY FRONTS. RECOGNIZING
OWNERSHIP OF OTHER PEOPLE BY
PEOPLE COMING IN TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE DENIAL OF
PROPERTY RIGHTS THE RED LINING
IN THE LIST GOES ON AND ON TO
PUT THIS IN OUR- CHALLENGE
TODAY. THE DEPTH OF THE
CHALLENGE MAY BE ONLY OFFSET.
BY THEM MOVEMENT UNDER WAY IN
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW. MOM THE-
LOSS OF JOHN LEWIS IN YET. IN
DEATH HIS LIFE IS BEING BETTER
UNDERSTOOD AND SHARED AROUND
THE COUNTRY. AND SO MANY OTHERS
YOUNG PEOPLE STEPPING UP. IN
RESISTANCE TO PLEASE PRACTICES
BUT GOING BEYOND PLEASE
PRACTICES I FULLY SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS
COMMISSION I WOULD HOPE THAT
PART OF THE ITS STUDY WOULD
LOOK TO THE TRUTH AND
RECONCILIATION COMMISSIONS
ESTABLISHED BY NELSON MANDELA.
FROM IN ARCHBISHOP DESMOND TUTU
IN SOUTH AFRICA A DIFFERENT
COUNTRY AT DIFFERENT HISTORY
BUT DEEP WOUNDS COMING OUT OF
DECADES OF WAR- IN APARTHEID IN
CONVENING. FORUM WHERE PEOPLE
FACE EACH OTHER AND SHARED
THEIR LOSS THEIR GRIEF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY AND WAS A
HEALING PROCESS THAT STILL
UNDER WAY BUT IT WAS RECOGNIZED
BY THE LEADERS. OF THE SOUTH
AFRICAN REVOLUTION THAT IT WAS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE COUNTRY TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. THIS
NEVER HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
WOULD MARK A STARTING POINT-
GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL I'D-
BE PROUD TO. MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR TO RUSSELL FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND I SEE
SENATOR STERN'S HAND IS UP SO.
HE WILL BE. PROBABLY BEFORE
CLOSE- BUT LET'S GO AHEAD TO
SENATOR TO ROSTER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD FOR. PRESENT TO A THE
ANTE. A DOCTOR WEBER ON THE
OFFICE OF. REPORT ON THIS. YOUR
STAFF OF. THE AMAZING AND I
THINK WE ALL WANT TO JUST GONNA
RUSHED SHARE THIS A THE- THERE
IS A SURE. A LOT THAT WILL BE
ON CA AND OF. MATURE DAMAGE AND
LOSSES THAT WERE INFLICTED ON
ON GENERATIONS AND GENERATIONS
OF BLACK AMERICANS. BUT THERE'S
ALSO THE TRAUMA AND THEIR ARE A
LOT OF THINGS. WHEN ASKED WHEN
DOES IT STOP. IT STOPS WILL WE
TO THE BOND OF IT ALL STOP SO
WE REALLY FIGURE THE- OF THE
DAMAGE TO- IN GENERATIONS OF A
BLACK AMERICANS- AND I HOLD
THROUGH THIS JUST AS- THE-
ANALYSIS BECAME MORE OF A- OF A
HISTORIC- PICTURE. ALL WE CAN
YOU FURTHER BECAUSE AS AS
SLAVES TRIED TO GET AWAY FROM
SLAVERY IN THE SOUTH IN THE
SOUTHEAST AND THEY WENT MORE
MORE WEST- THEY WERE THEY WERE
MOVING CLOSER AND CLOSER TO I
MEAN THEY WANT TO TAXES UP
BEFORE WITH TEXAS. BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO GET AWAY FROM SLAVERY.
AND THE PRIMARY REASON THAT
THERE WAS A ME U. S. MEXICO
WALLER WAS BECAUSE OF A VERY.
THE OF PEOPLE LIVING IN TEXAS
SAID WE WANT SLAVERY HERE TOO
AND THEY WERE PART OF MEXICO
AND IT WAS ILLEGAL IN MEXICO
FOR DECADES BEFORE IT HAD.
BECOME ILLEGAL SO. THERE IS SO
MUCH TO UNCOVER THAT I HOPE IN
THE PROCESS. OF COMING UP WITH
WHAT THE- THE PLAN ON THE ON
THE REPARATIONS HOW TO ADDRESS
REPARATIONS THAT WE ALSO USES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY.
EDUCATE AND INFORM- OF SO MANY
OF US ON MANY ISSUES THAT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT AND FINALLY I
WANT TO GIVE THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE- I'VE MENTIONED THIS
WITH REGARDS TO- THE LOSS OF
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE WE DID THE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS FREEDOM RIDE
WHICH WAS REALLY AN%
EXTRAORDINARY EXPERIENCE OF
AMERICANS OF ALL COLORS. OF
TRAVELING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND FOR SEVERAL WEEKS AND
STOPPING IN SMALL TOWNS AND BIG
CITIES- AND ENDING UP IN AND
NEW YORK AND- REMEMBER WHAT
THE- IMMIGRANT TO OR THE BOOKS
WHEN WE STOP. TO BURN A THE
HISTORY OF SLAVERY AND AFRICAN.
IN THE STORE WRITES ME. ON DATE
KNOW THEY DIDN'T KNOW. THE
HUMAN. NOT THE- STORK MOMENTS
AND SO I SEE THIS MORE AS A
EDUCATION AS MY AS IT WILL BE A
RIP SO. I AM SO PROUD THAT
DOING THIS FINALLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO SENATOR
GONZALEZ THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD AND DOCTOR WEBER AND
EVERYONE WHO PROVIDED TESTIMONY
IN PERSON AND OVER THE PHONE I
TWO MEN STRONG SUPPORT- I WILL
SAY THAT BACK HOME IN LONG
BEACH- WE'RE CREATING A
FRAMEWORK FOR RECONCILIATION I
THINK. THIS ACTION HERE WILL
SET THE STAGE IN THE FLOOR FOR
WHAT COULD BE DONE BACK HOME IN
LOS ANGELES AND ALL ACROSS THE
STATE I HOPE THAT CITIES SEE
THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EDUCATE. I'M NOT JUST IN THE
CASE IN HISTORY BY THE HIS OF
EACH OF OUR CITIES IN IN IN
TERMS OF RECONCILING THE
HISTORY OF FOR INSTANCE THE KKK
THAT WAS IN- LONG BEACH IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES THAT WE-
REALIZE. AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT
WE CAN DO HERE TO CHANGE- THE.
CHANGE WERE WERE WERE AT. AN
IMPROVEMENT NOT JUST A- MAY
IT'S GOING TO BE LISTENING AND
AS A COUPLE WITH A LOT OF
ACTION. WHICH IS WHAT I HOPE.
THE MOST- IMPORTANT THING A
PROFOUND THING FOR ME. AND THE
TASK FORCE. RECOMMENDATIONS WAS
THE APPROPRIATE WAYS EDUCATE
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC OF THE
TASK FORCE'S FINDINGS AND
ENSURING THAT EVERYBODY.
UNDERSTANDS OUR HISTORY IN THIS
WAY- BUT IT'S GOING TO SET THE
STAGE CERTAINLY FOR
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE WHICH
I'M VERY PROUD TO. TO THE-
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN. FROM THE NETWORK
OF LOS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SAY
A FEW WORDS WE'VE GOT YOU THERE
GO AHEAD DIDN'T. SHARE WITH US
YOUR THOUGHTS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD INTO DOCTOR WEBER FOR
EDUCATING ALL OF US NOT JUST-
THOSE OF US IN THE IN THE
BUILDING BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
STUDENTS AROUND THE STATE AND
THE NATION ARE BENEFITING FROM
YOUR INSISTENCE ON. SOME TRUTH
AND RECONCILIATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I DID HAVE. QUESTION
JUST IN TERMS OF THE SCOPE I
WAS LOOKING AT. WASHINGTON POST.
IF HE'S THAT SOMEBODY USING UP
AND IN. COMPLICITY IN THIS
SPECIFIC UNIVERSE. TERRY
INSTITUTION CHURCH THAT HAS OF
DOC. HISTORY AND WHEN BACK FOR
ENOUGH TO TRY THAT AND DO THE
ACCOUNTING- ENDS AS IT MY
COLLEAGUES IN AND YOU ALL OF
BROUGHT UP CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY- IS NOT AS A FREE STATE
BUT AS A SORT OF A SECRET
STUDIES STATE IN FACT THE GOLD
RUSH AND I PLUGGED THE ACLU FOR
THEIR RECENT WORK PUBLISHING
GOLD CHAINS WERE WHICH
DOCUMENTED HISTORY IN FACT OF
US. SELLING SLAVES IN THIS
STATE AND BRINGING SLAVES IN
AND IN THIS ACTUALLY BUILDING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY ON THE
BACK OF SLAVERY IN HIDDEN FORM
AS MINORS- AND OTHER OTHER
FORCED LABOR BUT I'M WONDERING-
IT IS THE- ARE REQUIREMENTS IN
THE- I WAS TRYING. REACH INTO.
THE TEXT ITSELF JUST MAKE SURE
THE WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE PUSH
PRIDE INSTITUTIONS AND SOLICIT
DATA FROM THEM TO ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO GO BACK AND TRACK-
FRIENDS IT'S IN BANKING
INSTITUTIONS. OR UNIVERSITIES
THAT MAY HAVE OWNED SLAVES- DO
WE HAVE IT IT WITH IT WITH THIS
COMMISSION- HAVE ENOUGH FORCE
IN LAW TO BE ABLE TO- GO BACK
CAN COMPEL THAT DATA. DO YOU
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT TO THE
WORLD WAR WORKING RIGHT NOW
WITH THE COMMISSIONER A RECORD
A LOT OF MAKING IN GOING BACK
TO STORE LOOKING AT THOSE
COMPANIES BAD IN SHE- IN
INVESTED IN SLAVE AND THOSE PAY
OUT THAT MANY OF THESE COURT.
AGREES DO TO SLAVE OWNERS SO
THAT'S FIRST STARTED WE COME
COMMISSIONER FOR WORKING HAND
IN HAND WITH NOT ONLY DOCTOR
WERE BROKE THE LEGISLATIVE LIKE
OFFICE ON THE AS WELL. WE WILL
OF THE DEL A LOT DEEPER I THIS
EIGHT MEMBER COMMISSION HELP
BILL OUT. FACT WHICH- IS
NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT LIKE
RIGHT TO RAW AND LOCAL THE FOR
AND EXT. SOME OF THE. WRONGS
THAT HAVE HOP OVER THE LAST
HUNDRED ANDSIXTY YEAR SINCE WE
AND THE PROBLEM THAT WERE TO
AFFERENTS AFTER AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN BROUGH SO YOU WE LOOKING
AT THAT WERE LITTLE LOOKING AT
COME ALSO A YOU SAY A NEW YORK
WHO INVESTED. IN THE SLAVE
TRADE IN ON THESE COAST OF WELL
SO WHERE WERE THE WITH THE THAT
WE BE EXPLORING YES. EXCELLENT
I'M LOOKING THANKS FOR THE CALL
FOR THAT WAS ACTUALLY ONLY IF
UP WAS HOW IT GOING THE ENSURE
COMMISSIONER AS WELL AS WITH
THE. UC REGENTS I KNOW WE DO A
TIMING. LAW ON THE AND IS WANT
TO SEE KIND OF PROGRESS ROOM.
BUT YOU WILL TO ADDRESS THAT IN
YOUR CLUB. THERE'S EVER AN
OPPORTUNE TO WORK DO A MAY
FURTHER I'D LOVE TO BE ARMS A
AUTHOR BUT AT THIS POINT I JUST
A- STRONG. I AND YOU KNOW TO A-
I'M TODAY'S A DAY OF MY IF
INDEED YOU FOR. IT'S TO SHIP
WITH IS THIS. DAY OF THE YEAR
WHERE WE MOURN. THE LOSS OF
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT HISTORY AND
OUR OUR LOSS OF HOLINESS AND-
IT ADDS ONLY APPROPRIATE TODAY
THAT WE REFLECT ON OUR OWN
SADNESS AT THIS. FEDERAL INCOME.
IN ALL THIS. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US TODAY. MARTY THE-
SINGLE FOR DEBATE OR DO ON TO
THANK YOU AS WELL AND THANK THE
HUNDRED SO WHO GOT ON THE PHONE
AND PAY WE TO THEIR FOR THIS
MEASURE. IT IS MORE LONG DUE.
BOGGLES MY MIND THAT TO WE ARE
SO IGNORANT ACTUALLY OF A LOT
OF THE HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
EVEN THOSE OF OUR AND ESTERS
THAT WE'RE NOT COMPLICIT BACK
IN THE EIGHTEEN FIFTIES OF WHO
WERE EITHER IGNORANT OR
UNINFORMED AND FRANKLY IN
READING THIS DOCUMENT I
REALIZED THAT I ALSO LIKE I
THINK PROBABLY MOST OF US. ARE
NOT AWARE OF THE DEPTHS. OF THE
DISCRIMINATION AND THE- CURRENT
EXTRAORDINARY DE HUMANIZATION.
OF OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SO I FIND THIS TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT WORTHWHILE MOMENT TO
ITS COMP AIDED. TO THE EXTENT
THAT. THE AMERICA WE ALL AS A
TRIBUTE TO ASCRIBE TO IS REALLY
AN ASPIRATIONAL AMERICA. THAT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT US
HISTORICALLY VIRTUALLY EVERY.
IMMIGRANT GROUP IN THIS COUNTRY
WAS DISCRIMINATED AGAINST I
THINK OF OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO WERE
SYSTEMATICALLY- OF VICTIMIZED-
I THINK OF. A JUST ABOUT EVERY
GROUP- WHEN THEY CAME NEAR THE
IRISH THE ITALIANS IN NEW YORK
CAN CERTAINLY MY A JEWISH
ANCESTORS BUT NOBODY ARE AT
UNDER WENT THE BLATANT A BREAK
UP OF. AND THE D. HUMAN. WE
BROUGHT PEOPLE OVER TO THEIR- A
FROM AFRICA IN SEOUL OFF
FAMILIES. IT IN BUT HE DIDN'T
IN A WAY THAT ABSOLUTELY IN
HUMAN. AND INCOMPREHENSIBLE
FRANKLY I THINK TO SOME OF US
SO TO LEARN ABOUT THAT IN TO
FACE THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY. IN HOPES SAYS IN THE
SPIRIT OF JOHN LEWIS WOULD MAKE
US BETTER I THINK IS. AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CERTAINLY
CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT BUT
PASSED SO WITH THAT- SENATOR
SHOULD LIKE TO CLOSE FOR SMART
I WOULD TAKE YOUR COMMENTS AS
MY CLOTHES BUT I WILL TRY TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERN
ISSUES THAT SIN REPORTAGE REYES
AS FAR AS THE NUMBER OF THE-
OF. THIS ARE COMMITTEE- RIGHT
NOW WHY OPEN TO GET THIS WHAT
EIGHT PASSED TO SO I'M PRETTY
WE WHAT WE LOOK AT A LARGE.
BODY IF THAT WAS. YEAH WE WILL.
BUT AS SAY YOU DO FOR ONE THAT
SO START WITH THAT EIGHT BUT
WE'RE- SURE AND WE ARE GONNA
SIGN. THAT BILLS EIGHT OURS THE
MOST. PEOPLE ON THIS WITH THIS
ISSUE WE'RE JUST GONNA A SONG
AN OLD PEOPLE BE A SIGN WILLIE
NAY. TO LET'S LOOK AT REBEL WE
WANT HIS STORY WE WANT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE A LEGAL BACKGROUND
RESEARCH BACKGROUND ALL THOSE
THINGS ARE GONNA BE NECESSARY
TO TRACE BACK ALL THE DAMAGES.
AND RIGHTS THAT PEOPLE. WHO
HAVE BEEN IN SLAVE ARE ENTITLED
TO THROUGH OUT THE FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS OF BEING BROUGHT TO THIS
LAND AS FAR AS A DIVERSITY OF
OPINION THAT'S CRITICAL- I A
FEW SPEAKING PARTY I THINK.
ONLY OUR CURRENT. WAS NOT A
THAT A LINCOLN OR- IN IN AND
NOT UNDER THAT HE PROBABLY
WASN'T THAT AFTERNOON UP UNTIL
THE SICK WERE REPUBLIC SO WE
WANT DIVERSITY OF POLITICAL
PARTY BACK TOOL WE WORK AS A
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SO WE WILL WALK
OUT BIPARTISAN PARTICIPATION AS
IT MAKES UP THIS BODY BECAUSE
AGAIN. MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
FAMILY WERE REPUBLICANS UNTIL
THE SIXTIES UNTIL KENNEDY. BUT
A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T KNOW THAT.
IN MANY BLACKS. REPUBLICANS
THIS COUNTRY UNTIL THE EARLY.
SIXTIES BECAUSE A RIVER LINCOLN
AND HE DID THE FREE FLOW. AND
WHAT HE IN A MATTER PROP. OF
THE OF ROUGH. THAT WAS QUICKLY
ALL. AFTER HIS A SOUTH. THE P.
FILLED UNDERSTAND. AND THE
ROUNDABOUT WAY TO RE
INSTITUTIONALIZING SLAVERY
THROUGH THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT MASS INCARCERATION IS
NOTHING NEW HERE WHEN IT COMES
TO PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT HAS ALLOWED WHO BY
SLAVERY THE LAST. HUNDRED AND
YEARS TO MASS GARCIA. AND WHEN
TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF SINGLE
FAMILIES. LIKE FAMILIES IN THIS
COUNTRY AGAIN THIS IS BEEN
INSTITUTIONAL. IT WAS TO BLACK
FAMILIES ADVANTAGES THE KICKED
THE MAN OUT THE HOUSE BECAUSE
WHAT THE IT LEARN TO SLAVERY
SEPARATING FAMILIES AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE INSTITUTIONAL
TO AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY. FOR AGAIN SINCE OUR
EXISTENCE AND THAT'S HAS
MEANING REMY TALK ABOUT HOW ARE
YOU IMAGE IN THE LOW
PERFORMANCE OF SCORES IN
EDUCATION IN THIS COUNTRY WENT
AT THE TURN OF THE CENTURY. I
AN AMERICAN SHIP INSTEAD OF
LEARNING THE OTHER GROUP IN
THIS COUNTRY MORE THAN THE
CATHOLIC MORE THAN THE JEWS
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE AND IN
THE NINETEEN HUNDREDS TO THE-
THOUSANDS THIS. BLACK COLLEGES
WE VALUE EDUCATION BUT THROUGH
THE SYSTEMATICS. SYSTEM HERE IN
AMERICA DISCO OPPRESSION OF THE
NILE. PUNISHING YOU LEARN
GETTING YOUR EYES GOUGED OUT AS
A SLAVE FOR LEARNING TO READ.
BEING PUT TO DEATH LOSE YEAH I
HAD EIGHT. A LAW ON THE BOOKS
UP UNTIL THE LATE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS ACT IF YOU WERE A
SLAVE IN YOU TALK TO YOUR CHILD
TO READ. YOU COULD BE SENTENCED
TO DEATH. THERE WERE SEVENTY
TWO LAWS ON THE BOOKS IN
LOUISIANA. FOR DEATH FOR BLACK
FOLKS ONLY TO WIN A RELATED TO
WHITES. SO WHAT THIS IS AT ALL
OF YOU AGREE TO IS A HISTORY
LESSON. IS A HISTORY LESSON
THAT WE SO BADLY NEED HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY. ABOUT WHAT. WE
WHAT THIS COUNTRY IS
REPRESENTED. IT'S BADLY EEDED
SO I'M HONORED TO BE. A JOINT
AUTHORED DOCTOR WEBER A CALL
AUTHORED SHOULD TO. DOCTOR
WHETHER WAS DOCTOR WAS MINE.
TEACHER MY FOR YEAR IN COLLEGE.
AND I DROPPED TO REPLY BECAUSE
I SAW HOW YOU'LL BE FEEL
PREPARED I WAS. A THE BAR HIS
IN THIS COUNTRY ARE AMERICA
HISTORY SO. HELLO TRACK THERE
BUT IT ALL TIES IN WHAT. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT AND AGAIN IT DOES
NOT SPELL OUT THE FORMER
REFEREE THAT WE WILL THAT WE
WILL TAKE. BUT I EVERY DOES
TAKE A BLUE ON UP AS MESSED TO
ADDRESS THE PERSISTENT A FAX OF
SLAVERY AND ITS SUCCESSORS.
INCLUDING JIM CORAL.
SHARECROPPING REDLINING WAY TO
LABOR. OVER IN CARS OVER POLICE.
AND SYSTEMATIC DISCRIMINATION
IN THE PAST WE HAVE. RIGHTLY
ADDRESS DEGREE JUST WRONG TO
REPARATIONS FOR JAPANESE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO WERE
PUT AN INTERNMENT CAMPS DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. WE'VE GOT
DRESSED AND IN THE BEST WAY SO
FAR FAR NATIVE AMERICANS WHO
HAD. ALL OF THEIR LAND STOLEN
FROM THEM. ALL THE COASTAL
LOWLANDS MALIBU TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS ALL NATIVE
AMERICAN LANDS THOSE REST
RESERVATIONS WHERE THEY ARE NOW
IN LYNN AND ROCKY ON FAR BEHIND
RANCH THE LAND. WAS A
PUNISHMENT. THANK AND THEIR LAN
STAKING AWAY THAT TO MAKE
SOMEONE MAY TO MEN'S I SHOULD
SAY TO. THE COMPACT SO WE
PROVIDE THEM TO BUT NOT AFTER
AMERICAN. WE HAVE YET TO SEE.
ANY JUSTICE SO WE RECKON IT AND
A THREE A RESPONSE. AND THE
GREATER. THE LONGER THE LEGACY.
THE WANTED AT A REPARATIONS
AFTER THE CIVIL CIVIL WAR THAT
WAS PROMISED THE FORTY ACRES
AND A MULE WAS REVERSED AS I
STATED SHIRLEY AFTER LINCOLN
WAS ASSASSINATED FORMER SLAVES
ENDED UP WORKING ON THE LAND.
OF THEIR FORMER- AND SLIPPERS.
SOME REPARATIONS WERE ACTUALLY
PAID BUT NOT TO THE SLAVE BUT
TO THE FARMER. AND SLAVE OWNER
WHO LOST THEIR SLAVES THEY WERE
PAID COMPENSATION FOR THOSE
SLAVES THAT HAS SINCE BEEN FREE.
AGAIN THIS PANDEMIC HAS CLEARLY
SHOWN ITS DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON BLACK CALIFORNIA'S AS
WELL AS BLACK AMERICANS AND
IT'S ONLY THE LATEST REMINDER
OF THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY THAT
IS NEVER BEEN TRULY ADDRESSED
AND IT'S SO FITTING THAT WE'RE
DOING THIS. MEASURE TODAY AGAIN
WE SAN PAYING HOMAGE TO THE
JEWISH RELATIONSHIP AS IT IS
MORE INTO THE LOSS BUT WE MORE
JOHN LEWIS TODAY HE WAS LAID TO
REST TODAY AND I WAS PROVIDED.
THIS ESSAY THAT HE WROTE AND IT
STATES TOGETHER. YOU CAN REDEEM
THE SOUL OF OUR NATION WHAT
TOGETHER WE CAN REDEEM THE SOUL
OF CALIFORNIA BY VOTING YES ON
THIS MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY
RIVAL. THANK YOU I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS MATTER- MOTION
BY SENATOR MORNING AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AW
AND WITH THAT. ONE ANGLER PUT
OF CLEAR. CHAIR SENATOR YES I'D
MADE SOME. AND I'D ASK YOU TO
COMMENT ON THEM FURTHER. CAN
YOU TAKE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE AUTHOR AND SEE WHETHER
OR NOT BEFORE IT MAKES THE
SENATE FLOOR. IF SHE WOULD GIVE
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION. TO
ARTICULATING. IN DETAIL. THE D.
PROPOSED CONSTITUTION AND
COMPOSITION OF THIS COMMISSION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT SENATOR
THAT LEAP WHICH NOT OF THE COIN
THIS ORDER WE WE'VE HAD CLOSURE
SENATOR PER- BRADFORD HIS
CLOSED THANK YOU FOR THE LAST
TIME. IT'S NOT FOR TE AND IF
YOU WISH TO DISCUSS THIS WITH
HIM FOR I'M SURE BE HAPPY TO DO
THAT. IT'S NOW TIME TO VOTE ON
pDO PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS BOTTOM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THAT IS
PLEASE TURN OUR MICROPHONE'S ON
THIS IS FILE ITEM. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THIRTY ONE ANYONE DOCTOR
WEBER. MEMBER WEBER THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ACCESS BY NOT ADDRESS. WHAT IS
NOT VOTING DRESSEL HI THE REST
I COULD HI AND THE I LAND.
MELINDA NO MONNING I MONNING I
STERN. NINE STERN I AMBERG.
NUMBER FIVE Y. CALLES HI I CAN
I. THE TWENTIETH OR FIVE SIX
THAT SEVEN I WERE NO EVER HERE.
SEVEN EYES A ONE NO. ONE ON
VOTING OF THE MAY PASS THANK
YOU MANAGER MANY MEMBERS. CURRY
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN THAT SENATOR
TO RUSSIA WILL BE PRESENTING
SENATOR IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
PRESENTING- AT THE DíAS THERE
SO THAT THE THOSE WATCHING OR
WEIRD. WHO'S PRESENTING AND SO
FORTH. RIGHT SENATOR ALSO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU ARE ON
FIVE FOR THOSE LISTENING AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE IT'S
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
SENATOR AWESOME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM PRESENTING AB ONE THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
TODAY. THIS BILL CODIFIES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
RESETTLING REFUGEES WITHOUT
DISCRIMINATION AS PART OF THE
U. S. RECEPTION AND PLACEMENT
PROGRAM. REFUGEES ARE MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN WHO ARE FORCED TO
FLEE THEIR COUNTRY OF ORIGIN.
TO SEEK SAFETY IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY DUE TO WAR.
GOVERNMENTAL OF HABEL OR
PERSECUTION BASED UPON THE
RELIGION NATIONALITY OR
MEMBERSHIP IN A PARTICULAR
SOCIAL OR POLITICAL GROUP.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG TRADITION
OF OFFERING REFUGE TO THOSE IN
NEED HAVE BEEN RECEIVED A
SUPPORTED NEARLY RECORD A NEWLY
ARRIVED REFUGEES SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY PROBABLY BEFORE THAT.
THESE REFUGEES THEN TURN AROUND
AND CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE
INCLUDING SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN SPENDING POWER AND
THE DIVERSITY WE ARE SO PROUD
OF. WITH FEDERAL FUNDING
SUPPORT RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES
PROVIDE DIRECT SUPPORT TO NEWLY
ARRIVED REFUGEES ASYLUM SEEKERS
AND DOCTOR RECIPIENTS THIS BILL
CODIFIES INTO IN OUR STATE LAW
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO UPHOLD
OUR COMMITMENT. TO ASSISTING
THOSE SEEKING REFUGE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND STATE. AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY THREE HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IT IS A LOT THE
YOU KNOW CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR DORADO AND WE DO
HAVE. A TWO WITNESSES IN THE
QUEUE BUT I HAVE TO REMIND YOU
ALL THAT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES ARE
INSTITUTING TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY AS AS AS A RESULT
EACH SIDE IS PROVIDED ONLY
THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. AND WITH THAT WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES WHO WILL SHARE
THAT THREE MINUTE PERIOD OF
TIME DONNA DO VENN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF I RC SAN DIEGO. IS
ARE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT I'M
SORRY DO WE HAVE MORE THAN ONE
RESEARCH HAS ONE WITNESS. IF IT
IS TRUST ONE WITNESS ON THE
LINE THEN YOU WILL GET THOUGH
THREE MINUTES TO SPEAK. DO WE
KNOW IS THERE ANYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE OTHER THAN DONNA DO
FAN. NOW ALL RIGHT MISS DUBIN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR OF UP
TO THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
AS BAD I AM DONE I DO THEN I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
AND SAN DIEGO. AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE INTERNATIONAL RESCUE
COMMITTEE WE REFER TO THAT AS
THE IRISH SEA- THE I RC AS THE
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT AGENCY WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE OFFICES SPREAD
ACROSS FIFTEEN STATES IN THE US.
AND HEARING CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SEVEN RESETTLEMENT SITES. WE
ARE ONE OF NINE NATIONAL
AGENCIES ASSISTING REFUGEES AND
THE MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE
REUNITING WITH FAMILY AFTER
FLEEING WAR CONFLICT IN
PERSECUTION. I'M PARTICIPATING
TODAY TO REPRESENT THE IRISH
HE'D SUPPORT FOR AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE. I SPONSORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT OF THE
PROCESS THAT IS DESIGNED AS A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND
EVENTS MENTIONED- IT HAS BEEN
BUILT OVER THE LAST FORTY YEARS
AN INCORPORATE THAT THE SUPPORT
OF FEDERAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENT. MANY COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. AND THE REFUGEE
RESETTLING- AGENCIES THAT
FACILITATE A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION FOR OUR CLIENTS. AS
RECESSES RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH A WIDE
RANGE OF LOCAL AGENCIES CAN
PROVIDE FEDERALLY FUNDED
SUPPORT TO HELP NEWLY ARRIVED
REFUGEES AND OTHER VULNERABLE
GROUPS SUCH AS ASYLUM SEEKERS
TO INTEGRATE INTO AND FIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY. AND DESPITE ALL
THIS COORDINATION. THEIR
RELATIONSHIP THAT MANIFEST IN A
SUCCESSFUL RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM
CAN BE ELIMINATED IN AN ACTION
AND SWIFT AS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS THE
RESETTLEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
FACED UNPRECEDENTED ATTACKS
AGAINST WHAT WAS ONCE A
STANDARD ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IN A FEW YEARS WE HAVE
WITNESSED STATE BOB TO WITHDRAW
FROM THE RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM.
AND THEN ADMINISTRATION WHICH
THIS PAST WINTER REQUIRED
GOVERNORS AND LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES. TO PUBLICLY AND
PROACTIVELY CERTIFIED THEIR
CONSENT IF THEY WISH TO SEE WE
SETTLEMENT CONTINUING THEIR
STATE. ABSENT THERE'S BY AN
RESETTLEMENT WOULD HAVE ENDED
IN OUR STATE COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
WELCOMING HOME FOR THE WORLD'S
MOST VULNERABLE AND AT RISK IT
IS THE STATE WHERE THE
RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM AS WE KNOW
IT TODAY WAS ACTUALLY BORN AND
WHEN THE FIRST WAVE OF
SOUTHEASTERN. ASIAN REFUGEES
ARRIVED SEEKING SAFETY AND
SHELTER. REFUGEES ARRIVED IN A
VERY TO WORK AND THEY HAVE MADE
THEIR MARK IN CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY. CONTRIBUTING TO
MAJOR INDUSTRY STARTING
BUSINESSES BOTH SMALL AND LARGE
AND REVITALIZING COMMUNITIES AS
THEY MAKE THEIR HOMES AND RAISE
THEIR FAMILIES HERE. AND
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
REFUGEES ARE SERVING AS THE
SPECIAL WORKERS IN A VARIETY OF
CAPACITIES AND THOSE WITH
HEALTHCARE TRAINING ARE
STEPPING UP TO HELP ON THE
FRONT LINES OUR STATE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BENEFIT FROM THEIR
RESILIENCE. FINALLY AND
IMPORTANTLY GIVEN SUPPORT AND
OPPORTUNITY REFUGEES GO ON TO
PROBABLY BECOME THE SOME OF OUR
MOST DEVOTED AND ENGAGED U. S.
THAT IS AN- WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA
REMAIN A WALKING STATE FOR
REFUGEES. THIS BILL PROMOTE THE
UNIFIED HONORING THE
CONTRIBUTION OF REFUGEES THAT
THEY JOINED THE FABRIC OF U. S.
LIKE IN CALIFORNIA. WE ASK THAT
YOU PASS AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE TO PROTECT THE FUTURE OF
THE US RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- REFUGEES
WHO ARRIVE AND CALLED. THE HOME
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT NOW WILL A GO TO ANY
WITNESSES WHO ARE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE LET'S MOVE ON TO ROOM FOR
A TWENTY FORTY. THEY DO NOT
APPEAR TO BE ANY PEOPLE IN
TWENTY FORTY LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES THEN. OF WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MATTER
MODERATOR- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE WE CAN BEGIN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB. THREE ONE THREE THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY THE PEOPLE ON THE
LINE AND IF SO HOW MANY ARE
LINED UP IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU I HAVE FOUR LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND
START WITH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU-
NAME AFFILIATION AND INDICATING
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN FOR OUR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM NOT
A POSSIBLE ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU I AM TO TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE FOR
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM ONE BURKE
ON BEHALF OF THE FRENCH
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES
PLACE NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
LINE FOR ALL FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR ZERO FOUR
THREE STORE HAD. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE
MATTER MODERATOR. I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE'S INK YOU AT THIS
TIME RIGHT LET'S GIVE IT ONE
ONE LAST EFFORT TO IF THERE ARE
ANY PEOPLE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. AND
I WILL REPEAT THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER ONE MORE TIME. IT IS ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AGAIN.
1-844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SIX ONE. ONE ONE ONE
SEVEN NINE AGAIN. SIX ONE ONE
ONE ONE SEVEN NINE. MATTER
MODERATOR HAVE WE GET ANYMORE
TAKERS IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
LINE FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES MATTER
MODERATOR. I HAVE NO FURTHER
BINDING YOU AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD THANK YOU LET'S- PROCEED
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
LET'S GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES.
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
MOVING ALONG TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ANY WITNESSES NO ONE IN
THAT ROOM LET'S CHECK THE LINE-
AND SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE
OF MATTER MODERATOR IF YOU WILL
PETE PLEASE PROCEED TO- FOR
THOSE WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION HOURS A. B. THREE
ONE THREE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO OUT THIS TIME.
META MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
TELL ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALRIGHT.
WITH THAT TO JUST ASK YOU TO
CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THE REGIONAL
OPPOSITION WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN THE QUEUE. I DO HAVE ONE IN
Q. FIND ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TIME FOR JOHN
MUHAMMAD IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE ONE THREE THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT- WE WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DíAS AND I WANT TO
THANK A- THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL AND TO.
FORGE SENATOR DRAWS THOSE
PRESENTATION. YOU KNOW WE ARE A
NATION OF IMMIGRANTS. WHETHER
THEY WERE THE PEOPLE WHO CAME
OVER INVOLUNTARILY AS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT PREVIOUSLY AS
SLAVES OR WHETHER THEY CAN THEY
WERE PEOPLE WHO CAME OVER FROM
ALL PARTS OF THE WORLD TO
OVERCOME. OF FAMINE AND WAR
AND- GENOCIDES SO IT COULD THIS
COUNTRY HAS. A HISTORY OF
OPENING ITSELF UP WHETHER IT'S
A TOUGH ROAD TO GET THAT
ACCEPTANCE ONCE THEY GET HERE.
OF COURSE IS FOR THE HISTORY
BOOKS TO DISCUSSION FOR US TO.
LEARN ABOUT- BECAUSE IT HASN'T
BEEN EASY BUT IT IS THE PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE WITH THE HOPE AND
EXPECTATION AND THE PROMISE.
THAT IF THEY- CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY AND THEY WORKED HARD
AND THEY DID THEIR BEST AND
THEY PLAY BY THE RULES THEY
COULD SUCCEED AND IT HAS BEEN
PROVEN FOR SO MANY TO BE THE
CASE. AND YET OF WE STILL FINE
THAT THERE ARE THOSE WANT TO
PUT UP OBSTACLES AND WALLS. ARE
AND KEEP OUT OTHERS AFTER WE
HAVE BEEN THE BENEFICIARIES OF
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND CERTAINLY-
IT IS A VERY SAD MOMENT THAT IT
HAS BECOME- A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL. AT THIS POINT WE KNOW
THE REFUGEES TRYING TO ESCAPE
WAR- IN CENTRAL AMERICA THE
STORIES OF LEGION PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE BECAUSE OF OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE I HAVE. FAMILY HERE FOR
WHATEVER REASON. AND TO OF
SADLY WE HAVE OF AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT- YOU KNOW HIS
BASICALLY. IN CITED THOSE KIND
OF INTERNET SEEN WARS AND OF
COURSE THE ORDERS OF MASS- A
FEDERAL OURT ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZED THAT OF MR TRUMP'S
ORDER EXECUTIVE ORDER THIRTEEN
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT- WAS
DEFICIENT IN TERMS OF PASSING
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER COMPLYING
WITH THE SEPARATION OF POWERS
PRINCIPLES AND SATISFYING THE
STRICTURES OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT-
IN OTHER MATTERS OF LAW THAT
DON'T SEEM TO. MEAN A WHOLE LOT
TO. THIS INDIVIDUAL BUT TO ITS
CREDIT THE OF THE FEDERAL COURT
DID ENJYING THAT ORDER NONE
THE LESS IT IS ON APPEAL. AND I
THINK IT'S AND THAT WE-
RECOGNIZE AND VALUE THOSE
PEOPLE IN RECOGNIZING VALUE THE
LAW. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE'S NO LOCALITY THAT IS
SUPPOSED THIS BILL OR HAS IT
SUGGESTED THAT IT'S AN UNDUE
INFRINGEMENT ON LOCAL CONTROL-
IT REALLY ISN'T CONTROVERSIAL
IT IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA LOCALITIES. NOT
REFUSE TO CONSENT TO RESETTLE
REFUGEES IN A WAY THAT
INTENTIONALLY OR EFFECTIVELY.
DISCRIMINATES ON THE BASIS OF
RACE OR GENDER OR OTHER
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTIC SO-
THIS BILL REALLY. I WOULD REFER
TO IT IS SORT OF A NO BRAINER.
AND IT IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE COUNTRY IN OPENING OUR
DOORS. TO OUR THE REFUGEE
POPULATION IT IS HERE SEEKING A
BETTER LIFE IS ALL OF OUR
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS AND
GREAT GRANDPARENTS AND GREAT
GREAT GRANDPARENTS BEFORE THEM
HAVE DONE SO WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND- WOULD
WELCOME ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
CENTER ON BURKE MOVES THE BILL.
THE COMMENTS ALL RIGHT- SENATOR
DRAWN SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
VERY GOOD SO THE MOTION BY
SENATOR UMBERG IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND SO PLEASE STERN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON. THIS IS FILE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B. THIRTY
ONE THIRTY THREE AGUIAR-CURRY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR JACKSON HI JACKSON
I A BOARD JUST. FOR JUST I DID
ALSO I DID A SO I GONZALEZ I ON
SERVICE I INLAND AS- MONNING HI
MONNING AYE STERN. STERN I AM
BURKE I'VE UMBERG AYE WHY
CASCADE A CASKET EIGHT ZERO
WITH THE MISSING MEMBER VOTE IS
EIGHT TWO ZERO WITH A ONE ONE
MEMBER MISSING WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN AND WHEN WE'RE DONE
WITH OUR NEXT A BILL WE WILL
ASK ANY MEMBERS WHO WERE NOT
HERE WHO WISH TO VOTE TO PLEASE
COME BACK BECAUSE- WE WILL THEN
DO ONE ROUND. AND THEN WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLES WITH THAT WE
HAVE ONE FINAL BILL THIS IS AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY C. THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX THE. ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY MEASURE
FOR DEALING WITH JUDICIAL
EMERGENCIES AND IT ALSO HAS AN
EMERGENCY CLAUSE. OF SENATOR
EXCUSE ME AS MEMBER STONE
WELCOME TO A PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT. THANK YOU I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
STATE'S RESPONSE OF PANDEMIC
SHOWN THAT A LOT OF THE SYSTEMS
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE FOR A
STATEEMERGENCY ARE SOMETIMES
INADEQUATE IN FACT WHEN THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL NEEDED
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO ADJUST
WHAT IT NEEDED TO ADJUST IT
TOOK. A AN EXECUTIVE ORDER SO
INSTEAD OF LETTING THE
EXECUTIVE ALWAYS THAT THEN I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR US IS AS
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE THE MECHANISMS IN PLACE
TO ALLOW. ALL THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT FUNCTION DURING
STATEWIDE. EMERGENCIES THE
EXISTING LAW. ALLOWS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE CHIEF
JUSTICE TO. ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE EMERGENCIES BUT IT'S ONLY
A COUNTY BY COUNTY BASIS AND AT
THE REQUEST OF THE PRESIDING
JUDGE OF THAT COUNTY WITH THIS
BILL DOES IS IT GIVES A FORTY
TWO. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
THE CHAIR THE USUAL COUNSEL. TO
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS ON WIDE OPEN
BECAUSE THESE EMERGENCIES DON'T
ARE NOT CONTAINED COUNTY BY
COUNTY. SO IT'S ABOUT
EFFICIENCY IT'S ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE SETTING THE
STANDARD. FOR THE- JUDICIAL
BRANCH TO BE ABLE TO DO WHAT IT
NEEDS TO DO TO ADDRESS.
EMERGENCIES AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE ABOUT. THANK YOU OF WE WILL
NOW GO TO OUR WITNESSES ONLINE
I WILL HAVE TO REPEAT THAT DUE
TO THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES
ARE INSTITUTING OR BE REQUIRED
TO INSTITUTE A THREE MINUTE
TIME LIMIT- TO BE SHARED
BETWEEN THE I BELIEVE THERE TO
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. ALL OTHERS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES OF THE SAME
WILL APPLY TO ANY OPPOSITION.
AND WITH THAT- I BELIEVE WE
HAVE- NANCY TRAVEL WITH THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS MIKE BELOW
TO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL. ALSO ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT. BETTER
MODERATORS CHECK CORRECT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS NANCY
TRAVEL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
MANSION AND THE COPA CRISIS
REALLY LAID BARE THE INADEQUACY
OF THE CURRENT AUTHORITY. FOR
THE CHIEF JUSTICE TO DEAL WITH
THE STATE WIDE EMERGENCY. SO
THIS BILL IS A NECESSARY FIRST
STEP. TO GIVE HER THE AUTHORITY
TO ATTEMPT TO OF HOPE WITH THE
TYPE OF EMERGENCY THAT WE'VE
BEEN FACING FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS. EVEN WITH THE
AUTHORITY THAT SHE WAS GRANTED
BY THE EXECUTIVE ORDER AND NOW
THE AUTHORITY THAT WOULD BE
OFFERED UNDER THIS STILL.
ACROSS THE STATE WE REALLY HAVE
SEEN EXTREME IN EQUITY. IN HOW
FULL WHO NEED TO GO TO COURT
CAN GET JUSTICE- MISTER BELOW
NEIER REPRESENTING. PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CIVIL CASES AND OF COURSE
THAT'S EVERYTHING FROM ELDER
ABUSE TO POLICE BRUTALITY TO
PERSONAL INJURY TO PRODUCT
LIABILITY AND WHAT WE ARE
SEEING AND THIS WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION GOING
FORWARD. IS THAT TRIAL DATES
ARE BEING SEVERELY DELAYED IN
SOME COUNTIES PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO. ELECTRONICALLY FILE AND
OTHER COUNTIES THEY CAN'T IN
SOME COUNTIES THEY CAN GET A
COURT DATE AND OTHERS THEY
CAN'T. AND SO THIS BILL. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO STARTING TO HAVE
UNIFORMITY INJUSTICE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THAT IT
SHOULDN'T MATTER WHICH COUNTY
YOU HAPPEN TO BE IN ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO GET YOUR DAY IN COURT.
ON SO WE THINK IT'S ESSENTIAL-
ALONG WITH NECESSARY FUNDING
FOR THE COURTS SO THEY CAN
OPERATE REMOTELY AND THEY CAN'T
PROVIDE JUSTICE TO PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER RUBBLE NEXT
MADAM CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS A
MIKE BELOW TO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL I
WOULD MERELY ADD. THAT THIS WE
DON'T VIEW THIS INTERROGATION
OF THE APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY AUTHORITY OF
INDIVIDUAL PRESIDING JUDGES. A
THAT WILL ALWAYS BE TAKEN INTO-
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION- BUT
AS- HIS TRAVEL NOTED YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN A TIME WHERE PEOPLE
OPERATE IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES-
AND SO THERE OUGHT TO BE
REASONABLE. ASSURANCE THAT
JUSTICE WILL BE A FORM.
REGARDLESS OF WHICH COUNTY
YOU'RE IN ITS- HE- WRITTEN
CONTEMPLATION OF A CATASTROPHE
OF FIRE OR OR SOME AFFECT A
SMALL NUMBER OF COUNTIES AND
REALLY DIDN'T CONTEMPLATE A
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY LIKE THE
PANDEMIC HOUSE HAS GIVEN US SO
AGAIN WE THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT REGARDLESS OF WHO THE
CHIEF JUSTICE IS- IN PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE AND FOR THAT WE
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT-
LET'S GO TO- FORTY TWO OR THREE
TO THE ROOM WHERE IN AND ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. SEEING
ONE OF ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE
APPEARED TO BE NO PEOPLE IN
THAT ROOM SO WE WILL- TAKE IT
NOW TO- WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCING
SERVICES MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX.
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE SIX SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM OF
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I HAVE NO LINES IN Q.
AT THIS TIME I WILL- PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONE LAST TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS NO ONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE
SIX SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE. I
HAVE AN ONLINE USING. YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU LET'S GO
TO. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT HAVEANY INDIVIDUALS LINED UP TO
SPEAK ARE IN OPPOSITION IN AT
THREE MINUTE TIME FRAME. IS
THAT A CORRECT MATTER%
MODERATORS WE HAVE NO
IDENTIFIED SPEAKERS. NONE OKAY
OF LET'S GO AHEAD AND SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE WISHES TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT MEASURE.
SEEING NONE FOR ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE ARE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY LET'S BRING IN THE
BACK TO YOU MADAM A MODERATOR
WOULD CHIU- PLEASE- LINE UP ANY
WITNESSES WHO MIGHT WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK I OPPOSITION HOURS A.
B. THREE THREE SIX SIX PLEASE-PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME.
MADAME MODERATOR TO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. I HAVE LEVINE DRINK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR Y.
CASKEY WILL THAT'S ONE MORE
TIME IF THERE IS ANYONE WHO
DOES WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- OUT OF AB THREE
THREE SIX SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
META MODERATOR WE HAVE ANY
TAKERS. I HAVE LOW LYING THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD THEN
WE WILL BRING THIS BACK TO THE
DíAS ANY COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS
BY ANYBODY. ALL RIGHT I WILL
SAY THAT HAVING THAT SERVING ON
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THIS IS. THAT
SEEMS LIKE A VERY MINOR. EFFORT
BUT ACTUALLY IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ONE BUT AS OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER POINTED OUT. WE HAVE
DONE MOST OF THE WORK- TO
ANTICIPATE DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES BASED UPON THINGS
LIKE FIRES AND FLOODS. BUT THIS
IS THE FIRST REAL PANDEMIC. OF
THE WE'VE HAD TO DEAL WITH AND
I THINK A HUNDRED YEARS AND
CERTAINLY. OF REDUCING. OF THE
PROCESS STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS HAS BECOME A VALUABLE
ALTHOUGH THIS DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING MORE THAN CHEN
STREAMLINE IT AND TO. I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY THERE'S
VERY LITTLE OPPOSITION BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THE CHIEF
HAVE THESE. ARE DISABILITY
INSIDE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL AND- WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU THIS
IS A NOT A- WITH ABSOLUTELY NO
OPPOSITION AND- WE AS A
LEGISLATOR- HAVE A COUPLE OF
CHOICES ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION. CONTINUE TO
ISSUE EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO BE IS
THAT WE WOULD BE DOING WHAT WE
CAN TAKE A STEP AND SET THE
FRAMEWORK. FOR OTHER BRANCHES
DOING THE WORK THAT THEY NEED
TO DO DURING EMERGENCY THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT AND I
HOUSE FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OF THE MOTION IS. TO
PAY US. THREE THIS IS A DO TO
SENATOR MOTION BY CENTER Y. QUE
SKI MADAM CHIEF WHICH LIKE TO
CALL ROLL AS SENATORS PLEASE
TURN YOUR MIKE FUNDS ON AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. THE MOTION AS DO
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
JACKSON HI X. AND I'D FORGES.
DID I SO I DRESS SO I GONZALEZ
HI I'M SALAS AYE MELINDA'S.
MORNING HI MONNING EYES STERN
BUT I. STERN AYE UMBERG HI I'M
BURKE I WAKE HOUSE SKI HI MY
CASKEY I. FOR WE HAVE SEVEN TWO
ZERO TWO MEMBERS MISSING SO
SEVEN TO ZERO WE ARE GOING TO
UPHOLD THE RULE OPEN VERY
BRIEFLY AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THOSE WHO. AND I WANNA AS YOU
LEAVE THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY. MORE TO
COME. AND THE. WE GOT UP TO
FIFTY FIVE SO WE CAN LIVE THE
CALL RIGHT RIGHT K. THE COURT.
AND SO WE'VE GOT- ALL OF THAT
WE- YOU REMEMBER FROM USING
AROUND THE FIRST ONE I MEAN THE
FIRST FIFTY. IT IS. WILL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WE NEED TO OPEN THE
ROLES FOR A NUMBER OF ITEMS. I
HAVE INDICATED THAT WE WOULD BE
DOING THIS AND WHAT WE WILL DO
IS CALL THE ROLL ONCE AND THEN
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE. CHAU HI
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO ONE MORE
TIME FOR THE RECORD HERE LET'S
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR- THE
VOTE IS EIGHT TWO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. A MOTION IS TO
PASS THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
RUSSELL BY. RUSSELL I NINE TWO
ZERO AT THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT FILE NUMBER TWO. AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN THE VOTE
COUNT IS SIX TO THE CHAIR
VOTING HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT WAS SAID TO
PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
DURACELL BY NASA I. SEVEN TWO
TWO THAT MEASURE IS OUT FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO AWAY
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. POLK
COUNTY IS SIX TWO ONE SURE
VOTING I. AM CONSOLED PLEASE
THE ABSENT MEMBERS OR DRESS.
NUMBER HI. NUMBER FIVE SEVEN
TWO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM EIGHT SHE- AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE THE VOTE COUNT IS A
TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING I SAID
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WITH THE OF THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WITH THE PASSES
MEDITATE THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MELINDA'S. HI EIGHT TWO ZERO
THAT MEASURE IS OUT FILE ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
THE VOTE IS A TWO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I'D MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WITH A DO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR MELENDEZ. EIGHT TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE THE VOTE COUNT AS
A TWO ZERO THE CHAIR VOTING HI
BUT I'M CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND AS.
EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX. THE VOTE COUNT
IS SEVEN TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING
HI BOTTOM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS THAT
WAS A TO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
BORGIAS. MELENDEZ. RIGHT
NEITHER OF THOSE MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT SO THE VOTE COUNT TO
SEVEN TWO ZERO AND THAT BILL IS
OUT I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TELL. PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE FOR ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO SUBMIT A
COMMENT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND THANK YOU TO
STAFF WHO'S HERE THAT MADE THIS
LUCKY SE IT'S NOT- BUT THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION AND THANKS TO
MY COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXTRAORDINARY WORK- THEY ARE AN
AMAZING GROUP AND I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THEIR EFFORTS.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
SERGEANTS FOR HELPING TO KEEP
THINGS RUNNING SMOOTHLY AND A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO THE TGS
STAFF WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
KEEP OUR HEARING ROOMS AND
OFFICES CLEAN SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THE PEOPLE'S
WORK IN THE MIDST OF THIS ON
PRESIDENT DID. GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
PLEASE WEAR YOUR MASKS.
SOCIALLY DISTANCE BY LEE SIX
FEET WASH YOUR HANDS REGULARLY
THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO. TO
LOWER THIS CURVE SO WE CAN ALL
GET BACK TO A NORMAL LIFE AND
GET OUR KIDS TO SCHOOL-
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS FOR THE SANITY
OF ALL OF US. AND FOR THEIR
EDUCATION AND WITH THAT WE HAVE
CONCLUDED TODAY'S AGENDA. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY IS ADJOURNED.